It went from make the thumbnail for me to he kept telling me
to suck his dick. And at that time he would tell me do your job,
you don't pay rent. And those are the words that I clearly remember
>> is that they had never
actually engaged
in traditional
intercourse.
Your fly is down. >> I was raped as a child and Hassan
had to bring that up. Hassan, we can't even we can't even sweep
for the eyes pointing in different directions in the in the pixelated
version, man.
legal mindset going over the actual transcripts. He has already
gone over the actual transcripts. Yes.
And he performed maybe the most disgusting sweep job I've ever
seen in my entire life. So, I do believe we will take a look
at this. Okay. Uh he doesn't do a whole lot of prelude before
he just gets right into it. So, what we start with is
introductions, introductions,
Okay, they talk through some stuff. Talks about how medical records
are sealed. I'm just getting to the right part, but I think we're
basically going to fire away right from the beginning. And I
watched some of it, but I didn't watch enough to really prevent
any info from being on screen. I don't I honestly don't think
it's like I'm just going to talk about this for like two seconds.
I've got a couple options here. I could wait. I could just not
cover stuff, which is maybe an option.
But I do think it's important to
have like responses to this and be able to respond to people
who are trying to spread whatever narrative he's going for. This
it now becomes clear why he went through the first day the first
you know civil case even though I I'm not sure he actually realized
it was that becomes clear why he was doing that. Okay. Because
that is going to be the basis for which Tone defends himself.
That's how he tries to defend himself here. And now the judge,
I think, just looked at that and was like, "Well, that's goofy."
Um, it's a lot of stuff to go with. So, when Pinky Chu filed
a lawsuit against Pink, Tek's ex-wife, she thought, because Teone
told her this, that Frame had been sharing around a video of
revenge for Pikachu, like that was recorded through some video
in their garage or something. And Pikachu thought that Frame
was sharing that around.
and she dropped the lawsuit. I think once it seems like once
she figured out that was not true, she dropped the lawsuit. So,
in that lawsuit, she is kind of still dating Teeone. Things are
rocky, but she's still dating Teeone. And she is like enemies
with this woman, right? And so, she's trying to say everything
that this woman is saying about Teone is false in some of her
testimony. Like, Teone didn't groom me. Teone is not like like
trying to groom me into a slave or something. There's like stuff
like this and they're like, "Well, boom, proven. Teone loved
this woman." And it's like, "Bro, there's no way you can use
the lawsuit she filed because of lies from Tee
to discredit her. That is insane."
This case has been pending, judge, since August 21st of 2025.
And it's a protective order based on assault as well as stalking
and harassment. And we'll get into the issues of what occurred,
but to give the court some background, the parties are streamers.
Foreign concept to me. I've learned more about that than in the
last couple months than I ever thought I would. They have an
immense amount of following. I think Mr. Perier at our continuence
of hearing on the extension mentioned and made the reference
to Barties being like Brad and Angelina.
Okay. Uh so you're going to hear some information about course
of control. You're going to hear that he recorded her without
her consent and acts. Was that him or was that Frame?
Because last time I checked that was actually Frame that did
that.
So again, legal mindset willing to take allegations that I believe
are doubts casted on them, cast on them in this hearing from
a civil hearing where Pinky actually withdrew that that evidence,
right? She withdrew that complaint.
She doesn't make that complaint anymore, right?
And you'll notice, by the way,
that Te's lawyer doesn't want to know whether or not that video
exists. He doesn't want to know. It will only ever be focusing
on, "Hey, um, Pikachu, could you tell me, did you think that
video existed?" Oh, well, you thought that video existed. Well,
isn't that interesting? And we'll we'll get into why he brings
that up, but he never wants to hear about whether or not the
video exists or the circumstances of it. He's always trying to
focus on what was your mindset at the time.
Uh, Andrew doing the same thing except less intelligently here,
just saying, "No, no, no, that video did exist. That video was
made. That video was a thing." Um, I can't say I know the truth
there for sure, but it is weird that Pinky would take would would
like back out of that lawsuit and stuff. >> No. Anyways,
once again, what you're into what you're into in the bedroom
>> is between you and your partner, right? If you're into
if you're into kinky stuff between you and your partner, as long
as they consent to it, >> it's fine. But, you know, the
question is, was this consensual? Right?
Uh what you're also going to hear is that the case, your honor,
is that they never actually engaged in traditional intercourse.
It was only he received there was never any reciprocation. So
they're literally making a case that that because he didn't have
sex with her,
this is abuse,
right? So I just want to make it clear here that there's an argument
here
that really the problem is they didn't
I will say that can be a I mean if you're in a relationship
if you're in a relationship relationships have kind of three
parts to the relationship. It's like a triangle, right? There's
a business part kind of like living together, working together,
you know, how you collaborate. There's communication, how you
communicate with each other. >> Uh yeah, I trust me, we're
not even remotely close. We're not even remotely close to where
this becomes infuriating. Guys, if you're already upset, we're
not even there. We're not even approaching it yet. Okay, >> there's
a element, right? Um, you know, and and there should be reciprocal
enjoyment there, but it's not necessarily illegal if one party
if one party receives more self enjoyment than the other. Right?
In addition, there was never any real kissing.
He would want to spit in her mouth and she refused. And so you're
going to hear a lot and I think you will hear judge is that my
client and the evidence will show that my client had been raped
before a pretty ugly rape in her 20s and knew what that was.
Well once again a
instance which is horrible and by the way uh whoever did that
to her should okay now an allegation you know that something
that's presented from Pikachu's side. Well I have to ask all
of these questions. Evidence from Teetone side, I am 100% supporting.
Evidence from Pikachu's side, I am 100% doubting, negating, trying
to pick apart as much as possible.
>> Punished if that that happened >> 100% of the
time. >> Um, but that doesn't necessarily make a future
partner liable for that previous
>> Why would Te not want to have sex with Pink? Is she
really ugly or something? I mean, obviously not. And you're trying
to bait me into doing the clip. Now, once we're doing this, where
it is this this discussion that we're having currently, it actually
is inappropriate to do the clip. Um, I could play the song for
you, though. Okay, we could do we could do this song.
>> Who is Pikachu? Well, maybe this song would be helpful.
So we we can do the song little meme little meme with the song
>> horrible experience which is horrible. No one should
have to go through that.
>> Um didn't understand until she got out of this relationship
how bad it was. And this is kind of the thing that, you know,
I see in a lot of the cases where we get assault claims filed
a year, two years, three years later. We saw this in the con
case, the Princeton case, um, where you have a person that does
not think they were assaulted, that knows everything was consensual,
but then they have a friend, uh, perhaps a a very, uh, activist
friend.
Why? I So the weird thing is is Andrew is basically saying something
that is true. This could happen, right? You could be convinced
that something that isn't sexual assault is sexual assault.
The obvious corlary of that is that you could be convinced that
something isn't sexual assault when it is. You could be convinced
of that in the moment. You could realize that. You could realize
you were wrong later,
right? Like it's it's very ob. I don't know why he just doesn't
seem to understand it. What is this? Physioctomy, dude. Um, so
Chud did like a censored stream. Okay.
And yeah, the the eyes are funny. Ch did a censored stream and
then this somebody grabbed this screenshot and it's like, bro,
not even we can't even we can't even sweep for the eyes pointing
in different directions in the in the pixelated version, man.
Dude, it's it's horrifying. Okay. Jesus >> Who convinces
them that they were essayed
because
they weren't because of their perspective and their So I I actually
agree that this happens too. This actually does happen. Right
now Pink is arguing that a lot of things they did were without
consent. That is her argument. Right. I was I had intercourse
without my consent. I tried to say no. I tried to say no. I was
forced multiple times.
That's the story, right?
It doesn't sound like she's saying this wasn't the story before.
It sounds like she was saying, "Well, you know, something in
the relationship made me think that
this was okay or normal."
She's not She's not describing different events. She's describing
a different mindset. Like yes, you could find out and everybody's
been in this case where you could find out that somebody's doing
something that is like, oh, you don't understand some fundamental
aspect of like relationships, fundamental aspect of anything.
It can happen in so many different ways in your day-to-day life
where somebody is just doing something wrong. They don't or they
don't understand something that most people
Um, yeah, it's it's like entirely possible. right
now. I don't think it's the same as like uh
as much as people meme, I don't think it's like some brutal thing
Tech was doing. Uh I don't even necessarily think that he
>> thought he was like doing things without consent. I
wouldn't even make that >> Reban Ruben donated $3
>> in the Cholola community. Everyone's
>> Okay. Thank you so much. Thank you so much for the Jesus
Christ. Reuben Ruben, thank you so much for the three. Appreciate
it, buddy.
Okay. Like I don't even have to say Tone did something like brutal.
Although some of these sound very brutal, right? Like he might
have thought he had some form of cons. There might have been
a
Where I tend to sort of change how I view this is after the fact
when this stuff comes to light and she describes the situation,
decides that he is going to like go sicko mode on her, right?
He makes a CNC claim at some point if I recall correctly. I'm
guessing he does that in the transcript itself. So we'll hopefully
we'll get to that. Okay. Now this is 250 pages. We're in for
a long,
>> Say in the future, hey, looking back on that, you were
actually I say you're actually a victim and we see this happen.
It's a very common pattern. Uh especially in campus cases where
you'll get people that talk and afterwards they talk to somebody
else and they convince them that that is indeed a thing. Um real
quick, the legal mind you name drop. what this reminds me of.
Yeah, exactly. Exactly. Depp versus herd. Uh, devil's absent.
>> So, you can just tell the entire stream, this is the
audience he's building, right? Is he's got Johnny Depp fans,
people who watch the Depp Heard trial and think that's like every
one of these
Um, I I just don't see how you could think that. From what I
understand, Johnny Depp was not making any of this stuff public
before he was accused, right? He was not like And even when he
was accused, I think he was mostly keeping it to the court cases.
I don't I don't remember any instances of him going out and talking
about how he was going to one day like totally destroy the person
who was accusing him of this. I don't remember that. Maybe that
did
right? And that's what colors this in a totally different way
for me is how TeeOne reacted when he found out like stuff about
Pinku. You know what I'm
Oh man, there's a uh there's a Chud clip on this earlier today.
Uh, we'll just listen to it through Chad's point of >> A
[__] place.
>> I just want the date on this one. >> Pink ain't
talk about me no more. Y'all ever notice that? Why? Why y'all
think Pink don't talk about me no more?
>> So Chad is saying this is after the court case has been
filed, after the protective order thing has been filed,
And Teone Pink is being intelligent. Pink is saying, "You know
what? I'm uh
I'm not going to talk about this case. I'm just going to file
it. I'm going to stay off social media because it's just none
of it will be good. None of it will be good.
And Teone goes, "Yo, why did she stop tweeting about me?" By
the way, now his argument in court is going to be the harm from
this is from her tweets about me. But now he goes on stream when
she decides after filing she's not going to talk about it. Why
doesn't she talk about me anymore? Why isn't she talking about
this?
Cuz she knows
she's [__]
CUZ SHE KNOWS
SHE'S FUNNY. >> HOW'S THAT working out now, Techie? >> Every
now and then this will >> How's it working out now? You
>> She does. This is what she does. All she'll do is pin.
>> Dude, this is the level of bravado people can have.
This baffles me, right?
I'm still
uh sorry, I could talk about this after. I'm not using the term
as much because
there's like something different here.
There's like a different term. Maybe is something I should use.
It upsets him, which is good. But there's something else going
on here. It's like the course of control thing that it's very
different. Okay.
Confidence is really is just a cheat code. But I think it's like
I I know this is bravado, by the way. It's not confidence. Bravado
is like totally unearned confidence, right? It's like a different
thing. But it's it's crazy to me. I feel like such a scumbag
if I try to present confidence like this when I'm not confident.
And I don't know how he was. There's no way he was actually confident
here. Right. Rape tone. I'm fine saying rape tone. There's no
way he's actually confident here.
It's just a totally false sense of bravado he's putting forward
and saying he's just trying to talk. It's so stupid, man. >> All
she'll do is pin old tweets. She won't tweet anything new cuz
she knows
Yep.
Every now and then she tweets a little kitty face.
Won't say which is >> Like he's basically just saying I'm
stalking your social media and go ahead and tweet something,
[__] Like it's just bizarre that you would do this.
It's bizarre that you would do this, man. Hold on. I'm looking
for it on uh Fil Mott right now. I just want I want this whole
thing cuz I want the date. I want everything. Give me a second.
Capture. Capture.
You beat the capture.
Oh, did he take it down? Maybe it's taken down >> because
before she had all this to talk about.
But man, Pink, if only you knew the I knew. But don't worry,
you'll find out. And what's crazy is Pink and I'm going to let
you know, I would still forgive you if you apologized
publicly. Of course, that's what's crazy. But you won't. And
it's going to be great to see what happens. But it is a shame.
>> Wait, this video is gone now. Hold on.
I know the secrets
that you hideone.
This This stream is like gone. I'm trying to find it right now.
Oh, no. It's not gone. It's not gone. Here it
>> Why couldn't I find the pink part then? Oh, it's got
a transcript and everything. What the heck? >> Why you
pink ain't talking about me? >> You're at the end. July
21st, 2025.
Okay,
so this is after
this is after she went to the police, but before she filed for
the protective order. Y'all ever notice that? Why? Why y'all
think Ping don't talk about me no
CUZ SHE KNOWS she's
cuz SHE KNOWS
SHE'S [__] YEP. Every now and then, this is what
she does. This is what she does,
>> absolutely just baffling, man. And that's why these
people just are the the worst human beings, dude. Conflict resolution
god right there. Absolutely. >> I am the conflict resolution
god.
>> Tone is actually medicated for schizophrenia. I don't
know, dude. Um, it's not what we're talking about right now.
Um, he said he wasn't medicated during his thing. Anyway, we're
going to keep reading the transcript in just a little bit, but
I don't understand how he could put on this false sense of bravado
right now. Okay. And I think this is trying to intimidate intimidate
her out. Like he's basically saying this is before the protective
order. Okay. The protective order is
uh when is it first filed?
November of 2025, right? It's got to be sorry, August. August
2025. So, it's a month before. I can see why this leads to her
filing the protective order. Oh, mama. Thanks for the
>> I don't like some of the stuff Pinky said, but also
I think the judge was harsh on Teone because of his online
>> Uh, and I said that was something that could happen.
Mama Ako, yes. I think the judge probably was harsh on Teone
because of his online response because his online response was
schizophrenic
I agree. But the judge did find it likely, right? The judge said
based on a propoundonderance of evidence, I think he she she
he actually assaulted her.
The judge did not just say TTO was stalking. I do think she was
harsher because of the stalking clearly,
but the judge did not only rule on the stalking.
So, while I do agree that probably the 10 years has a lot to
do with how
I how genuinely like depraved he was, and I don't say that in
terms of he was saying the most depraved things, although he
was saying some depraved things. I say that as in he genuinely
displayed no capacity for self-control through all of his streams
after the initial tweets and police report. Okay? He he genuinely
showed zero
capacity for self-control.
It was insane watching him just in the middle of a stream, not
about this at all, just go off on Pikachu and all of the people
going after him and how there were going to be consequences for
all of them and they'd they'd give it they'd unlock demon mode.
He was going to be a demon. I'm a demon and they've got aggro
on me now. It's this kind of stuff that for me personally, right,
I
this we were covering this, you know, months and months ago.
He's just he's wild. He's uh he's been crazy the whole time.
But if your overall point there, Mama Ako, is that you don't
believe he assaulted her? I I don't know why you would cut against
what the judge said. And I guess maybe maybe I'll figure that
out once we cover the Legal Mindset stuff. Although, Legal Mindset
seems to be focusing far more on just discrediting Pinky Chu
as a person than anything else. I guess we're going to have to
watch a little bit more. We got two and a half hours left.
All right. Thank you very much for the donation because who knows?
Absence could be the cause of >> Oh, [__] Did
I I did kind of want to watch a little bit more of this. Okay,
we'll watch just a little bit more of this one right here and
then we'll go back to the transcript >> is pin All she'll
do is pin old tweets.
>> Like this right here. All she'll do is pin old tweets.
It's like he's clearly watching. He clearly I feel like he clearly
opens her Twitter up every single day. >> She won't tweet
anything new cuz she knows she's
Every now and then she tweets a little kitty face
won't say which is weird because before she had all this to talk
about
but man pink if only you knew the I knew but don't worry you'll
find out and what's crazy is pink and I'm going to let you know
I would still forgive you if you apologized
publicly of course that's what's crazy >> wow imagine imagine
totally with somebody making their life horrible and then demanding
an apology from them. I can't imagine the kind of psychopath
that would do that. Teto must be one of a kind. There couldn't
just be like a bunch. He couldn't be a dime a dozen, right? No
way somebody else would do. No way someone would do that. That's
crazy, >> But you >> a public a public one. Of course.
>> Publicly. Of course. >> That publicly, of course.
Uh I cringe. I like physically cringe when I hear that. Uh, you
know, Pink, I would still dain to forgive you if you apologized.
Publicly, of course. Uh, publicly, of course. It's dude, like
a worm goes into my ear when I hear that. It's just
>> actually, I know, I know. And, you know, he suffers
from low testosterone. So, I mean, that's a thing. You can have
issues with ED. You know, when you have low testosterone or if
you're depressed, right, you can have issues with the ED. Um,
that's something that's very real, right? Dark Shadow Killer
44 for 5 year.
>> Oh, some There was a
It was a donation. Who knew absence could be a cause of action?
Oh, that's not it.
We didn't skip forward too much, did we?
No, we >> That was him that
>> what this reminds me of. Yeah, exactly. >> That's
he read forward cuz that is something that comes up. They talk
about tech getting medicated for
>> uh devil's absence. Who knows? Absence could be the
which by the way everybody predicted just I know we all and you
know comes essay or worse quickly. No yes that's exactly right.
>> It's always dangerous. It can be consensual as long
as the other person is into it and if they change their >> No
no this isn't this isn't it.
Um and I don't believe that's what happened here. I would say
especially if techone goes to a consensual non-consent thing.
If that's a dynamic that's brought up here. Okay. If they bring
up the consent non-consent dynamic and he doesn't have like some
strong outlines that Pinky basically can't like oppose, if they
didn't have strong guidelines for how they're going to engage
in that, then what did you think was going to happen, man? People
People do this. They watch like Fifty Shades of Gray. They go
to do this and they don't like they don't figure anything out
and they're like, "Oh, I'm shocked somebody got hurt."
So all these things you do which should be private and once again
it's not it's neither a sin nor a crime to have very
>> intercourse with your partner. You want to do cosplay,
you want to do roleplay. You want to do other stuff. It's all
right. There are certain things that are not legal. Like for
example, you can't actually assault somebody, right? You can't
like punch somebody in the in the face and call that uh consensual
because that's that's not
if you just want to do kinky stuff, right? You know, you want
to you want to do bodyw writing, whatever, that's not necessarily
illegal.
Um anyways
uh then what you will see judge is he used this platform from
time they broke up until the court signed an emergency protective
order of 25 he went on a constant rampage against on social media.
Okay so my critique of text techone is he probably shouldn't
have done that. Um and I get it you're pissed off but you know
I'll say this
I'll say >> we'll see we'll see this is the this is the
strong condemnation of >> techto I'll come out here and
say this I've got some exes I'm pretty pissed off at. Uh, I've
got I've got a couple um and I've had some stuff I'm going >> I
totally empathize with why TeeOne went off and and was this way,
but you probably should have made fewer posts. You shouldn't
have talked about it on social media, man. That's like the full
I I believe that'll be the the fullest condemnation we get. >> Personally,
I wish I could just get on a stream and I could just rail about
it and talk about it, but it's not smart. It doesn't look good
and you should not do that, right? So, that is uh calling balls
and strikes here, right? not trying to just make it. Techone
probably should have just shut up about her on the stream. Uh
that probably is what he should have done. Right. So spuring
out about it is not smart. It's not. Right. Let me call it fair
here. Once again, I'm not just sing for techone.
Did you look into any of the spuring out? Did we look into the
sping out? Are you aware of what it was? Are you aware of how
persistent it was? Are you aware of how deranged it sounded where
he basically like confesses to stalking her social media all
the time? Like once she had shut up, I Here's the thing. he didn't
want her to post about him, right? And it sounds like as we build
out this timeline, as we go along, it sounds like there's a period
in June or July
in 2025
where she may have dropped the police investigation. She might
have withdrawn from that
and she might have been willing to just go on with her life and
say, "Fuck it, I don't want to talk about this guy. I don't want
to do it. This is not worth it anymore." She might have done
that. I think there's a real significant chance
that Tee continued to be like deranged about this, blaming everybody
else's like he would get he got so deranged about it and blaming
her for it that he caused her to go file the protective order.
Right. So it's it's in August of 25 that she goes and files for
the protective order. She I think reports to the police in January
of 2025.
There's I I think there will be a period here where she stops
pursuing the criminal complaint
and then eventually he pushes her in. I think so, but I we'll
have to go through and we'll have to see. I think that's the
case.
The last hearing uh the court said, "I will caution the parties
to stay off social media especially as relates to the case and
this he should have done, right?" And Mr. Robertson that day
went and posted something about the case. That was that's stupid.
That is stupid. Uh and as so what you will see is his consistent
threats on social media wherein he has told his audience of over
a million subscribers he suffers from schizophrenia. He has delusions
at least once a month and they're not control. Well, okay. So
he's allowed to tell his audience about his mental health condition
if that's something that's out there and that's relevant, right?
He should of course be on medication for that. He should of course
be getting treatment for that. Uh I've talked about how um I
recently got diagnosed last year with bipolar disorder and I've
been working on that and it's really difficult um sometimes uh
to deal with um and that's something you should be considered
of but it doesn't give you the excuse to spur out and you should
try to keep that under control right um so he has also said that
in additional uh social media >> how do you work on that
I mean therapy and medication probably >> media posts that
he will take her down and that he will expose the truth he goes
on rampages about women etc uh which is fine. I mean, look, we've
got, you know, we've got a whole manosphere out there that rages
about women uh pretty much incessantly, right? That's >> Is
it Is it not your IS IT NOT TETO'S RIGHT to hate women? Is that
not his right as an American? >> What a lot of the internet
does. Uh it's you got to calm down about it, right? You go through
a little bit of a rage phase and then you got to calm down, >> right?
Uh that my client and evidence will show that since his protective
order has been in effect, my client has had peace for the first
time since they broke up because he has for the most part been
retained in what he's allowed to do online. And the concern is
based on his own statements to these streamers and we'll have
the videos judge that if a protective order goes away that my
client's life will turn into a nightmare again. So saying the
protective order is really to keep him shut up on the internet.
And I can see why
I god we have to go through we're going to we're going to find
everything. We're going to find every instance where he's seething
about her through all of his streams from January or November
until
like the protective order comes into place. I I hope and maybe
we'll have it all in exhibits. Maybe they'll actually all be
laid out here. But my god, it's all just
it was it was deranged. We we'd go through it and when we covered
Teone stuff, we'd laugh about like how deranged he was on his
streams, how he would just be in the middle of like gaming and
he would go on a rant about his ex ruining his life.
And it was I know what it was. It was like denims. It was denims
in almost entirely. It's like some amalgamation of Denims and
Pinky Chu is Teetone's sleep paralysis demon, right? Like Denims
would call him Rton and he would immediately like get furious
that Pinky Chu had the audacity to say anything about it. >> You
see why a judge would enter into a protective order for the sole
reason of getting him to shut up online and coming to the conclusions
that you need to come to to get that to happen. >> Right.
An activist judge, right?
Um Okay.
So my client is on the spectrum for autism and suffers from anxiety
disorder. So we've we've got a bunch of mental health conditions
here on both sides. Um it is unfortunate case and what is difficult
about it is that both part of these parties earn their living
from social media and streaming and that any effect effect that
he puts on social media and the threats they get back to her.
Uh they he knows that they can get back to her and he knows that
it can affect her business. the court will hear a little bit
of detail. >> And like the thing about this is is like
imagine you were somebody who knows Pink and you wanted to say
like, "Hey, I'm really sorry this is happening."
I don't even know how you do that without reminding her that
like Techone exists. Tech's talking about you. All of this, right?
>> I don't actually I don't know how you do
>> I can't stand him. I have my bias, but I'd like to see
if she does another crim or if he appeals.
uh he'll definitely appeal this
and I don't even know. So I don't know what you would get out
of a criminal complaint to be honest with you that isn't going
to come out of this. Like essentially a criminal complaint would
go through the same evidence and say with this evidence could
you be 99%
sure
it's basically beyond a reasonable doubt right? So it would say
would you be 99% sure that he consulted her? You will never really
almost ever and again we said this yesterday, okay? People don't
want you to know this, but if you sell somebody while in a relationship
and they don't break up with you immediately and leave, that
will never be able to be proven in court. That it just won't.
And there are tons of situations, it's a well doumented phenomenon
that people won't necessarily leave a relationship if they are
assaulted physically or sexually assaulted that they will try
to work through that. As soon as you are working through that,
as soon as you don't go to the police immediately, get a medical
court immediately, you're basically never going to be able to
prove that out, right? So, saying to me, when you say you want
to see a criminal complaint, that's basically you saying, um,
I don't want him held responsible for anything.
You could just look at this evidence and come to the like a determination
on the level of responsibility or condemnation through the evidence.
You actually don't have to find out if
like you don't have to see a criminal conviction. You don't have
to see that,
You just go through all the things that get laid out here and
come to your own determination.
I understand that's way more difficult, though. I understand
that's way more information. It's way like more difficult than
getting, you know, wrapped up in a nice package for yourself.
But we're getting something that allows you to make a better
determination than just a criminal complaint where you don't
see the evidence and you just get a guilty verdict, right? Like
you could come to your own determination on this.
Very easy to do.
details on how the online streaming works and compens >> there's
no one better going over these. Uh I think Miz was going over
them as well, but I want to talk about Andrew's reaction. Like
I want to talk about the way Tech's friends are trying to frame
this. So unfortunately, as much as there may be somebody better
going over it or in your opinion better, I actually want to watch
the person who is trying to sweep for TechOne and say why that's
stupid, right? That's my personal thing. >> Nobody has
time for that. Yeah, I understand that, Dom. That's I laugh because
like lots of people will say that they, you know, they don't
they don't find somebody credible or like when Misk was talking
about this, people go, "Oh, I don't I don't find Misk credible."
It's like, "No, you just don't want to go and watch what he's
saying. You don't want to go look through what he's saying. You're
just lazy or you're busy." Either one. But don't make it like,
"Oh, Misk's bad, so I can't listen to him." Don't talk about
that. Just say you're lazy. Just say you don't have time. That's
all you got to do. I don't have time for that. Okay, that's fine.
But it was very much she thought that if she left him all of
her social media and all the income will go away. Will this h
I don't know about that. Uh that's one that I'm I'm I'm skeptical
of. I think um okay
court will hear a little bit of the details uh how online streaming
works compensation but is very much but it was very much she
thought if she left him that all of her social media and income
would go away. Oh, this would be very important and I wonder
if we'll get any arguments on this front. Pikachu's social media
really popped after she left Tee, right?
Like she was not that big when she was with Techone.
Um her current like she found like a dynamic. She went into like
that goth
thing and like she did a whole she popped the off like after
she used to stream. She used to do a bunch of stuff. It was not
really all that popular
now she's really popular. So Andrew is going to doubt this. I
think there's reason to believe that she did derive a significant
portion of her viewership of her like fan base from Teone. Teone
was the way bigger creator at that point. >> Look, especially
for someone who has only fans and fans Lee and that's her revenue
stream. I don't think this the people that are sing for that
and on that and doing that are not going to go away, right, because
of an ex-boyfriend. In fact, they probably >> that's actually
I I feel like that's almost certainly not true that a big portion
of those people would be techone fans. And I don't know I don't
know if a lot of them would stick around if she hadn't you know
made a a huge leap forward in her business like and gotten a
way bigger fan base like she has more people following her now
than Tee has right but if she hadn't done that if she hadn't
figured out like this this new way of marketing herself
I think it's entirely possible that I think this is a reasonable
fear to have at the time >> we are going to give you more
money because they're going to feel more sympathetic towards
you right so I don't think that that all of her revenue would
go away but I can see how she'd be worried that it might affect
her image, right? Yeah. S are going to s, right? They're just
going to s and they're going to s harder. Amaranth is a good
is a good u a good bell weather for that. Ss are going to simp.
Exhibit A techone files part two. S are going to simp guys.
Oh, you got me into mythic talent. Well, I got you in this assault
civil matter. Okay, I got you, buddy. So the at the end of the
day we're asking the court to grant a protective order for the
appropriate time period the court determines under the statuto
authority in order attorney's fees in connection with the granting
of protective order. Court says all right thank you Mr. Perier
uh M said judge very briefly I think what the court is going
to hear and what the court is going to see for the document in
the documentation itself that will be offered and my expectation
that will be emitted is that the summation of relationship could
not be further from the truth. I think what you'll hear is the
applicant uh Pikachu was the one that reached out to Mr. Robertson
to begin the relationship. So that's and a romantic relationship
was begun in December of 2022 and the romantic relationship progressed
as many do and they moved in together. It's true that the applicant
never paid rent. What I think you're going to hear is that Mr.
Robertson had a male roommate who didn't pay rent either. So
he was uh he was going both ways. You could say techone was going
both ways and allowing people to live rent
>> free. I will say that you should not allow people to
live rentree in your life. That is not something you should do.
Don't do that. No rent free, you know. Um
okay.
uh and people over there on on uh >> rest as many do and
they moved in. It's true that the applicant never paid rent.
I this has gone back and forth on whether or not
what I think you're going to hear is that Oh, hold on. Is that
Mr. Robinson had a male roommate who didn't pay rent either.
Robinson has been fortunate in his finances. He makes pretty
good money.
There's never any quid proquo associated with it. Okay.
uh so what do we think is most likely
I would say on this front I'm going to cut against Pinky in this
one way. Okay.
I I don't even know if it's cutting against Pinky. What I think
happened was
was getting into like some kind of like
and he was saying, "Well, yeah, you got to pay rent. this is
how you pay rent or something. He was like talking.
I don't think he I in my mind I don't believe that he was actually
going to kick her out if she wasn't sucking him off or something,
right? I believe it was something like he was saying this during
encounters as a way of like degrading her and that it wasn't
like legitimate. That wasn't like the plan and she couldn't hear
it any other way because she so it was just became like a discuss
thing for her where she would hear it that way. Right. I I would
expect that's the case
>> again if you want to do something like >> Hold
on a second.
>> I just missed what that was. That was a fishing coat
with the primer. Thank you so much. Fishing coat.
I would give him that charity that I don't necessarily. But here's
the thing. If she's confusing that, it has to stop, right? If
she's confusing that at all, that has to stop. It can't be something
where it's confused, where she thinks this. And it sounds like
that got brought up,
right? Like that's the sign that something got really wires got
crossed, things got [__] up.
And I do wonder if there's any testimony on how he handled it
after because if she was if she was confusing that you have to
stop that cuz now you have somebody who's saying that she feels
like you are treating her like a prostitute. You are actually
controlling her in some way. You are trying to get her to do
this so she doesn't have to pay rent. Like that's not the situation
you want. So, I I guess how they handle it would would be interesting
going forward because I I could believe that. I I guess I shouldn't
say I think that I could believe it.
I actually don't really know which way to go on that, but I could
believe it if that's what it if that's going to be his argument.
Right. But it sounds like whatever non-consent like blackmailing
dynamic they had going just was communicated horribly, not understood
well by both parties. >> Uh and people over there on on
uh locals, I appreciate you guys though.
no, no subpoenas about the No, no, that's a good comment from
locals. Appreciate you guys there. Little little swear jar for
that one. Um, we'll get into I think the we'll see how many times
comes up in this in this because yeah, last time it came up way
too many times.
Um, Mr. Robertson has been fortunate in his finances. He makes
pretty good money doing what he does and is happy to accommodate
friends, romantic relationships in that way. And this is a problem.
I I I can even empathize with this because I used to be very
much like that. But when you allow people to go rentree, they
don't respect you, right? they lose respect for you. There was
never any quid proquo associated with it. Now they were certainly
intimate as people in relationships are.
Is this not like the most common? Now there's no quid proquo
associated with it. I do believe we have evidence of tee like
getting angry at her for not cleaning and not doing other stuff
because she didn't pay rent. So I think there's actually evidence
suggesting there were expectations for her not paying rent. There
was a quid proquo. Was there a quid proquo? I don't know if we'll
have solid evidence of that, but there absolutely were expectations
of him because she didn't pay rent. I believe we have that clip
somewhere. That's a there's a Denims clip on that one, right?
>> Can somebody try to find that real quick? The Denim's
clip of her talking about how
Man, it's out there somewhere. I'm almost positive it's out there
>> If you were in a relationship, you're probably doing
stuff. I I know that this is a 2020 in six or five and there's
a lot of weird assumptions, but generally, if you're in a relationship,
you're having sex. Now, there are situations where you're not
and some people have trauma, some people have other issues, some
people have uh, you know, backgrounds and you have to be considerate
of that, but typically stuff is happening of some nature. Uh,
I think what you're going to see is the evidence of the nature
of that relationship and how consensual was. It's my expectation
that you're also going to hear about a police report that was
filed in February of 2024 by the applicant against Mr. Robertson's
ex-wife, Jessica. That's free, right? And the nature of that
police report and the applicant believed that John's ex-wife
was recording them in their intimate interactions. Exactly. It
was the ex-wife that was doing the
Oh, I don't believe that to be true. I don't believe that to
be true. And I think I think Legal Mindset's probably going to
himself over here if he if he continues with that line because
I do
Oh, man. I the judge definitely tells Teeone that he has to delete
everything off of his phone after this. And I don't know if that's
just whatever these videos are,
man.
because he must understand that
Pinky explicitly said, "I was recorded without my consent. I
was recorded while I was upset, right?
I like there there's no possible conflating of the recordings
that are referred to in this civil case, the frame civil case,
and the the allegations Pinky made." >> Mazrova Obama dropping
a big 20 legal mindset memberships. Thank you for helping out.
>> Jesus Christ. >> Appreciate that. definitely appreciate
the love from all the supporters. Say thank you if you received
a a membership. Uh you're going to hear that this was the nature
of the police report and that at the point in February of 2024,
uh you know, a year and a half into the relationship,
she never made any claims about the alleged recordings containing
evidence of victimization or that they contained any evidence
of John abusing her. Further, she never made any outcry to officer
Hoffman with the Leander Police Department that she was a victim,
that she was a survivor, and that John abused her in any other
way. Further, you're going to hear that in the applicant filed
a lawsuit against the ex-wife in Williamson County. So, once
again, a year and a half into the relationship, she was not saying
that she was a victim. I think that's very relevant fact. And
the nature of the lawsuit was centered around these alleged recordings
that John's wife made that he didn't make. The wife made the
recordings, right? The wife made the recordings. Casewolf said,
"Saying it shouldn't be shouldn't be common sense." This is 226.
Common sense in the West is mostly dead. Sorry. I live in the
East where
people get laid, right? You know, I don't No, I mean it just
seems it seems normal when you're in a relationship, but thank
you for >> dude. Everybody everybody on this channel is
just like the h
it's like a spiritual sickness. Okay, >> that also
is this just legal being a techone s the whole time. Yes. The
whole time. Every single thing that works in Tech's favor at
all, he'll like extol. He'll he'll totally believe. Everything
that works against Pink, he'll like constantly
constantly um
sorry, everything that works in Pink's favor, he'll constantly
like cast out on. It's very funny. >> Uh thank you for
the 10 legal mindset, Sib. Spirit of the underachiever. Thank
you so much.
Like this one. >> In another sense, disgusting. Yes, >> I'm
glad there weren't things like smartphones or streamers when
I grew up in the 80s. I know. I know. I mean, even when I was
younger, it's just like imagine how many people would be cancelled.
It's even more. It's crazy. Uh, nobody's docked anybody's or
court documents, right?
Um, okay.
Um, all right. The wife was Frame. Somebody asked who was the
wife. Free was the wife. Pikachu was the girlfriend.
Um, you're going to hear that in this loss of the applicants,
details, lies.
Crab Navy says, "JT, these are the people who super chat. This
is why YouTube is an ecosystem is totally these are the caliber
of people who actually pay streamers."
That sounds like you kind of sweeping for yourself and the fact
that you're a broky crap navy and you can't donate. Okay, donators
are awesome. And there's, by the way, there's lots of donators
who actually have families who actually have like real lives.
I know this for a fact. Okay, I know this for a fact.
So, you're just wrong about it just being people who pay streamers.
Okay, there is unfortunately though a huge market for anyone
who's just going to take like a men's rights activist side on
anything. If you want to, if you go into any
any vertical on YouTube and you're going to try to spin it, okay,
legal analysis or [__] it, what else is there? Legal
analysis, financial analysis. If you're going to spin any of
this stuff, do like a MRA lens, you could totally make a money.
Okay, you make a of money.
Um, Andrew Wilson debate, right? Andrew Wilson with debate, taking
the the men's rights like side of it and being effective. He
made insane amounts of money. He still makes insane amounts of
money, right?
Yeah. Anyway, but there are people who donate to me that I know
they've got like uh families, they got a whole situation, they
got jobs, they live fruitful lives, okay, they just like listening
to some drama once in a while that uh been told by John's ex-wife
online, very similar to the allegation in this case. The applicant
made some bold proclamations online to her followers and followed
up with the lawsuit. You're going to hear that among the lies
that she details in the lawsuit that John's ex-wife was spreading
online was that she was John's slave.
uh that she was being groomed to be a slave. She unequivocally
states those fa those statements are lies and not true. So So
Pikachu herself stated that she was not a slave and that she
was not groomed and that it was consensual.
Okay. So one,
what does that even mean? Okay.
Does does her saying I'm not a slave or I'm not groomed? Do I
Would either of those statements actually preclude her being
assaulted?
Would they?
Obviously not. You'd have to be like here was overdosing a complete
[__] to think so, right? None of those have anything
to do with sexual assault. You'd have to be like a completely
You'd have to be subhuman to think this. Okay. And
on top of that, and I'm not even going to allege that TTO groomed
this person or was like manipulative. I I don't have to allege
that. We'll we'll go through the documents. We'll figure out
exactly what they're saying, what they agree is said was said,
all of this. Okay? But if she were groomed, if that were the
case,
then obviously she'd say she wasn't.
Now, I'm not going to I'm I'm not even opening up that can of
worms, but like the idea that somebody was saying she was groomed,
that she couldn't like she had diminished agency for some reason.
Somebody's making that claim. if she did have diminished agency,
her claim that she didn't is not proof that that wasn't the case.
Obviously, okay,
uh to put this in a terms that a lot of people would understand,
if somebody were very very drunk, right, and they have diminished
agency, they don't they don't actually they're not thinking through
their their um their decisions, their their inhibitions are far
lower, right, than they'd normally be. Somebody's very very drunk,
you can take advantage of them. If they say, "No, I'm not drunk."
Do you take them seriously?
you believe them. No, I can see that you're drunk. I can see
that you have diminished like agency right now. I can see that
you've diminished inhibitions. No, I'm not taking you seriously.
Obviously, right now, that's again, I'm not even like going down
that train of thought yet, but it's just it's crazy that he goes,
"Oh, smoking gun. It's over, guys.
It's over." No, it's not. Are you out of your mind? So, in She's
literally arguing. So, Pikachu is arguing out of both sides of
her mouth. She's arguing in her case against Freen. She's saying
it was consensual
and I'm not a
She didn't just say like it was consensual there. That's what
do you mean it was? She didn't say that in the civil case. That's
not said. You didn't read that yesterday. Oh, all of our relations
are consensual. She said I'm not groomed. I'm not a slave.
Which if she were a groom slave, she would say, but beyond that
is not proof that she was not assaulted. >> I was not groomed.
But then later on she's going to say actually now it's not was
not okay. It was non-conensual because I spoke about this later
with a friend and now I figured out this was not consensual.
Right. Uh Stocky
dude it's it's uh actually crazy. It's just obviously this these
don't entail the other. Right. One doesn't entail the other.
When she says I'm not a slave that doesn't necessarily entail
as a logical conclusion that she was not insulted.
It's just silly. It's it's 9,000 for 10. >> He has to know
this. He passed he passed law school. He passed the bar in Florida.
He has to know this. He has to be smart enough to understand
this, >> So, top of mindset know
Mudang was on her body, not giant. I may or may not watch content
high as much love. Buy hats. Hey, that's fine. I'm not judging
you for being high as it's quite legal over here in Thailand.
The cannabis. Um, but anyways, no. Mudang is not is is detached.
She's got little legs right there. Real cute. She is not attached
to the lamp. Okay. I would never attach Mudang to the lamp. Okay.
She wants to change her hat right now. So, we're going to change
her hat. All right, let's give her
let's give her a new hat. She's got a new hat now. All right,
thank you guys.
Okay, Doug Diaz, thank you for the five legal minds in
>> Palm says almost two years, huh? Time flies and eat
those arrows like fruitfly bananas. Thank you and appreciate
that. So long, almost two years. Mark XR said the whole thing
is kind of like,
oh god, Tone's SEO are all his allegations. Wait, this is envious.
This is somebody who hates techone, right? I feel like I recognize
this name from uh Gotcha Drama, which we've never covered necessarily,
but
wait. I don't know what you're talking What are you talking about
then? Full of hell. Tech's SEO or all of his allegations.
This is somebody else here. Oh, you mean like if you look up
Tee, this is at the top. I see. Never mind. I thought you were
saying Tees like his own search analytics like show this. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Okay. Okay. This is a different one.
Yeah. This is somebody you fought with. We could go over that
maybe later. Okay. >> Like a traffic
you don't want to u that can cover >> skipping donos. >> Um
in fact she characterizes the statements about being a slave
for being you know non-conentual as disgusting lies. You're going
to hear that the lawsuit was filed at the end of June in 2024
a month after the last details abuse she mentions in her application
for a protective order. So you're going to hear less than a month
after May 28 29th incident that she discloses in her application
for a protective order. She's filing this lawsuit saying the
motion that she is a slave or that she has been groomed to be
a sex slave is a disgusting lie. You're also going to hear that
she was admitted to Austin Oaks about a month after she files
for a lawsuit. This is a mental health uh institute, right? So,
she was admitted >> very important that we, you know, question
the mental health of the filant, the applicant here. Very important,
guys. >> You're going to see >> why is it important?
I don't know, but it's important. writing the intake staff at
Austin Oaks asked her about her
oh, story writer rent. Uh, Msk is going to give me the transcripts.
I actually do want to react to Andrew's reading of the transcript.
I understand that's frustrating for some people, but I do I actually
want to go and react to this >> victimization and they
asked specifically now this is this is redacted because it's
about her medical records, right? But we know she's admitted
for mental health. So, she has mental health issues going on,
which I'm sympathetic towards. I am very sympathetic towards,
right? Extremely sympathetic towards, but your own personal mental
health issue doesn't impact somebody else's guilt or innocence,
right? >> What What did he just say? >> Right. So,
she was admitted for mental health purposes. You're going to
see yourself that uh writing the intake staff at Austin Oaks
asked her about her history for victimization. And they asked
specifically, now this is this is redacted because it's about
her medical records, right? But we know she's admitted for mental
health. So she has mental health issues going on which I'm sympathetic
towards. I am very sympathetic towards, right? Extremely sympathetic
towards. But your own personal mental health issue doesn't impact
somebody else's guilt or >> Yeah. Which is why it's weird
that you keep drawing attention to it.
That's really bizarre that you just keep drawing attention to
it over and over again. That that's like your defense is look
at this. This woman's like crazy. This woman's crazy. This woman's
crazy. Look, this woman was having a really rough time. She's
like so crazy.
And you keep doing it, bro. I I'm like walking right up to the
line of saying I don't think this guy was diagnosed with anything.
I think he's literally just making this up at this point. I I
like what is what is showing any empathy here? Where is the empathy?
Where is any empathy that exists from him? He's like, "Oh, I
was diagnosed. I was really depressed, guys. I'm gonna cry and
stream about it. People make fun of me, but I don't care. We
should talk about this. Uh, by the way, we should also talk about
how how crazy this is. Like, there's no empathy for other people.
It's all for you. You have a mental health issue. Empathy for
you. And when it's a person who claims there's victimized, well,
she's actually kind of crazy, guys. Should we take her seriously?
Should we take her serious? Like, I don't know.
I don't know, man. I It's It's just bizarre to me that he's weaponizing
this stuff against her. And then he says, "Oh, well, it doesn't
actually affect anything." Sure.
Now, correct me if I'm wrong. Who's bringing this up? Is she
bringing this up and saying, "This is, you know, something we're
talking about.
It's Teton's lawyer bringing it up."
So, you brought something up that's unrelated. Tone's lawyer
is bringing up something that's unrelated and you're going, "Well,
it doesn't determine somebody else's guilt or innocence." He's
clearly hinting that because she's mentally ill, she wants to
like allege Teone did these things, right? That's what he's clearly
hinting at. obviously.
and he's doing that by saying, "Well, this doesn't affect guilt
or innocence."
It's like he's trying to build a defense while hinting that this
person's crazy and you shouldn't take it seriously, >> right?
Um 6 months being the span that covers both the allegations and
the application for the tech order, she says something and they're
going to go on more specifically and she says something, right?
This is about her mental health. Uh a period of time preceded
the interaction between the parties at all. You're going to be
able to see for yourself in writing. Um, two, my explanation
is that you're going to see the text messages, communication
between the parties. It's going to give you better context in
the >> I'm like I'm two seconds away from switching to
Misg's coverage just cuz this guy gets too many donations and
I let me see where Misg's coverage is at >> cuz I bro I
I don't know if I can do the legal mindset coverage much longer.
>> and I will show you how disgusting this is. This guy
would write >> here. I'm going to I'm going to start >> do
not post anything about Pinkchu. to not talk about anything.
And what did he do? He went and did it immediately that day.
Similar to what happened after the protective order that he was
just given that he's already talking about it. >> We're
locked in. We're locked in. >> Notion that she is to be
a slave is a disgusting lie. You're going to hear that she was
admitted to Austin Oaks about a month after she files this lawsuit
at the end of July of 2024. So what is she what they're trying
to say, chat? She's crazy and she's lying. And the reason why
she was admitted to the hospital is because she's crazy.
>> See yourself in writing that the intake staff at Austin
Oaks asked her about her history of victimization and they asked
6 months being the span that covers both of the specific allegations
in the application for protective order and she says blank. >> Trust
me, Crab Navy, we'll go back and we'll watch the other stream
as well or I will go and find the parts that I want to cover
from it. I'm not going to leave a bunch of that stuff out. Okay,
>> they go to ask her with more specifically blank and
she says blank a time period that precedes any interaction between
the parties at all. You're going to be able to see that for yourself
in writing. In addition to my ex expectation is that you're going
to see text messages, communications between the parties. It's
going to give you better context on the nature of the relationship,
one that was purely romantic, one that ran its course and one
that ended unfortunately because of the applicant.
>> so this the opening statement from
Tech >> what Teton's lawyer is trying to say is it's all
>> all it's Pinkchu. She's lying. She's manipulating this.
It was
do everything together. She never talked about this until after
the text that she tweeted and it's lies. Everything's lies. Whoa.
Big boom that is. So, it's my expectation at the end of all of
the evidence, the court is going to have no reservations denying
the application. >> Also, Crab Navy, you could find me
that time stamp if you like. I would totally I will cover a bunch
of that stuff. >> No protective order. And we're going
to ask you respectively to do so. So, they're saying no protective
order for Teone. Why? That would destroy Pinkchu. If Pinkchu
lost that, Tek would go live and just sh on her for the rest
of his life. That's what would happen.
and rightfully deserved if she was fully lying about everything,
right? I would think that's totally fair. If she was lying in
Ruin Tech's life for years, that's fair. Um, the court. All right.
Thank you, Mr. Poorier. Mrs. Lock, I I don't even like that.
And that's this just me personally. It's like I don't know what
you if she was like knowingly lying, sure, but people can have
different interpretations of events. I don't think I just I hate
this idea that like well if I don't agree with your interpretation
you're a liar who should be destroyed. I'm just not a fan. Personally
not a fan. If she was if she was knowingly lying about something
that's different but I do think that people can have different
interpretations of like especially
and I just I don't want to I don't feel like it's appropriate
to demonize either side. Transcripts are out. Yes, Matt LP transcripts
are out. Let's go. >> This is remember Pinku's lawyer.
I call my client Pingchu. All right, Pinkchu, if you please have
a seat on the witness stand, make yourself comfortable and I
will swear you in.
Go ahead.
All right. I've seen every indication that Pink wants to move
on from this, right? Teone is the person who basically says,
"Well, actually, because other people call me a now and that's
your fault, I'm going to talk about you forever." like Teeone
is it's so clear to me that this should be like there should
be a protective order here purely because of that. Like Pink
is like I'm ready to move on with this. I want to be gone. Uh
I want to be I want to move on with my life.
Tone is the one who keeps dragging it back to this. Right,
dude. Yes, she does. Oh my god. No, I man I I usually hate like
slight derails like this, but
bro, for real. For real though,
it's actually one to one.
Miz, go get her some Go get her some antenna. Okay. Holy [__]
It's like precise. Oh. Oh my god. That's crazy.
That's actually crazy.
Not talking, by the way.
Not talking. I'm not like saying she looks She looks like a Hollywood
actress. Okay. I'm But it's like it's actually crazy how close
it is.
>> Okay. So, I'm not going to lie. All right. So, Pinky
wants to get this done. to tell the court why he has relentlessly
harassed me and threatened me and threatened to ruin my life.
It's just been it's been a nightmare. I've been having to get
therapy for all of the obviously sexual assault and things he's
done and I would like to move on in my life and not have to be
consistently afraid of things he's doing or threatening me and
I just want to move on and stop being scared. Okay. In your application
for protective order, you signed a declaration. Do you recall
that? Yes. Mrs. Lock, this is the the this is Pink Choose lawyer
and judge, forgive me. I have not practiced in front of you before.
I have digital and I have paper and I don't know if you would
how would you like me to present because I've got my client who
needs to see some of the evidence and we're going to introduce
if you want me to do it electronically but I have a paper copy
for you. She says paper's fine. She's old school. Are you talking
about the actual declaration? Yes, the actual declaration. I
do have that. Well, judge, I'm going to move to introduce applicants
exhibit one which is the actual application for protective order
with the declaration that is attached there too. All right. Any
objections, Mr. Porier? Mr. Porier. No, your honor. All right.
Applicants uh one is admitted.
Mrs. Lock, uh Pinchu, that is the applicant that you in fact
filed. Is that correct? Application you filed. Yes. All right.
Can you turn to the page where your decoration starts, which
is I can help you with that. Page five. Yes. All right. When
did you Let's give the court a little bit of your background.
What is it that you did at the time for a living when you met
Mr. Robertson? At the time, I was a fairly small streamer and
I did GTA roleplay online. So like voice acting and storytelling
with other >> What is GTA? Grand Theft Auto. Okay. And
when you uh and you say when you were a small a little small
streamer, can you qualify quantify that for the court in terms
of what a large streamer versus small streamer is? Pink. >> So
around December of 2022 is where she
where she starts um dating Technone, right? December of 2022,
right? She start Well, she starts dating him in December of 2022.
So she's got some like she was she got a little bigger here.
She almost got up to a thousand concurrents at some point here
and then she kind of stopped streaming as much was down here
in 2022. So she met him. She was like a couple hundred viewers.
All right. At that time couple hundred viewers after she met
Tech or around the time she met Teone. Go back. How how much
bigger was she? No, was this is her biggest peak. Okay. All right.
So the where she meets him is right here in this like uh downward
bit right here. Okay. Just for for context, very important. >> A
large streamer would have around 5,000 viewers consistently.
Mine was around maybe 200, but I think at the time I had less
than 100,000 followers. I'm sorry, like 500. By 500, do you mean
500,000 followers? Sorry. Sorry. Less than 100,000 at the time
on Twitch. At the time you met Mr. Robertson, how many And they're
called followers. Is that correct? Yes. How many did he have
at the time he you met him? I think almost 1 million. Damn. All
right. And what is it that Mr. Robertson did at the time that
you met him. He would play go t you games. What?
>> Caught you. A gotcha. Gotcha. So >> gotcha. Gotcha
games which is Chinese gambling games like the anime girls and
characters like that. Okay. And is that how Mr. How did Mr. Robinson
earn income at the time to the best of your knowledge? I believe
he was >> Oh, Vane. I pull I pulled this tweet out >> making
$100,000 a month and that was from doing what in particular if
you know he was streaming the games and then he was also part
of the very large gaming organization called one true king
>> they had basically all the largest streamers in Austin
and you know like they had a lot of control over the space true
okay and just because >> damn the Midas guy already responded
I quote tweeted that guy already responded let's go let's go
>> I don't know is Austin a large market for streamers
it has a large market for some of the largest streamers Okay.
And what are some And this is uh it's OTK, correct? Yes. All
right. And was Mr. Robertson a member of OTK? >> Is that
Drake? On a side note, >> you a member of OTK, Miss Bingch?
Absolutely not. >> Okay. Why not? I was way too small.
A nobody in that sense. Okay. The people that were belong to
OTK, she also wasn't Asian. How many followers did those >> crazy
man? >> Millions. Millions. >> Also, we're going
through stuff. This is like boiler plate. We all know >> Robertson
at that level of millions. I believe he was on his way. We'll
wait until we get to something substantial to
>> when how did you meet Mr. Robertson? My I had a friend
that recommended I reached out to him because we were supposed
to I guess have some lunch thing and he's like he's also like
anime you know uh you should reach out. He seems really cool
and so I reached out on Twitter and he wanted to hang out right
away and we began a friendship.
Okay. And you heard opposing council indicate that you have pursued
him and wanted to get into the relationship with Mr. Robertson.
Was that accurate? No. All right. Tell the court what is the
accurate version of that of you all getting together. This is
about techone by the way.
I told him I do not want to date at the time. I would never date
a streamer. That's why I currently on online dating apps because
I just wanted uh to date a little bit outside. I tried talking
to somebody in the streaming space. I wasn't really sure about
it. And he then had me sit in the his bathroom one time and he
had like a very emotional conversation and kind of used that
as his leverage to, you know, convince me to try dating him.
Dude, how did it go? >> Oh, this is going to be funny as
Oh, also when you get into like coercive control, when you get
into like here's the thing you have to watch for, okay, Tone
is manipulative as like naturally. He's just always manipulating.
It's like um probably a lot of people do this a lot of the time,
but you will find little things like this where you hear,
it's all of this leads me in a direction to think there was some
amount of like coercive control going on because he just does
this stuff all the time. Listen to this story. I fully believe
it. It just it goes along with how he acts. It goes along with
this became obvious to me when he did the thing where he was
basically like I was raped as a child and Hassan had to bring
that up Hassan and he was like crying and he's like doing all
this and then he ends he like snaps his fingers is totally done
crying throws a grape in his mouth but you know what I'm just
going to keep farming Hassan I'm just going to keep farming the
[__] out of him right as soon as I saw that session
that like crying session into snaps out of it and immediately
like I'm going to keep farming I'm like, "Bro, this guy's psychotic.
This guy's a total psycho."
We should watch that that clip again. >> From convincing
you to date a game to you moving. >> So manipulative, man.
It's crazy. >> Together with him, >> he told me,
he said, "I could change your life forever." >> It was
a good point. >> I'm an OTK. I have connections. You should
just move in with me. You won't have to pay rent and I will help
you and you try to help me. He's like, "I'll get you. Here's
some vitamins." And was like, "I'll change your life and we'll
get you better." And kept telling me he's going to change my
career.
Okay. Is it a big deal to be belonging in OTK? Absolutely. It's
huge. Okay. Just so the court understands why is that? Because
they have a pretty much control in Austin to make and break your
career. Mostly break. Whether you get invited to collaborations
or get sponsorships, they have control and the owners own one
of the largest management companies that I was also part of at
the time or he got me into because he was the other promise he
said he could do.
Okay. And do you know what Mr. Robertson's role in OTK was? He
was a core member. And what is that? Uh core member. What's a
core? What does that mean? Well, just like the main members like
uh that represent the organization.
Okay. So, what was your understanding of the authority that Mr.
Robertson had within OTK? Like he got invited to everything.
He could get into your parties. He could get you into collaborations.
And then obvious
>> so like to me it's just wild that
somebody would basically go he like finds Pikachu and he's like
listen I could make you a star. Okay. It's like the it's the
Ice Diddy, right? Don't you want to be a star, man? Imagine how
big you could be if you dated me. Imagine how big you could be.
Uh [__] >> He was working with mythic. I
if this didn't in my mind line up with like everything I've sensed
about Teone over time, the way he is manipulative, all of the
fights he's been in where he talks about how he did nothing wrong
and these people all just betrayed him. If if it didn't all line
up to me, I would be more suspect of some of these things. I
would want like like it just it dude it lines up so well >> talent
and could get you into mythic >> I'm trying not to let
it affect me too much. It lines up very well though. >> And
that's huge if you're wanting to get money and sponsorships.
Okay. So, what is Mythic Talent? It is I believe Mr. Robertson
has part of or some of the ownership in it and another member
owns it. It's like a management media management where they manage
creators and give sponsorships and collaborations.
Uh example is Tectton got the angry lawyer whatever his name
is uh
in it. Techone got a lot of people in Mythic Town. I will say
that he got a lot of people in it. A lot of YouTubers, a lot
of people. Tech was getting a lot of people in Mythic Town.
And what promises, if any, did Mr. Robertson make to you about
your career if you moved in with him? He said he could come on
my stream like it would be a good dynamic, you know, having a
what he explained to me having a hot cosplay girl living in his
house. And what was the arrangement that you had before you moved
in with regards to rent? I would help him with some thumbnails.
So, in my assumption, it was just be helping him because I do
graphic design and media. So, I like make his thumbnails and
edited some things for him. Just so the court understands, so
the record is clear. What are thumbnails?
So when he posts things like YouTube videos, like I'd go into
Photoshop and create a graphics design for him. Okay. And at
some point did the arrangement for rent change? It changed after
we moved into Chestnut Ridge. Okay. And what changed? It went
from make this thumbnail for me to he kept telling me do your
job and you don't pay rent. And those are the words I clearly
remember. Okay. And >> wait, there hold on. There is an
actual angry lawyer, right? Isn't there? He's not just talking
about legal mindset, right? She wasn't just saying the angry
lawyers in legal mindset. I think there's an actual angry lawyer
>> after and Chestnut was in Austin, Texas. Is that correct?
Yes. And how soon after you moved into Chestnut Address? Did
>> skipped a lot? >> Okay. And how soon
after and Chestnut was in Austin, Texas? Is that correct? Yes.
And how soon after you moved into Chestnut Address
did those activities start occurring with Mr. Robertson? >> Pretty
much right away. He I didn't have any inclination of like issues
until we moved into that home.
>> Okay. How soon after you moved into uh did those issues
begin? Pretty right away. I think once he had said that in particular,
I was disgusted. And then told him I wanted to pay rent. And
that's why soon after towards the end, I I believe it was the
end of February, I started paying rent. I gave him $1,000. I
said I didn't like this dynamic. It made me feel disgusting.
Okay. Um you Okay. Hold on. Hold on. This is actually really
important that we get this down. Okay. So they move into a new
place in this is February
and she says I don't like this dynamic the thing that you said
here I I don't like this dynamic
oh and what would have been of 2023 2024 2023 you're right okay
so he made that demand then you said no and started paying rent
yes all right wait what
no previous page >> yeah previous page line >> I
can't read I have literally been reading just chat not a big
deal we're good might have been. >> Okay, hold on. Let's
go. Let's go back to it here. >> Let's we'll we'll jump
back to it really quickly. Okay,
so hold on. This page right here. It went from make the thumbnail
for me to he kept telling me to suck his dick. And at that time,
he would tell me do your job, you don't pay rent. And those are
the words that I clearly remember. Okay,
again, the other thing about this is, and I don't know if they
bring this up, but they should bring it up. I'm almost positive
that Tetone talked about how the place was like a pigsty and
things wasn't weren't getting cleaned up. There's a whole denim
stream on this. I do need to find I think I think somebody sent
it to me. Okay, so it wasn't just that she lived there for free
or anything like Teone did expect things from her. I'm almost
positive. Asking that you don't feel comfortable doing something
when he records you demands you stop making faces and pretend
to like it or you say you don't want to do it anymore. Shoves
your head down till you throw up. Guilt trips you into giving
him and says, "Do your job because you don't pay rent. I took
you to a water park. You owe me, so all you can do is sleep."
>> None of these none of these are the clip, though. None
of these are the clip. There is a clip specifically on this and
we will find it if I have to go find it myself. If if nobody
else remembers this, I'm the only one. I will find it. It's him
talking about like how his place is a mess and Pink wasn't cleaning
up. I know when Pink originally came out the allegations, this
was something that popped up. And I do want to find it because
it is important to show that it wasn't just like, "Oh, you live
here for free." There was some quid proquo. He was admitting
to some quid proquo. He had expectations. And so when he says,
"This is a part of your job." It doesn't shock me because he'd
used that to try to get her to clean up before as well. >> Yes.
And how soon after you moved into chestnut address did that did
those activities start occurring with Mr. Robertson? Pretty much
right away. He I didn't have any inclination of like issues until
we moved into that home. Okay. How soon after you moved into
uh did those issues begin? Pretty right away. I think once he
had said that in particular, I was disgusted and then told him
I wanted to pay rent. And that's why soon after towards the end,
I I believe it was the end of February, I started paying rent.
I gave him $1,000. I said I didn't like this dynamic. It made
me feel disgusting.
Okay. Um you skipped a line.
What line did I skip? was actually kind of an important line
he missed. Right. The thing about the dick ducking >> kind
of a consequential line, man.
>> Oh, and what would have been of 2023, 2024? 2023. You're
right. Okay. So, he made that demand, then you said no and started
paying rent. Yes. All right. Wait, what?
No. Previous page.
Dude can't read. I have literally been reading. Just chat. Not
a big deal. We're good. You understand the premise? Okay. And
so, he made that demand. Then you said no and you started paying
rent. Yes. Wait, the dick [__] part. I missed that.
Oh, >> it went from make this thumbnail to me to he kept
telling me to suck his >> consequential line. He would
tell me, "Do your job. You don't pay rent." And those are the
words I clearly remember. Oh my god, I missed that line. Are
you kidding me? >> Okay. And he made that demand. Then
you said no and started paying rent. Yes. All right. Did you
start paying rent? Can you call when? I believe it was February
2023. Okay. And did you consistently pay rent until you moved
out of the residence? Yes. It wasn't consistent. He changed pricing
a lot. Okay. What was the highest amount you paid Tim? $4,000.
$4,000.
>> That's not That can't be right. Right. >> What?
I made my roommate chat pay $1,000 a month. You know why I made
them pay $1,000 a month of rent? It was because of insurance
reasons because uh I don't remember what it was, but SK told
me I need to charge them something so that way it's not a liability
on me uh if something happens. So, we had to charge them. So,
we charged Russell, Emmy, Simply, Corey, you name it, $1,000
a month rent. And they had maids come every single weekend. >> Basically
free. Yes, it was. I barely charged them rent. $1,000 for rent
is nothing. Uh it that included internet, that included electricity,
that included gas, that was everything included. And but also
included a bathroom inside your apartment. Um that's why Maya
paid. Yes, that is why Maya paid rent. Maya paid rent because
one, Maya wanted to pay rent from what I remember and two uh
Maya was very self like she wanted to do stuff. She wasn't like
she never like took, she would give, if that makes sense. She
would. She paid rent because she wanted to pay rent. Um, and
it was $1,000 a month. >> Hold on. This is these are the
sets of clips here. Hold on. Give me a second. >> She never
paid rent. She said that Teone told her that since you don't
pay rent, you have to pay me back in these other ways. And then
we literally saw a video of him doing exactly that. >> [__]
[__] >> She never said that she never paid
rent. She said that he said she never paid rent. um is that the
garbage the garbage has not been taken out uh in seven days.
It's Pink's responsibility and the reality is that she's in my
house role playing as a goth Hooters order orderer waitress and
honestly it's really annoying because the reality is she doesn't
pay rent. The reality is she doesn't paying rent. She's not doing
her
>> Tech's thoughts on living with Pink Chew. Teone's thoughts
on living with Pink Chew. >> I charge him $1,000 a month.
Just let you guys understand what I was charging $4,000. I've
been to Tekone's house. Dude, Tone's house is not $4,000 a month
to rent, just to let you understand. So, let's understand this.
What are the circumstances that he raised your rent from $1,000
to $4,000? Some of you guys are asking why I didn't charge them
more rent. Um, the reason why is they did help me a lot with
my content. Russell would constantly come in my room. Simply
would constantly come in my room. Cory, I was just trying to
help cuz he's my close friend for 15 years. Um, and Emmy and
I were obviously dating and I also didn't really care for the
money. It wasn't that big of a deal to me. Like, whatever. What
am I going to charge Russell $2,000? And that really him, but
it doesn't do anything for me. It's not fair. Um, so I didn't
charge him extra money. Uh, and Lucari, I believe, never paid
rent in the 12 months or year that he was there. I don't think
he ever paid rent once. Um, let's continue. What were the circumstances
that he raised your rent from $1,000 to $4,000? He told me I
would be moving in to the next home and started having me pay
double rent when I started making more money.
Were there any demands for tax when that rent went up as well?
I believe at the time it was more of an obligation. Whoa.
Can you describe what you mean for that to the court? Like for
example, after I had my breast surgery and I couldn't like do
it for him, he would get very upset because I had to lay up straight.
Am I allowed to talk about that situation? So let's we'll talk
about that in just a second. Sorry, I was So hang on just one
second. You suffer from what? Anxiety.
>> So a quota. It it sounds like So it sounds basically
like this. Tectone wouldn't, you know, demand directly, but he
would ask for and if she said no, he'd get like super he'd make
it like a both of their problem, right? That's that's like another
form of I don't want to have this direct conversation about how
much we're having sex. So, I'm just going to be a [__]
When you say no, I don't want to right now. I'm just going to
be a whiny. I'm going to like throw tantrums. I'm going to I'm
going to be upset. And so eventually the the people with you
who are especially if they're, you know, uh, what would you say?
Like they don't want to get in confrontation. They don't want
to have you be upset. They'll like start doing it out of what
they feel is like obligation. Okay. Well, I he's just going to
lose it. I guess he's going to get super mad if I don't do this,
so I guess we'll just do it. Now,
that wouldn't necessarily be just speaks to a lot of the um the
course of control stuff, right? >> Is that it, Pinku? Yes.
Okay. And you were also is it on the >> Yeah, it really
is like a lot of classic victim abuser things that that are like
going on here. And
again,
it's like how much is Techone aware of this or how much of it
is malad mal adaptation? I'm not sure. But a lot of this stuff
is already bad. And a lot of people like, you know, Legal Mindset
would see this and he'd go, "Wait, so you like did this out of
obligation? So that means you did consent to it?" And she'd probably
say like, "I didn't say no. it he would have no problem with
this and it's like this dude that's how abusers work man >> spectrum
you are yes all right so when you were talk taking breaths you
were trying to calm yourself down is that right yes okay so let's
talk about what happened with when did you get your breast augmentation
I believe I did in late of 2023 and then I had to get it redone
in 2024 earlier in 2024 all right and in August of 2023 was that
the incident you were just talking about yes it was in May of
2024 okay so it was after your revision This was the revision
part that this incident occurred. Okay. So, May of 2024, tell
the court what exactly happened.
>> Revision. Okay. May of 2024. This will be the This is
moving ahead in the timeline from February 2023 to May of >> I
was lying in bed and I, you know, my doctor told me that I had
to sit up straight. Like I couldn't lie down or the side of anything
because I still had stitches and I was still taking heavy medication
and he was getting very unruly like and upset that I couldn't
give him a during my healing period. Okay. So, when you said
he would get upset and unruly, can you describe for the court
what he would actually do? He'd be like, "So,
>> you think you can suck my dick or he was just very He
seems very >> It's exactly what I said. He'd just be super
he would just like start throwing tantrum. He'd just be like
an angsty >> Annoyed, I guess, is a good word for it. Very
annoyed.
>> Did you consent to him doing that?" No, I told him I
can't. I think after that point, I think he was just kind of
in shock. Like I think there's just some circumstances that I
can that I say no and I'd assume that's enough to say no that
I can't. Did you cause did it cause you any physical pain that
incident? I was under a lot of medication but I think I was just
scared that it was going to mess up any of these stitches I currently
had healing. Okay. Have there been another incident like that
before where you had some kind of cosmetic procedure and he required
you to do the same action? Yes. Okay. What was it if you can
recall? Do you mind if I look? You have an affidavit. Thank you.
It's been introduced into evidence if you need to review that.
Okay. I can't recall. I think the last incident. I got it mixed
up with the date because I read the date. Okay. So, I believe
this was one in May. Okay. So, May of what? 2024. All right.
So, what happened in May of 2024? Pingchu. >> This is the
lip filler. >> I just had my lips done. They were very
swollen and painful. Like, you could still see the injection
sites. And he asked me to suck his and I said no. That it would
ruin my lip injection. >> Funny because this is like a
million times worse than anything Miz has been accused of. Yes.
Obviously. So, right. Like, it's crazy. that Teeone knew and
I think he absolutely knew exactly what her allegations would
be, right? Like he knew exactly the situations when she was talking
about them, what those allegations would be. And Teone felt it
appropriate for him to go and comment on Misk's allegations,
which are nothing like this at all. There's no non-consentual
element. There's no like um please don't no stop. No, no, don't
do that. No, I can't do that. And then he pushes forward through
it. There's no there isn't even an allegation of this. Okay?
is because, you know, I can't imagine how harrowing this was
for um for Pink to go and describe here. I'm sure she I'm sure
this is difficult.
I'm sure this is difficult, but you should read the whole thing.
I think he just skipped it. Seemed like he skipped a bunch. She
just got her lips done. They're very swollen and painful. Oh,
hold on. Did he skip it?
>> Like that all big and fat. And I'm like, I can't because
it's going to mess up my >> Oh, no. Maybe not. Because
this happened when we were lying in bed. He put my face and he
made me suck his dick.
Okay. When you say that he made you
>> Oh, no. I Sorry. He got the whole thing. He got the
whole thing. >> He described to the court the action he
took to force you to do so. He grabbed the back of my head and
slowly put it towards his dick and told me to open my mouth and
suck his dick. >> Okay. And he told also made public comments
about this as well that I believe I have in my timeline. If someone
would like to link the YouTube video of Techone literally saying
he basically learned from uh learned from something where he
was got got his dick stuck with lip filler that they're not good,
I will show that uh present that to you guys right now. And then
he also made public comments about this as well that I believe
are in my timeline. Okay, we'll get to the public comments in
a minute. Did you end up having issues with your lip filler after
this incident? Yes. So, because he did this, it did migrate and
I complained to him multiple times afterwards that what he did
caused the migration and he's like, "Oh, it doesn't look that
bad. It's not a big deal." Is what he would say. And what did
you have to done if anything to correct that? I had to get them
dissolved and then fixed. Let's talk a little bit about the relationship.
Did >> Okay, so Teone acknowledged himself that he was
at fault here, right? And I do wonder if he would say that he
doesn't remember this or doesn't know about it cuz that seems
pretty important to me that she blamed him directly. And if she
was blaming him directly to his face, I do believe it seems likely
to me that she would have had she would have said the same thing
to her surgeon that he was forceful about this that like, you
know, I told him not to and he was forceful. I I wouldn't be
shocked if she actually said this to her surgeon. Okay. >> Did
you have your own room at the >> Very interesting. Grab
that talked about there. And this is why Tee is the biggest [__]
of all Babylon is because Teone can't shut the up. And literally
right there, he thought he was being discreet, but he doesn't
understand that in court, you can still use that against him
if it's obvious about the relationship that it is. Just like
when
>> yeah, it also Yeah. Hold on. It does it does lend a
lot of credence to her story, right? Obviously. So, did he admit
to No, he's saying he's basically admitting that this story very
likely happened. It would be about the consent of the story,
right? Would be where there would be contention.
But he's obviously saying that this happened. >> Obviously
was tweeting about Techone. They use that in court. You can obviously
refer to that as Pink Jew. And that's exactly what he did. He
incriminated himself when he thought that those things can't
be used against him because he thought that, oh, I'm not going
to mention her name. >> Just wait for your time, little
pup. Please enlighten me how any of this can refrain to me. I
would like to uh one, call me Lil Gup. Uh would be insanity.
Um calling me little Gup. Uh I guess you probably watch uh >> just
wait for your time, Lil Gup. >> Two, uh where is this in
my timeline at all? because my uh ex went public with all her
information and none of this was said at all. Uh she literally
went over with her lawyer and had it prepared for months. None
of this was said. So, I would like to be very I'm curious on
where you think any of this revolves around me. Lil Pop,
>> I'm sorry I doubted you, miss. It's okay, bro. It's
okay. Um I totally understand how the industry works. I understand
how streaming works. It's very tough to really understand the
information uh and understand these people, but I'm glad that
people are understanding that I wasn't the bad guy and that I'm
not the >> Yeah. If you guys real quick, he's doing his
thing about the emir thing. Okay, with this and the the Ultra
Zinus, this is the rule they put in is like if you use Zionist
with like um the name of an animal or something, that is supposed
to be a ban. Dan complained about it. Twitch doesn't want to
run a foul of the ADL, so they do have to ban Hassan for this.
Okay, now we'll see how long they ban him for because I don't
know, personally, I'm not sure Hassan will ever be able to work
that out of his vocabulary. And he could s he could virtue signal
so hard on this and get so many viewers for it, right? Oh, look
at the ADL censorship again. ADL censorship, I guess, because
when they got this rule passed, there was a little more of an
equal footing on the Israel question on like Israel's campaign
in Gaza. All right.
There was there was equal footing. Now, Israel looks totally
psychotic. It looks like Hassan totally won on that. And you're
basically going, "Hey, this guy, when he complains about like
all of the murder that's happening in Gaza, could you please
um could we use the ADL to shut this down? Could we use the ADL
to shut down this guy complaining about the murder in Gaza?"
That's how it looks. Okay, that's how it looks to the whole world.
And I
I do think it's actually kind of they don't understand what they're
doing when they when they do this. But hey, you know, keep
buy Tik Tok, censor all Israel
get the ADL to censor Israel criticism on Twitch. It's all This
is all looking really good, guys. This is a good look. It's a
good look overall. >> This massive piece of And this is
what really is. This is what real crimes are. These are the people
that need to be put out there and shown the realities of them.
Uh and coincidentally, these are the people that attack me >> the
most.
Let's keep going.
And what did you have done, if anything, to correct that? I had
to get them dissolved and then fixed. Let's talk a little bit
about the relationship. Did you have your own room at the residence?
I was paying for one room and because the other roommate he would
complain that the other roommate wasn't paying rent all the time.
He told me for so I offered to pay him for another room to help
pay for the rent because he complained about money a lot. Why
was he complaining about money? Probably because he owed me $300,000
and he didn't know how to pay it back. And when I say he didn't
know how to pay it back, I meant the guy literally just used
PayPal, lost about 10% on fees like a and was struggling with
paying me back because he's a [__] Uh he could have
literally just wired Synak instead. He just used PayPal fees
and gave Elon Musk an extra 30 grand. An actual [__]
Okay. So, did you all, I guess, uh, cohabitate in the same bedroom?
Yes. He had me sleep with him a lot because he always mentioned
that with his schizophrenia, he was afraid to sleep alone and
I felt guilty and bad if I didn't. Okay. >> Oh, that's
You always mentioned that with his schizophrenia, he was afraid
to sleep alone and I felt guilty and bad if I didn't. Okay. >> He
had admitted to you that he's schizophrenic. Yes. And publicly.
Okay. He's actually done so his on his streams, correct? Yes.
Do you know if at all what medication he takes for his schizophrenia,
which is a really serious thing to have, Chad? If you have schizophrenia,
get medicated. It is a very serious thing. You have an alternate
reality of what things are. You need to get medicated. It's not
a joke. You know, schizophrenia is a superpower. You don't need
to take your medication. It is the government trying to control
you, trying to prevent an uprising of mutants like you. You are
basically Professor Xavier from X-Men. You have mental powers.
Do not let them deny you your mental powers. Okay? Do not take
them. Don't take the meds. NEVER TAKE THE MEDS. >> UM,
that's that is not >> Also, those voices are actually inside
of your walls. And the bugs are actually
medication for schizophrenia. You should, especially if it's
serious schizophrenia like Tekone claims he has. You should be
seeing a doctor. You should be taking your medications that your
doctor prescribes. Let's see what Tone did with his really serious
schizophrenia that he one time almost Jimmy here because he thought
a tree was talking or something. Let's see. Did you know at all
what medications he took for his schizophrenia? allegedly, by
the way, he said he used to take them when he was younger and
he didn't like that. I guess it didn't make him himself, so he
stopped taking them. And are you aware, and this goes back to
when you were living together, was he taking any medication that
you're aware of for his schizophrenia? No. Okay. Did you ever
have him did you ever see him have any
>> Now, I will say we're talking through this
with regards to Tecton
I don't know. So, where will it become relevant? It will become
relevant right here where he's like trying to get the he's trying
to get her to sleep with them because of the schizophrenia, right?
Sleep in the same bed. Not necessarily, but because of the schizophrenia.
I'm guessing
we'll have to hear about the episodes and we'll have to hear
what exactly. But I'm thinking in terms of the allegations, unless
she wants to say that this contributed, I'm not sure how relevant
this is. I'm guessing at some point when you're making requests
for like medical records, they are both aware that the each other
will be painting, you know, they'll paint. Sorry. She'll know
that Tetone got her medical records to try to paint her a certain
way. They might be just trying to do the same thing. I'm not
a fan of this. I I do think it's gross personally.
Um, we'll see how this becomes relevant as it unfolds. They're
going to what they're driving. I'm not totally described for
the court what it was like when he would have a schizophrenic
episode. He mentioned one time he was driving with his friend
Jimmy and he almost crashed his car because he saw something.
>> Yeah, sorry. That's what I'm saying. ADHD runs runs
me is um
Oh, hold on. Wait, who made this joke? Did we hear about this
from a Miz stream? Somebody joked about uh Pikachu's face melting.
Maybe Miz wrote that down. I thought he was like memeing about
that. No, it actually is a thing,
bro. What?
Dude, the that's going to get crazy with the the memes. Okay.
Face is melting and
>> Can you describe for the court what it was like he would
have a schizophrenic episode? He mentioned one time he was driving
with his friend Jimmy and he almost crashed his car because he
saw somebody behind him. I guess speaking to him because he sees
people walking around as well as he would get scared because
he said he'd see versions of myself giving myself around the
house.
versions of you. Yes. And then my face would be melt, >> dude.
This is
I'm sorry.
Why would Why are people living with this guy? What the [__]
I'm
Man, there's a couple different things here. Okay, there's
there's a couple different things going on here. Okay,
schizophrenics have a hard time like judging reality and speaking
consistently. And there are a lot of problems associated. I do
not believe he has full full-blown schizophrenia.
I just can't see it. Schizophrenics do not function in society
normally without medication. Um, you can kind of get it into
remission with medication, but I feel like people slip in and
out of it. And Teton's been an incredibly consistent content
creator for a long time. I think this is like the longest break
he's ever taken.
I really
I really don't know.
like he might have um delusions, he might have hallucinations.
I don't know if it could possibly be full-blown schizophrenia
because I just can't see him having been like a full-on content
creator this much, right? Like to this level. It just wouldn't
make sense.
I don't understand how you live with somebody who's describing
these things to you and you're like okay with that situation.
Like this guy's having violent episodes where he almost like
runs somebody over, right?
He's having like violent episodes.
How in the world
is everybody okay with this? I'm very shocked that he's got like
a male roommate, too. >> Thing when he looked at me and
it would scare him. Okay. He never went and sought psychiatric
care to the best of your knowledge. No, I tried to tell him many
times, especially because he told me almost he almost crashed
his car and had a lot of those issues where he consistently was
afraid or paranoid.
So, this is the guy that also attacked me for driving fast with
Emmy. Keep that in mind. Did you all in your relationship ever
have traditional like?
>> Okay. Why not? He told me because of trauma. He mentioned
his ex-wife. >> POV POV Teone going for a cruise. POV Techone
going for a cruise.
Why is the frame rate so bad on this? What the?
This is just tone on like a Sunday night drive. A Sunday evening
drive. Okay. Sky's like melting.
He's just like, you know what? I'm going to keep driving. I'm
going to keep I'm going to keep going. Everything's fine. At least
Rust isn't driving here, man.
I Is this slowed down? No. I don't know what's wrong with the
scene. I turned the volume off. Jesus. But I don't know if I
can go into that. Well, there's an NDA related to that particular
lawsuit, correct? Yes. He had her sign.
Uh, did you all in your relationship ever have traditional like?
No. Okay, why not? Told me because of trauma. Then he mentioned
his ex-wife, but I don't know if I can go into that. Well, there's
an NDA related to that particular. Okay. Okay. So, we won't talk
about the details of that, but what else did he tell you about
and what did he not engage in traditional intercourse with you?
He said his sister him when he was younger and he consistently
told me he was disgusted by the
>> So I do think this is basically
I we deduce this from what by the you can deduce this from what
he said publicly just so we're clear, right? As much as this
is like sens a sensitive topic. >> Okay. And did you all
ever like kiss like a normal relationship? We did hug a lot but
he was not a fan of kissing because he said he had a lot of he
would get a lot of saliva in his mouth. That's what so consistently
anyone who knows him uh knows him and that he would uh spits
all the time when he walks around. And what did he ask you to
do instead of the traditional kissing? Multiple times he would
ask if you could spit in my mouth. And what was your response
to him asking you to spit in his mouth? I would personally have
a disgust for like spit stuff myself. All right. So were there
any interactions where he was physical with you to engage in
relation that would make you happy? Never. And so
>> he never did he ever have his hands ever touched you
physically under your pants? No, not under my pants. No,
>> bro. What?
that's crazy.
Bro, what?
No. Okay. So, I'm sorry to be explicit, but his hands never touched
your in two years of dating. Is that right? No. >> I'm
sorry.
Matt. I It's tough because of the thing, which could be a thing.
I Is there any real reason to think that this guy isn't just
gay and like closeted and like self-hating?
Like he I've heard him talk more about kissing his random guy
friend and how their beards mashed together and [__]
was giving him. How often would he record you during those? I
would say about 40% of the time.
Okay. Did he do so with your consent? There was I could say maybe
two or three times where he asked and it got to the point where
I just didn't ask. I there were times where I didn't like it
and I would squint my eyes and he would get upset and delete
the recording and then start the recording and he's like, "I
need you to open your eyes. Make noises. Stick your tongue out."
I I don't want to do it, but like make a huffing like moaning
noises and look at the camera and look like you like it is what
he would tell me when he would record >> That's crazy.
And did he do any >> Yeah, Liberal Texas. Hold on. Maybe
I can um can I pin something in the chat that just says, "Yeah,
we know Husan got banned. We already covered exactly why Han
got banned.
It's out there. We know
>> anything else with regards to oral with him that you
disliked. I really didn't like and so much with it. The spit
thing just personal trauma. I didn't like it. And so he would
always want to try like his goal, I guess, was to get me to swallow
a lot. There's a lot most most a lot of the times I would just
gag a lot. So did you tell him no? I would just tell him I really
don't like it and he would wanted me to make it a goal to get
him to do it. to get me to do it.
>> Jesus Christ, man. This is a lot, dude. This is a lot.
I There's so many like weird things going on. >> How did
he convey? >> By the way, this this isn't even like weird.
If you talk through this, like I don't think it's weird that
Teeone liked this stuff. People like things. I don't really give
a Okay.
Honestly, I don't really give a [__] It's just a
non-conensual thing that bothers me. Or like having to consistently
break down her barriers to do something he wants. I
I feel like there's a way to angle for this stuff that doesn't
feel manipulative.
And it just seems like every
every little manipulation he could do to get exactly what he
wanted out of this was what he was doing. What he was engaging
in the whole >> knew that he wanted that to that was his
goal. He's like, "Oh, you know, you just got to keep doing it
and you'll get used to it."
>> That this girl was like she just wanted to have a normal
relationship with this guy like normal intercourse so badly that
she's like, "Yeah, I'll degrade myself. Please just can we can
we please just have the normal I don't understand why he said
yeah we'll do it though to me that's like crazy
if it was really trauma.
You know what I'm saying? It's just >> Sorry. In my head
I thought if he did that he'd just have a normal
>> Sorry. It's okay. Take a deep breath.
>> Yeah. It's dude, it's
it's got to be disgusting reading through this stuff on a stream.
Uh, sorry, not a also on a stream. It's got to just be disgusting
going through this stuff and like she's sort of she has come
to the understanding that she was coerced into a lot of this
and
it's obviously like traumatic from that perspective when you
sort of realign and figure out like I really didn't want to do
this and I was sort of doing it under the ospaces that we could
get to like a normal relationship and after everything it just
seems like this guy manipulated me for the things he wanted I
never got anything out of it. It feels very
And she has to go back through and she's like talking about the
stuff she went the extent she went to. >> I'm sorry. >> It's
okay. Sorry.
Sorry. We have a break, please. Yes. Take a recess. Thank you,
your judge. Brief. So, chat, she was panicking on the stage.
A little bit upset. A lot of drama. A lot of things to talk about.
Brief rece uh recess happens. The court
Let's go back on.
>> Yeah. um thin signal. I do think this is true and I
think you have to understand
I on both sides of a relationship. You should try to understand
when a person is making sacrifices for you and be willing to
if you're going to ask of those things of them be willing to
reciprocate, right? And without making it a thing you have to
litigate all the time. Like if they're making some kind of sacrifice
for you, um if if you are discussing something that they don't
necessarily like, especially in a dynamic, something they don't
necessarily like and you're not willing to at all reciprocate
that, it just all goes in your direction. It does feel
wrong. It doesn't feel like a normal relationship to me. That's
just me personally. That's how it feels. >> Record in this
case. >> Yeah, but Jtock, you don't know she's an OF girl.
That means she should be cool with all of this.
I think for one thing, I do think that gets said in the legal
mindset video, and I almost lost it when I heard that. He does
say that at some point or or somebody says it. Maybe it's even
in the transcript. We'll see if we get there. But dude, the idea
that oh well, she does stuff. one, she doesn't do anything in
her like sorry, she doesn't do anything um graphically in her
only fan stuff as far as I know. The new Yes, the new legal mindset
video. Um she doesn't do anything graphically as far as I know.
And
so, but even if she did, that wouldn't be the case. Even if she
did do graphically stuff, it doesn't mean she wants to go home
and do that. Bro, >> please proceed. Mrs. Lock. Mrs. Lock.
Thank you.
So, thank you. He told you that he would that you all could have
a normal relationship if he did that particular act. Is that
right? Yes. Okay. And at that point did you all have any normal
relationships after that? No. Okay. And at what point did the
relationship start to unravel or get close to ending? We had
a talk and mutually decided to end it more. I believe on his
side and then soon after we had a talk about getting back together
and then I ended the relationship later on. So Teto wanted to
break up with her and then they had a talk and got back together
and then I ended the relationship later on. So, that's not going
to look good for Pingchu because that's one thing that they can
definitely use against her is that if you were really that bad,
if it was really that bad, why did you go back to TechOne and
then uh you were the one that ended it later on, but why did
you go back to Techone in the first place when you had so much
bad things happening? Um, that is something that's not going
to look good for Pingchu. So, let's keep going.
All right. And you all had discussions. He would address your
mental health, right? Yes. He always said that my whenever I
had complaints about how he was treating me or anything, he said
my because I'm a my versions of reality is like not normal people
and that he would have to explain to me what was really going
on. So keep in mind chat techone has schizophrenia. He would
see faces melting. He almost Jimmy here and he's telling Pinku
that she is the problem and she's a and her reality is not like
a normal people. I understand that
>> um Yes. So
that's that's like, dude,
listen, Pinky Chu, I need you to understand that you're a and
you don't see reality like most people do. Could you stop letting
your face melt like that for a second and be serious? Okay,
listen. You don't see reality the way the rest of us do. AND
GET DOWN. THERE'S A MONSTER BEHIND YOU. WAIT, WAIT, WAIT. NO,
hold on. You don't see reality like the rest of us. So, I think
you need to understand that we have to document things and make
sure that you like we're on the same page. OH MY GOD, WHERE ARE
THE BUGS COMING FROM? LIKE,
BRO, can we
>> There are some people that don't have a normal reality.
Some guys like um Mewtwo King who thinks that he is going to,
you know, he's continuing to play Super Smash Brothers Melee
despite the fact that he makes $2 an hour is what was told. Um
but the thing is people don't have that different of a version
of reality where they're seeing faces melt in problems. people
clearly can see the reality that is uh they just don't understand
some social cues more so I then so techone is just completely
gaslighting her um that is not the case and you all had a journal
is that right or you had a journal I kind of just started one
he had me write a list of things he said that were wrong with
me that he said I needed to give a psychiatrist and he later
graded me on things he thinks I need to work on
>> that's that you might have a hard time figuring out
what is psychotic about that could almost found. It's like right
there where you could almost think that that's just a caring
boyfriend. He He got you to write out a list and go to your psychiatrist,
right? He He helped you out. You could almost think that. Almost.
Except for did I write out the list of things that I think is
wrong with my life? No. He had me write out a list of things
he said that were wrong with me that he said I needed to give
a
It's not things that she had come to the determination that these
things were going wrong in her life, that these were the issues
she was facing. This is somebody else saying, "You need to go
to therapy and say these things that I'm telling you are wrong
with you."
Right?
that's bad. That's really bad.
That shouldn't be how that works. If you have a partner who needs
to go to therapy and if even if you want them to go to therapy,
you could work on a list, but when they go to therapy, it should
be their issues they're working on, right? Yeah. They could,
by the way, they could write down
their issues in their opinion that are informed by you. Or you
could even work on that list together. But if it's one person
dictating to the other what goes in that list and what's wrong
with you, and you need to work on these things so we can actually
communicate, that can't be how it works, right? That just can't
that cares too much. That is his greatest weakness. I've heard
this. People have been saying this. Bro is giving five stars
to her mental health. Are you kidding me? YouTube King catching
strays. No, you think he's a goat.
I I I am glad that Mewtwo King is continuing to work. I I believe
that this is just off tangent. We live in a world that is so
confusing that the future is so unknown that if you find something
you love, stick with it. Do it forever. No matter if it works
or doesn't work, you should just do it. If you love what you
do, do it because the world is very confusing nowadays. Sometimes
I even wonder chat with my money I've made. I'm like, well, am
I ever really going to use all this? Because is money going to
even be a thing in 30 years, 40 years? I don't know. With how
things change so fast nowadays, you really don't know. So, live
life, do whatever you need to, you know? So, I'm going to give
away all my money to chat. And what did he say that you needed
to go see a psychiatrist for
that? My memory recollection was incorrect. I believe I wrote
it in the journal. I can't remember by specifics. Mrs. Lock.
Okay. Oh, wait. I'm sorry, >> This is another big One second
here. I'm trying to get a tweet out here. needs to be black cuz
you guys can't see. There we go.
Okay. I sent you a copy of this, but this is the actual journal.
Would seeing the journal help you refresh your recollection?
Yes. Judge, may I approach? You may. Thank you. Hang on. That
is in fact the journal that he wrote in. Is that right? Yes.
All right. Just to review it to refresh your recollection first.
I'm actually not going to introduce the journal. Okay, I see
it. All right. Now, do you remember what it was that he was complaining
with regards to you and your mental state? He said I was immature,
that my memory recollection was incorrect, that my phrasing,
that, you know, he would say things and then I would phrase it
incorrectly, that I lacked communication skills, that I was depressed
and dooming a lot, that I wasn't a positive person, I didn't
take accountability, I was not independent enough, I was paranoid,
and I had no emotional control. What the actual is wrong with
this guy? Did he accuse you of being schizophrenic? It felt like
it at times. Okay. Okay. I see it. All right. Now, do you remember
what it was that he was complaining with regard to you and your
mental state? He said I was immature, that my memory recollection
was incorrect, that my phrasing, that, you know, he would say
things and then I would phrase it incorrectly, that I lacked
communication skills, that I was depressed and dooming a lot,
that I wasn't a positive person, I didn't take accountability,
I was not independent enough, I was paranoid and I had no emotional
control. What the actual is wrong with this guy? Did he accuse
you of being schizophrenic? It felt like it at times. Okay. And
what are your actual like sitting here today, your mental health
diagnosis? I am an as well as have anxiety disorder. Okay. You've
not been diagnosed with bipolar disorder. Is that correct, Pingchu?
I was misdiagnosed incorrectly diagnosed with autism and I was
diagnosed with a autism twice by psychiatrists and medical professionals.
Okay. So, they replaced the bipolar with the autism spectrum
disorder. That was a primary care doctor. He just gave me like
a I don't think this is what you might have, but it wasn't a
psychiatrist. And then I went to see a psychiatrist and got it
correctly diagnosed.
>> Okay, that's a big difference. primary care physician
diagnosing. I do think um
man, I think um
I I do think bipolar is overdiagnosed,
but it's very um it's very weird that I don't know why why would
a primary care physician, somebody who's not a psychiatrist,
diagnosed bipolar. That's that's [__] weird to me.
>> And you there's been a discussion of hospitalization
that you had. Do you recall? Yes. All right. Pingchu. And you
went to Austin Oaks. Is that correct? Yes, that is correct. Did
you do so voluntarily or were you forced to go? I think because
of the situation I was in, I just wanted to get out. I think
because of the list he gave me, I went to an online doctor and
told them that the list of things that he told me to tell her
and she gave me medications that made me shake and I because
I obviously I'm not schizophrenic or anything. So, it didn't
work for me and I just I just needed to get out. I needed to
get out of that house. When you did that online appointment,
was there with you? Uh was he with you when you did the online
appointment? No. But he had me write the list of what I needed
to tell her.
Okay. And what medications did that doctor prescribe? I believe
it was blank, which I've already said the name of it, chat. Uh
I've already said this because Axium was there and he is the
one that knows it. Uh Ailify is is what it was. U
>> That's so weird that Teone Why would Tectone be doing
this at all? >> A vilify a It's a a drug that's used for
people. Uh we can look this up. This is a typical antiscychotic
drug. It treats conditions such as schizophrenia, bipolar disorder,
irritability, linked to autism, major depressive disorder, and
Tourette's.
>> how insane is that? So, the doctor prescribed her based
on what TTON had her believed that she had
medications for psychiatric help, which made her shake. And did
that work for you in any way? No. I tried to tell him, "Oh, it's
great. It's fine." But I would tell my assistant and I was like,
"This is making me shake. I don't like it. This makes me feel."
Are you currently taking it, MJ? Absolutely not. I am not taking
that drug. Okay. Okay. And so the Austin Oaks, where did you
go afterwards? Let's get a little bit of uh back me up a little
bit. How long were you in Austin Oaks? 3 days. Okay. And what
were your discharge instructions? Just blank. I can't remember
what it was, but instead I decided to go ahead and see a therapist.
Okay. And did you actually have any acts of like did you intentionally
self harm or No. So what was the reason you went? I just needed
to get out of the house. I I think at the time I was just confused.
Like I knew something in my gut was wrong, like how I was being
treated. But, you know, he was telling me otherwise. And I was
just confused and I was just I told I called my sister. I said,
"I just need to get out. I just need to see somebody. I need
to get out of this place." I calmly packed my clothes, told my
roommate, "Hey, I'm going to be leaving. I'm not feeling good."
And then my sister drove me. I went there. They said, "Hey, there's
nothing we can really do. You're fine, but if you want, you can
admit yourself to get evaluated." Okay. So, >> okay. I
mean, so it's self admission and
I guess maybe they'll go a little bit more into this, but this
doesn't sound like it sounds like she was just in a like a crisis
and she figured like, hey, I've got money. I've got insurance
or whatever. I'm going to go check myself in cuz I I feel like
I'm not getting the help I need. That's
maybe the most mentally sane thing described in the entirety
of this transcript. Hey, I'm feeling like really mentally [__]
up right now. I feeling like hopeless. I'm I'm I'm having problems.
I am going to go check myself into this place cuz I've tried
taking some medications. They're not working. And maybe I'll
just try to go to some place that explicitly made for this to
get a diagnosed, get evaluated, see if they can help. And like
maybe the most mentally sound thing I've heard in the entirety
of this transcript so far. >> Did you get evaluated and
did you self admit? Yes. And when you were discharged or left
Austin Oaks, did you go back into the same residence with Mr.
Robertson? No. Okay. Where did you go afterwards? I went to my
mom's. I did go to his house to collect items that he when he
wasn't there and that's when I confined it in my at the time
his roommate that I guess that was going to be moving in. I said
I'm afraid of him. I'm really scared. I'm going ahead and staying
at my mom's because I can't be here. So
she left him after all of this. She realized by the way if Teone
had not like
lost his here, right? If he'd not been going after this woman
publicly constantly when she'd basically stopped referring to
him, I could have sympathy for him and say that like I maybe
this felt really unfair to you. Maybe this felt like um like
she was like lying about you or something. I could have sympathy
for the guy. It's his consistent attacking of Pink and his friend's
consistent attacking of Pink now that really disturbs me.
like if there's a chance that let's say she was like um just
unstable and he wasn't the person who could help, right? He was
he cared. Let's say hypothetically, I don't believe this to be
the case anymore, but hypothetically cared and he just wasn't
the person who could help. His his like personality wasn't set
up for that, okay? He wasn't he wasn't the guy. I could have
sympathy for him if she felt scared and and I could understand
how, you know, she might view him badly because of things he
wasn't intending to do or some [__] like this, right?
It's all of the conduct after this that colors the stuff before
in a way that makes it really hard to give him the benefit of
the doubt. Like when he is consistently trying to silence her
after the fact after she's like talked about this publicly, that's
what colors this for me in a very negative way, thinking maybe
there there was or likely there was some kind of course of control
or manipulation going on,
right?
It's all of the reactions after the fact that really color some
of this stuff. And cuz I I don't think this is at this point.
I wouldn't say that you would know. You know, I'm thinking of
how this timeline would have gone. It's not like it's not like
the friends would have been like, "Oh yeah, Teone is a total
piece of it would have been like, oh, she was, you know, she
just went through this stuff and we need to give her some space."
I think that's what anybody would have thought reasonably, but
when somebody says something bad about Tee, he like a switch
flips and they've become like evil to him. Like >> what
was going on and she left and she moved in with her mom. This
is before she said anything. This is before she tweeted anything.
She just got up, went and checked herself into Austin Oaks uh
for 3 days to get evaluated, and then her family moved her out
because they realized that this guy is a problem, which is not
similar to what other people have done where uh they asked to
marry someone and then they 10 months later come out with saying
that they're stalkers. This is different, chat. This is uh more
serious. This is actually real. Um
crazy how you can see the
>> differences between what is being
>> said about me and being said about Techone and Pinku.
Uh, and you heard council indicate in opening that you didn't
make any reference to Mr. Robertson being abusive when he went
to Austin Oaks. Do you recall him saying >> I'm I'm sorry.
I'll rephrase. Do you recall the opposing council in his opening
statements making comments that you didn't mention anything wrong
about Mr. Robertson when you read Austin Oaks? Yes, I remember.
Okay. When was it the first you realized that was going on and
was that it was assault? It was after I moved my stuff out and
I talked to my online friend and I felt safe enough to speak
to someone about what the events that had occurred.
Okay,
this is to me like what in my opinion this is what really like
it changes it from being convinced to being like I just described
the things that happened. She's saying I describe the events
that occurred.
If she had said, you know, if she'd been describing something,
the friend goes, oh, like,
are you sure you didn't do this? Are you sure you didn't do that?
It would really come down to how that conversation went, right?
When she just says, I describe the events. There are absolutely
situations where something bad is happening. Something very bad
is
and
you are unaware of it because of some the mental state you're
in at the time. So, Legal Mindset when we do watch his coverage
is going to say like this is proof that she had her mind changed
after the fact. She got gaslighted into making these allegations.
I This just does not share any of the normal hallmarks of that
kind of situation. >> Have you had contact with law enforcement
regarding these allegations? Yes.
When did you first contact law enforcement? I
do. You mind if I look?
You can look at your affidavit.
Mrs. Lock. Judge, may I retrieve the journal? You may. I believe
it was around January 2025. I do believe it was early the next
year. I just can't remember the exact date of when we went into
the Okay, but did you file a criminal complaint? Yes, I filed
a police report. So, she filed a police report 8 months later,
chat. 8 months later, it happened in May 2024 and in January
2025, she filed a police report. She finally realized what was
going on. She understood her family moved her she moved out of
the place and she filed a police report. And what is the current
status of that?
Because of the harassment, I had to suspend it. Okay. They wanted
what did law enforcement want you to do with regards to a phone
call to Mr. Robertson? A preliminary call. And was it a pre-text
call? Yes. And what was your understanding of what you were supposed
to do on that phone call? Call him and get him to talk about
the things he did to me. So the the police were probably like,
"Hey, there's not much we can do here. Um we need to get some
proof of this because it is a he said, she said. So you need
to call him and have him prove that these things were true."
Um because at the time she was probably just by herself. She
didn't have a lawyer and she didn't have any evidence. So she
just went to the police and they were like, "Look, you want to
prove this, take him and call him right now." And she just didn't
do it.
>> this is
interesting. I This is like new stuff, so this is always interesting.
>> Were you able to do so? No, because he was threatening
me and harassing me publicly and I was scared. Okay, we'll get
into that in a second. But you did not follow along with what
the law enforcement wanted you to do. No, I did not follow along
with what the law enforcement uh counselor that was there was
with me. I Oh, no. I did what was recommended by the counselor
that was there with me. All right. So, >> hold on, hold
on, hold on, hold on. >> What you're going to hear about
this case, your honor, is that they had never actually engaged
in traditional
Your fly is down, >> dude. Holy [__] Oh, dude.
The internet is leading to fantastic advancements in content
sometimes. Okay. You can't beat that moment. That's a amazing
moment. Holy [__]
>> Your honor, >> he's having an incredibly serious
conversation. How did you even see his eyes down? >> Actually
engaged
in traditional
Your fly is down. Did >> you hear it immediately? Oh, that's
goofy as [__] >> Around that time, did Mr.
Robertson start posting on what was it? It was Twitter or was
it X? I don't remember. It was Twitch, YouTube, and Twitter.
He did it on all three. And starting of January of 2025, what
did he start doing with regards to the online platforms? He started
before then. He started, I believe, around November. He started
the threats in 2024.
And what kind of threats was he making to you online?
I have a timeline of everything. So, she has a timeline of every
single time that Tech was threatening her online,
>> bro. Pinky. Pinky. Hey, Pinky.
Can I get that, dude? That's what I want. That's what I want
to do. Might have to recreate it. We'll see. Maybe. Maybe Miz
could foy that. Can we get a foil on that trans whatever that
is? That timeline.
Who's Who's Pinky? Well, we can't do it here. Who's Who's Pinky
Chu, by the way? I think it's Pink Chu, just so we're clear.
I say Pinky, but it's it's like Pink Chu. It's not Pinky technically,
but it just flows better.
But we're we're not going to during this incredibly sensitive
time. We're not going to do the the video because it's just a
little more sensitive than before. Okay,
>> but we can do the songever
>> about her and this and she she has it. Let's keep going.
But it was mainly I'm going to sue you. I'm He's also making
threats he's going to ruin me. That everybody was going to know
the truth. That he was coming after me. that also there were
explicit material that he shared with multiple people and that
he will post them online if I don't retract my statements
and it's just it's almost 200 pages of
Okay, so
it sounds like this is where the differentiation comes in. It
sounds like the allegation, the revenge stuff that she was talking
about
might actually be what Tee was telling her was the stuff from
Frame and that he was going to post that that that was recorded
by their security system and that he was going to post that on
the internet. Uh I don't know why he'd be threatening with that.
That's what it sounds like there that shared with multiple people.
That would be I get sorry that is what I that is what I'm inferring
shared with multiple people but it's not for sure. I guess he
could have said I shared the video of you like that I recorded
the POV video I recorded of you with multiple people. He could
have said that. That would be insane. That could be something
that leads to a 10-year
uh protective order. Okay. >> Slam the book. Pink Chu had
200 pages of proof and material that showed that Tech was harassing
her, threatening her, and had explicit material that he shared
with multiple people and that he will post them online if I don't
retract the statements. 200 pages of threats. That is insanity.
Threats, not comments, not concerns, threats, things that he
was saying. And you actually asked him to do when you first broke
up. What did you actually ask him to do with regards to those
videos? >> Oh, yeah. No. Telling her to keep a journal
because she can't remember things was probably a bad idea. You
unlocked Pink. You unlocked Pink's superpower. Okay. Turns out
she is a gifted A- logger. Okay. Actually, totally just extremely
gifted.
Unlocked her actual superpower. Not good. Teone.
Is there anybody who's contributed more to the demise of Tee
than Tee himself?
I say no. I asked them multiple times in multiple circumstances.
please delete any footage you have of me because I knew that
some of it was not consensual and he would make coll uh collages
of my uh collages of my
videos and things like that and it was very disturbing. I didn't
want him to have access to them sitting here today. Do you know
if he has deleted all those videos? Keep in mind, chat, this
is now two years later. Two years later, after she asked him
to remove disturbing videos that were not consensual that he
had and 40% of the time he would get head in a 2-year
or in a year and a half relationship.
Let's see. I do not know. He's told me he would, and then the
last time I requested, he just did not respond. Okay. So, sitting
here today, you have no idea if he still has those videos in
his possession. Yes. I'm not aware if he does or not. Are you
concerned about what he will do if he has those? Yes. And what
are your concerns?
He'll either post them publicly, continue to share them with
more people as he has stated, and possibly I just I don't want
that. I I don't think anybody wants that. So, I've still not
seen any like if there's evidence of him explicitly threatening,
I will send this recorded of you to somebody or I will send you
that was recorded without your consent. Even if it's the video
recorded by the security system, right? If he's ever said that
to her, he is I think he'd be >> Why couldn't Tee just
message her and say, "I deleted all the photos. I deleted all
the videos. Everything's done." Why couldn't Te just continuously
let her know that it's all gone. Showed evidence and proof of
that. So that way, Pingchu feels better. Instead, he just let
her sit in this question of anxiety for 2 years straight, wondering
if he still has these videos of non-consensual or consensual,
allegedly uh acts. So, what's going on there?
>> Has he threatened you with putting that out there? Yes.
How has he done so?
>> My vehicle is going off again. I got to fix this. Sorry,
I need to back this up just a little bit. I'm sorry that this
is happening. >> I'll be right back. >> Let's see.
I do not know. He's told me he would and then the last time I
requested, he just did not respond. Okay, so sitting here today,
you have no idea if he still has those videos in his possession.
Yes, I'm not aware if he does or not. Are you concerned about
what he will do if he has those? Yes. And what are your concerns?
He'll either post them publicly, continue to share them with
more people as he has stated, and possibly I just I don't want
that. I I don't think anybody wants that. So why couldn't Te
just message her and say, "I deleted all the photos. I deleted
all the videos. Everything's done." Why couldn't Tee just continuously
let her know that it's all gone. Showed evidence and proof of
that, so that way Pink Chu feels better. Instead, he just let
her sit in this question of anxiety for two years straight, wondering
if he still has these videos of non-consensual or consensual,
allegedly uh acts. So, what's going on there?
Has he threatened you with putting that out there? Yes. How has
he done so? I don't have the exact verbiage. It is in the timeline
of what was said in his words. Okay. Do you have to contact an
attorney in early 2025 with regards to what was going online?
Yes. It had just gotten very overwhelming because no one wanted
to associate with me because he will attack me. He had attacked
them as well. Okay. And I was just I was becoming very isolated.
I kind of had to rebuild my friend group with my family. Sorry,
what was the question? That's okay. What was going on online
that gave you to the point where you had to hire an attorney
back in early 2025?
Oh, yes. Even after going to the police, he still would not stop
harassing me. And I had an attorney send him a cease and desist,
telling him I had to gone to the police and he needs to leave
me alone.
Did that stop him? No. In fact, he went publicly and laughed
about it and said, "She's she's sent me a cease and desist for
defaming her, but I'm going to keep defaming her."
>> So, he got sent.
Dude, that is a total
What? Why? Why in the world, dude?
I You know, it happened over time and we would cover some of
the times where he would talk about Pink
and it happened over time and it's like we got a distorted view
of it. Like once you put it together, it sounds so much worse
than all of the different instances happening by themselves.
It's crazy. ist about her and he continued to defame her despite
the fact that it was told to not do that. Good job, Teto. Okay.
And that was February 6th of 2025. Posted a live stream on
I'm not sure.
>> Use these pennies to get a new car. >> Uh I cannot
use those pennies to get a new car. I love my car, but I just
had it plugged in. It's It's I think it's actually something
different than what I thought. It's when my um my hood is slightly
open. It's fine. It's fine. >> The exact date that he did
that fine >> Okay. He made threats about going nuclear
when the legal situation between you and him ends. Yes. And I
believe it was the time he was like showing his guns and things.
Okay. And in fact, he indicated on social media he was schizophrenic
in his strapping referring to weapons. Is that correct? Yes.
Tell the court your concerns about his use of or I'm sorry, his
possession of fire. one of those plug looks. >> I'm afraid
that if he does, obviously with the threats, he's got gets so
>> Is that the same date? It was February 5th, right? >> February
6th. Oh, it was his next one. Oh, that's also very helpful, isn't
it? So, here's the on the 5th is when he did this when he talked
about the lip fillers. And then on the 6th is apparently when
he went psycho on her. Let's take a Let's take a look. Uh O2.
Put O2 in here. February
February 2nd. We're looking for February 6th, 2025.
Oh, sorry, 2020. Yeah, 2025, right?
Wait, why did I even do that? I just scroll. Just scroll. February
6th right here. Part one.
Part two. Oh, is there not an Oh, no.
Ah, hold on. This is just part two. Oh, we lost the whatever
the first part of the VOD is.
Hold on. Let me see. Let me see.
I wonder if we have any of this other stuff here because it'd
be very interesting to see. Uh cease. Um
nope.
I wonder if somebody took that
Ah, I want to dude I want to see. I'm not sure the exact date.
Maybe it's a different date. >> Okay. And in fact, he indicated
on social media that he was schizophrenic and his strapping referring
to weapons. Is that correct? Yes.
Tell the court your concerns about his use of or I'm sorry his
possession of firearms. I'm afraid that if he does obviously
with the threats he's got gets so upset that he will try to do
something to me especially because I go to conventions and public
things or if he has like an episode or anything and is upset
enough. Totally fair and understandable.
>> And you filed this on a protective order. So you first
contacted an attorney in January, went to the police in January.
Why is it that you filed a protective order application in August
of 2025?
Well, first it was mainly just dealing with the police and the
preliminary call and trying to get that set up and whether that
was the right move for my safety. And so it was kind of just
kept getting pushed between the police and his threats and he
I'll ask the court to take judicial notice on the filing of the
application for protective order which was August 21st of 2025.
Yes, the court will do so. May I approach the witness? You may.
Thank you. I'm going to show you what we've been marked as application
exhibit 7. Are you able to identify that? Yes. Okay. Without
telling what's in it yet, the statements in it. What is it? A
tweet from Robertson. Mr. Robertson. Okay. What does Mr. Robertson
go by and go by on his social media? The first time we've heard
this word, the microphone don't like to say, it's Voldemort here.
>> Teone. And that's >> Don't say techones. just
say, "Oh, he should have said he should have actually gotten
the when he got the person to censor Pink's information out of
this, he should have gotten all versions of tech tone changed
to rape tone. That would have been amazing."
Possibly making a mockery of the the proceedings, but I don't
care. >> Can you spell it out for the court reporter, please?
Please spell it. Yes, for the court order. T E C T O N E. All
right. And what is it that you R a
T O N E. >> Go buy online Pinchu. Can you spell that for
the court, please? P I N K C H YU. All right. That is a true
and accurate copy of the message that he put on the social media
on August 25th, 2025. Is that correct? Yes. And when you read
this, do you note this related to you? Yes. And how do you know
this was related to you? This was many of his multiple times
where he's named me or not named me or it was times where I consent
a cease and desist or I've gone to the police and he would make
statements like this. So what this is referring to chat I believe
if you can try to find out what he posted on August 25th of 2025
and go look for it. I believe that is when he had the picture
of the person's head being held. >> It will just be your
pay.
>> Ruben donated $3. >> Hello Ruben Voldemort. A
more like Tom Diddle. Haha. Oh, I get it. Yeah, like Tom Riddle.
I got it. You got him. I Listen, that almost went over my head,
but I got it right at the end. Thank you so much, Ruben Rubin.
Appreciate the donation. Also, guys, with that being said, we
are two subs away from another hour on the stream. If you like
the content, go ahead, follow on every platform. Join the Discord.
All right, we'll go over everything.
We're going over everything. And if you want to call in, if you're
a Techone defender, you want to call in, please feel free to
do so right after we finish this stuff. We might have to take
calls tomorrow, but if you go ahead, join the Discord and we'll
figure it out. Okay, we're going to take open call-ins on this
topic if you want to come argue.
what else is there here? Oh, and yeah, so follow that stuff.
If you guys really like the content, you go ahead. You can donate
a couple dollars my way, okay? You give bits or subs on kick.
You can give your primers on Twitch. You can on kick give kicks
and subs. You can send a TTS message through Kickbot or through
Streamlabs. I appreciate all the money. All the all the dollar
donations go to additional time on the stream. I think probably
I don't even know if we're going to do a timer for this stream
necessarily, but I still would like donations anyway. That I
I'm probably going to finish this entire transcript. When I say
probably, I'm definitely finishing this entire transcript regardless
of how much you donate, okay? But I would appreciate the donations
anyway and then we can keep the timer running. Okay. I love you
guys. Thank you so much for all the support. Let's get back to
the content. >> Try to find that. Let me know.
>> All right. Uh, it's in the file.
>> It's in. >> Hello. Hello. Hello. Hello.
>> Anonymous gifted to Let's go. Thank you so much, Anonymous.
There's two hours 12 on the board. Let's go.
Thank you very much. Oh, so it's it's here. Maybe Miz can scroll
to the bottom of this and we'll we'll get to see >> Let's
go
>> try to find it.
All right. And this is a true and correct copy of this. You've
not changed or modified it in any way. Is this correct? >> And
real quick, Coherent Memes actually has a good point here as
well, which is
right here. Okay. Critical shock critical Shogun is showing the
head cut off tweet or something. Thank you. Let's take a look.
That's not the head cut off suite, is it? That's not what we
already covered this, but thank you very much.
>> Um, yes, >> looking for this. Skip to 15 seconds.
>> I moved to >> Did I miss it? Also, coherent memes.
Excellent point as well. Defamation was I think in part he was
denying what Pinky Ch was saying. He's saying she was
>> Why you think Pink ain't talking about me no more?
>> That's at 15 seconds. What are we talking about?
Skip 15 seconds into the
I don't see him pull up. Does he pull up a tweet? I don't see
a tweet getting pulled out here. I Are you trying to provide
the tweet wire rope or sorry uh >> introduce applicant
seven? Any objections, Mr. Porier? Relevance, your honor. I don't
I mean this could be about anything. I don't understand what
the relevance this has to the proceedings in front of the court.
Oh, >> I don't think that those dots have been connected
sufficiently. But that's that's my objection.
Your objection is relevance. It's overruled. Applicant seven
is admitted,
Mrs. Lock. Thank you. >> Okay, hold on. Uh, any objection,
Mr.
Applicants seven. Okay, so they're introducing the evidence there.
Relevance, your honor. I don't I mean, this could be about anything.
I don't understand. This could be about anything. This could
This could be about anything. Uh, I don't know. What are we What
are we doing here? >> That's my objection.
Your objection is relevance. It's overruled. Applicant 7 is admitted.
Mrs. Lock, thank you. What was it that TechTome published 4 days
after this application for a protective order that was filed?
So, this was 4 days after she filed that his lawyer saying why
why is this why is this relevant? 4 days after it was filed.
If someone can find me the tweet of what he posted,
what was it that Tee published 4 days after the application for
protective order that was filed? I'm not sure of the dates correctly.
I'm sorry. What were the dates? Can you zoom in? Do you say I'm
sorry. August 22nd, 2025. And this was the day after the application
was filed. Is that right? I believe so. Okay. And you received
extension of this exparte protective order that was granted back
in August. Is that right? Yes. All right.
Mrs. Lockach. Judge, may I approach the witness? Of course. I'm
going to show you what has been marked as applicants 9, 10, 11,
12, and 13. Will you look at those please? Yes, I see. Let's
start with those are all like the last exhibit, exhibit 7. Those
are all various screenshots of Techone posting. Is that correct?
Yes. All right. And just to lay the foundation, you've not
>> Changed or modified these in any way. Is that correct?
Yes. These are >> I think the exhibits are at the bottom
of the document. I think Miz could just go grab them. true and
correct copies of the social media post that Techone Mr. aka
Mr. Robertson published. Is that correct? Yes.
And nine is from 9/116, 2025. Is that correct? Yes. All right.
And there's an extension of this protective order signed back
in on September 3rd. Is that correct? Yes. All right. And it
was that paperwork was extended until December 3rd, 2025.
Is that correct? I believe so. Yes. Judge Dude. Oh, [__]
Is Teeone removed from way back machine? I'm trying to find these
tweets at the same time, you know, cuz >> ladies quit trying
to give hand jobs. Men have been doing that to ourselves our
entire life. You ain't >> No, this is the 18th Miz. It
says right there, the 18th Miz. It couldn't possibly be that
one. They wouldn't be that far off. It's supposed to be after
the protective order. Biz >> going to do it better. I don't
think that's it, but that's still weird as like what? Who tweets
that, dude? I don't get it. And who likes that? It's like you're
35 years old, bro. It's so weird.
It's so gross. Like, you're talking about hand jobs and trying
to get likes on Twitter.
if you find it, put it in my general chat on Discord.
>> Uh, I don't care about your age. It's just an unoriginal
joke that's been done a 100 different times.
If like, it's just it was funny when it happened 10 years ago
when it 15 years ago. It was like funny for a second. Bro, guys
are there's like a diff 100 different >> Is a true and
correct copy of the post that Techone aka Mr. Robinson posted
about that date. Let me ask Axian because he was there. Can you
try to find the stuff? I'm also going to message someone else
that I know uh might be able to help. All right. Yes. And is
this was related to something involving you? Yes. All right.
And that's how you believed it to be. So this is Pink Chu believing
that Oh, my lawyer text me. Hold on.
>> J, did you just fall? >> Hold on. Did you just
fall? >> Are you okay? Keep going. >> So, back to
uh what we're talking about, chat. Pink Chu is showing a lot
of evidence that is saying that Techone has threatened her on
social media. Has been threatening her a lot on Twitter, Instagram,
and YouTube or Twitter, Twitch, and YouTube. And Tech's lawyer
is trying to say that this has no relevance because this stuff
doesn't say her name uh and is not about her. But let's say so,
let's get to all what does Mr. Robert to tell you his followers
on 9:23
2025.
If you think $10,000 is a lot to start vtubing, you should see
how much women spend on plastic surgery to start Only Fans or
of
>> Only Fans stands for Only Fans. Yes. Do you have an
Only Fans account? Yes. When did you create your Only Fans account?
I believe towards the end of December of 2024 2024.
>> Now, this one I don't know.
I don't know
personally if this one could be attributed. We'll see if they've
got more to cook with here. Okay. >> All right. So, Mr.
Robertson knew you had an Only Fans account. He encouraged me
to make one. Okay. And but you are not doing any nudity on your
account. Is that correct? I will say I'm I'm trying to be unbiased.
This isn't really a big comment that I think is a big deal. All
right. So, Mr. Robinson knew you had an Only Fans account. He
encouraged me to make one. Wow. Okay. And but you are not doing
any nudity on your account. Is that correct? I did not do full
nudity. Damn it. All right. And he encouraged you to do >> HEY
YO, WHAT? HEY YO, BIZ, WHAT?
Excuse me. Hey, you're covering
>> what the do. So we agree.
Oh, whoa. Miz, not appropriate right now. Miz Miz was like he
heard this and he he had the song play in his head and he was
like damn it
agreed that I did not do full nudity. Okay, but he is the one
who encouraged you to do to make an Only Fans. I had a Fansly
account at the time. Only Fans is more stigmatized and kind of
can just hurt your career more than just having a fans.
Okay. And what do you know what the reference to the 10K to start
Vtubing was? What was the reference to to making a VTuber model?
This is might be half the
>> the lawyer
>> Uh, and what is a VTuber exactly? Well, you see, you
get somebody to craft a 12-year-old girl. Well, they start with
a 12-year-old girl and then they put triple D on it and they're
like, "That's an adult now." That's That's what Vtubing model
That's what Vtubing is. >> Talking about what the this
is. I don't I'm so sorry. I just I'm just a lawyer to make a
graphic for your stream. Okay. All right. Let's go to 12. What
does Mr. Robinson post to his audience again around the same
date, September of 2025?
Can you read that, please? I made a post about this earlier,
and I'm going to need to say it again. Do not date crazy chicks.
No, you will not fix them. No, it will not be worth it. Yes,
it's stupid. It's like inviting a rabid dog. >> It's so
crazy.
It's just insane to me that he's saying this and he's trying
to picture the good times. Listen, he was going to make this
post and he was like trying to picture the good times with Pink
and all he could all he could remember was her face melting while
like during intercourse or during um
the interactions they had this interactions they had was her
face melting and he's like don't date crazy people man.
Also,
if if a giant life-sized rabbit tells you that you're going to
save the world, don't believe him. Okay,
both very important things to remember. in your house. Sure,
they might be cute, but what thing got rabies and going to your
ass? You won't have a partner. You'll have >> By the way,
do you think Tek's dog Tone got a golden retriever? Very cute
golden retriever. Do you think that's like a service animal?
Cuz I've seen that there's like a skit there's schizophrenia
golden retrievers you can get that basically like you can point
in a direction and if they see a person there, they'll like bark
for you or something or they won't bark. But if you point and
there's nobody there, then they won't like they're basically
a a touch zone, right? So you could like point, you give them
signals.
This kind of a Donny Darko reference. I've never seen the movie.
Um, so do you think that's what he's training his dog to do?
So he could like go in public and he's like, "Hey, look over
there." Like, "No, that's uh, no. Don't don't don't swerve out
of the way of that guy. That guy's >> a liability. And
if you don't stoop to >> What if the dog starts talking
to you? Row tech. Row rap." >> Oh, wait. Hold on. It's
It's Scooby. So it would be um
redone.
>> Yeah. Rone. Yeah. Okay. >> To their delusions,
they'll turn against you and make you their next target.
Find yourself a nice girl or a guy that you can communicate efficiently
with. Not an adult with a mind of a deranged
Dude, yeah, it's you won't have a partner. You'll have a liability.
This is just Dude,
I find this
there's just so much stigmatization.
You would think as a guy who's got
well he doesn't I don't think he has schizophrenia which is why
he doesn't have this um this empathy. I think there's just a
lot of stigmatization of mental illness that is like largely
Um
you can make these things work. I think probably for him, you
know, he is someone who can't consider other people. And I to
some extent I have some empathy cuz I'm I'm like pretty selfish
in relationships too. But like don't take your faults, your inability
to help this person, your inability to to to make this person
happy or be happy with them and project that entirely onto them
is so psychotic.
No, Teone, you are up. Tone, you are up. People can't be happy
with you. Don't put that on everyone else. There's a reason you
can't be with somebody for more than like Well, actually, he's
with Free for a long time. Dude, I don't know how Frame did it,
man. Sure. Sure seemed like she was depressed when she got out
of that. Okay. There's like It's
There's a reason that everybody your friends, you never like
stay in a community. You never stay in a friendship for very
long. It seems like he's constantly cycling through these people.
It's very obvious why. Okay.
I don't know. And I wouldn't even have a lot of I wouldn't try
to throw that in his face if he wasn't clearly trying to paint
pink as like the insane person here who can't be loved. That's
just brutal, man. It's brutal. >> I wonder who that's about.
Was there any doubt who this referred to in your mind? It was
me. Okay, so the first one was the only fans comment that I could
have been about anybody. That was clearly about Pink Jew. Duh.
Um,
and how do you know it was about you? He said multiple times
with my name, specifically stating my name on stream and publicly
that I was crazy. All right, let's go to 13. Are these the type
of messages that you found to be harassing? Yes. Okay. And what
were these types of messages that your attorney requested he
stopped doing in the cease and desist? Yes. All right. Let's
go to A13.
Tell me this.
Do you do a little bit of like anime? Is that what you do? Like
you dress up as a cosplay anime character? Yes. Okay. So go back
in October 3rd of 2025.
So 2 months after the protective order has been filed and the
exparte has been granted. What did he post on his socials? Do
not put your in crazy. It's hot in anime. Stupid as in real life.
What else did he say about mental illness? You cannot you can't
fix a mental illness, bro. You can medicate it, but that's a
crap a crapshoot. Get someone who you don't need to fix much
easier. Oh my god. Techone literally just it's it just writes
itself. He literally just pro everything is obviously about Pink.
All right. Do you have any doubt these were about you? No. I'm
No. I had no doubt it was about me. Okay. And did you How did
your fans, if at all, because I don't know how this works, how
did you learn that he was talking about you on social media?
people in my community would let me know and tag me and at me
my friends people in the space because it did affect my >> it's
dude it's it's kind of rough because I man how do you help in
this situation cuz I do think there's some effect of like people
will say something but I know I get the same thing when certain
people talk about me like a whole bunch of people will message
me and be like oh man this guy's like a total psycho this guy's
really up right oh this guy's crazy
and it's like, well, technically, if I was feeling like tormented.
I don't know how much that would help, right? But they're like
trying to check in. It's like a double-edged sword. It's kind
of up, right? People are like trying to check in, but they're
also drawing your attention to the person you're trying to ignore.
Uh, it sounds like she would have it way worse. For me, I have
a genuinely like somebody who's like falling apart. I don't know.
For her, she probably wasn't doing well herself in that case.
Got to be feel pretty rough. livelihood in my consistent life
because people who worked with me would be technically associated
with somebody he's consistently attacking and they were afraid
that if he would also attack them as well. >> All right.
And he let's go to 13. I'm sorry. 14. Is that correct? I don't
believe I have that page but I can see it on the screen. I'm
sorry. That will be these ones. 15 21. May I approach judge?
You may. I'm going to show you applicants exhibit 15 16 19 20
and 21 right here. No objection to these, your honor. No obje
objections. All right. Applicants 15 through 21 are admitted.
All right. Let's start with 15. And this is Mr. Robertson on
applicants 15 actually referring to your allegations. Is that
right? I believe so. All right. And what does he say? They're
going to hate what I found today. Your loss is now even more
inevitable. Now I wait.
Okay.
Dude,
like skitso monologuing at the person who filed the police report
and I guess the person who's about to file or sorry who did file
protective order. Yeah, the protective order is f >> And
when you see these messages that he posts like this, how did
you interpret them? Like how did it make you feel? >> Like
he's coming after me. >> Okay. And then let's go to >> Hold
on. Hold on. >> All right. And what >> this was on
when was this? This was um >> All right. Let's start with
15. And this is Mr. Robertson on applicants 15 actually referring
to your allegations. Is that right? I believe so. All right.
And what does he say? They're going to hate what I found today.
Your loss is now even more inevitable.
I've pulled this one up. I've seen this one. The one he's talking
about. I feel like I've pulled this up or I talked about um this
is like the same one in the Chud clip, right? Where he's talking
about you're going to hate what they found. >> Found I
wait. >> I'm almost positive. >> Okay. Okay. And
when you see these messages that he posts like this, how did
you interpret them? Like how did it make you feel like he's coming
after me? Okay. And then let's go to 16. So the same month, October.
>> Wait, I have a similar stalker that subweets me all
the time. Wait, who are you talking about? Klein,
>> I don't know who you're talking about.
>> Oh no. >> Shortly after the protective order was
filed, what does techone Mr. Robertson yet again post about you?
Another only fans woman lying about then just moves on. No damage
done to them. Ruins a man's life for three years. Why is this
so common?
And did you >> That's the rich stuff. >> You believe
that this was also related to you in a way? Yes. Okay. And why
did you believe so? He he does is he gets basically trains his
community into hating Only Fans or women or also migrants and
things like that. I'm half Mexican and just things to hate about
women and women that they have only fans. So when he does attack
me that they're more angry towards me. Now, have you seen some
of his fans come after you in those platforms? Oh, absolutely.
Can you explain that to the court, please? I've had people make
threats, YouTube videos, call me a liar, a [__] threaten
to want to kill me. I believe also I have a DM of someone threatening
to rape me. Basically, it had gotten to the point where I didn't
even go to TwitchCon because afraid
maybe one of his fans might try to physically hurt
Does Mr. Robertson know that his or let me rephrase that. Has
he told you previously about how he can get his fans to do what
he needs them to do?
Yes. Okay. Can you tell the court what he has told you with regards
to that? It was in the situation with his ex, >> bro. Is
she white? Shut the up. Who's got the legal mindset tweet? Okay,
where's that legal mindset tweet? Why was she wearing a Mexican
bikini if she is not in fact Latina? >> His wife after
their he had her sign at NDA. He wanted me to go after her. Can
I give context?
I don't want to go into what that is. The issue is the NDA. Okay,
just answer the question. What he told you specifically about
having his fans to do things. Yeah, that if you kind of guide
them into the right direction, ironic that they'll know who to
attack and he's done it to multiple multiple people. And how
have you seen him do it to multiple people?
Enviosity
was one example. He has a lot of I guess beef with a lot of people.
I can't even count in his YouTube videos. He names each of his
YouTube videos after the person he's going after in that video.
After the person he's going after in that video. And what was
your concern with regards to what happens if the protective order
is not granted after this hearing today? He is going to continue
and he's going to show before relentlessly harassing me and threatening
me to the point where I will probably have to take measures with
my life might be in danger.
Whoa.
I I get what she's going for here. I do think that like
realistically
this would probably apply to like a lot of YouTube beefs
in general. I don't think that it quite rises to this level and
she is going to get like anonymous hatred for people. I do think
Tekone is trying to do it. It's hard to decide like where the
lines are.
I think he should have stopped talking about her obviously and
the way he talks about her is like pretty deranged. I'm just
saying that like I don't know if you could quite attribute every
threat she gets to him necessarily.
It's it's like in between, right? I I try to be careful on like
where your speech could be curbed just for criticizing somebody
or being upset with someone and like tweeting about them.
I do think that for him having that close personal relationship
where he's saying things like this, I do think it's colored differently
in my eyes though. >> A7 he posts in October of 2021.
What does he post? Proud to be blocked. Proud to be blocked.
Women who falsely accused men are scum and should be in prison.
Are you falsely accusing him of these actions? Absolutely not.
Okay. Did they in fact take place? Yes. A19. What does Mr. Robertson
say? And this was actually before the protective order was filed
on June 18th of 2025.
I'm excited to be called misogynist for thinking women are smarter
than people. Believe in that the bad actors who lie and scream.
I was manipulated and going to make it harder for real victims
to be taken seriously.
Did you think this post was related to you? Yes.
>> Because he's already said
>> publicly that I ruined it for other
What the is that? I'm excited to be called misogynistic for thinking
women are smarter than people believe and that the bad actors
who lie in >> it's like the laziest way of looking at things
and so many people are this kind of lazy and it's so depressing
to watch. Um
I think I don't I don't like this person and I think they ruin
everything for everyone else. Um I don't I don't like I don't
like that Pinky Drew said this. Like a whole bunch of people
will reiterate this when they haven't looked at the allegations
at all. They'll just go, "Oh, there's some reason to doubt this.
Well, that person's making it worse for all women.
Bro, what
does this himself use this exact move many times? Links clips
cheese >> and scream. I was manipulated
uh are going to make it harder for real victims to be taken seriously.
So, Tech's basically saying right there that the bad actors and
bad people who lie make it difficult for real victims who actually
get assault to be taken seriously. Now, that is very true. I
agree with that statement. But he is clearly uh talking about
Pinkchu. He's
>> Oh, wait. Never mind.
That is very true. I agree with that statement. I I don't think
you should really throw that out there. I think it's um Unless
>> Unless you're talking about somebody who's been like
conclusively proven to have been lying. Otherwise, you're just
creating a weird environment,
trying to continue to make his audience groomed into thinking
that Pink Chu is bad, that Tech's life's not fair, and that whenever
this court case comes out, whatever happens, Teeone did nothing
wrong. And it's disgusting. Which is ironic because Tee literally
attacked me relentlessly for months, threatened me for about
eight months about Emmy, and uh tried to allude to the fact that
I >> Yeah, but he's saying, Hold on. I don't know. Wait.
Uh don't do do proper things. Restate whatever you're saying.
went around Austin lying about me, telling people that I shook
Pinkchu's hand and then I harassed her when I never did that
and made people think that I was weird to Pinkchu. So, he was
lying to people all around me and making everyone in Austin hate
me for stupid like I shook a hand. Um, but says this that the
people who lie and scream uh make it harder for real victims
and he's just such a pathetic person.
He said you specifically. Yes, he made a tweet with my name specifically
about me. Whoa. Let's get to 20, please. On October 27th, this
is after chat that she's already filed a cease and desist.
>> Loud. Very loud
every time. Thank you, Dickers, for the raid. Jesus Christ. I
think I'm going to shut down that raid notification. That is
so loud. Jesus. Thank you very much, Dickers, for the raid. Appreciate
it. >> Against Techone. Keep that in mind. He was filing
a cease and she got filed a cease and desist on her on him.
And Teone has a very easy route in this world at this point,
chat. He could just >> This one I do not believe. Um,
this one I don't believe is about denim. >> Sorry. I don't
believe it's about pinky. I believe this one's about denims.
He was like mostly seething about denims around politics. He
can just sit under >> Well, no. I maybe both. He can just
continue doing what he's doing, but instead he just continues
to run his
To all the Only fans trying to give me life advice, bro. I can
see your for less than buying a Fortnite battle pass. Shut the
[__] up. Obviously, he needs that Fortnite battle
pass to play with Mar uh as she was just 18 years old. Um cuz
that is what occurred. Is this how he would refer to women in
front of you? Yes. Okay, let's get to 21. Um that's hopefully
what I was waiting for Tech to do, but All right. And then on
it looks like again in October of 2025. What does Mr. Robertson
say? Who will be the next Only Finn girl to call me out, bot
their likes, and unlock their comments? Holy absolute rent free
in their minds. Get back to making your family shameful of your
experience.
And did you believe that he was referring to you? It was possibly
just kind of like I said, getting his audience to have a certain
view for when he attacks me. Yes, Tekum was, you know, continuing
to make his community hate Only Fans, women, and and her. Yes.
One of the extensions. Yes. All right. May I approach judge?
You may. Do you have any objections to 31 and 32? No. Applicants
31 and 32 are
There was an agree.
>> Does he think this is a loophole? I do wonder if he
thinks this is a loophole.
Um, he's got to be really careful with this, right? He's taking
Henry Resilient. So, Techone Tweety right now. He's got to be
very careful with this. He's taking Henry Resilient talking about
his case and going who and drawing attention over here. I don't
think this is the loophole you think it is. Man, you got to be
super careful.
You got to be super careful. >> And he can appeal this
and say that the judge abused their discretion. Maybe it's too
intense. Maybe there's new evidence. But I do not think he has
a leg to stand on in getting this overturned, tossed out, or
even modified in the slightest. if he even applies for a modification,
but I'm sure he will address the elephant in the room.
Wow. Who? Who?
I wish I could reply to this. I cannot though. He has been blocked.
Unlucky. >> Read order for an extension of PO23 on 2025.
Is that your understanding of recollection? Yes.
Are admitt >> uh judge? I would ask the court to take judicial
notice of the agreed order of extension of protective order that
was signed on January 23rd of 2025.
No, this can't be January 23rd of 2025. That was last year. It's
got to be this year, right? Greed order for an extension of the
the PO on 123, 2025.
Protective order. The protective order was
it was in August of 2025. I'm confused. They must mean 2026 here.
There was an agreed order, >> but also that's the date
of the trial, >> for an extension of PO23 on 2025. Is that
your understanding of the >> Yes. Judge, I would ask the
court to take judicial notice of the agreed order of extension
of protective order that was signed on January 2023 of 2025.
>> I don't know. Ms. is confused now, too. Uh-oh. M is
also confused now. >> Court will do so. All right. I would
ask the court to take judicial
>> 2023 of January 2025.
>> Notice that it was originally set for hearing, not originally.
The extension was set for December 3rd of 2025, but it was extended
the day before because the parties agreed to extend it. So, this
is referring to the fact that Teetone and Pink both agreed that
they're going to extend the protective order because they >> Oh,
that actually shocked me. Right. I believe one of these cases
Tee actually asked for the extension. like Teetones uh Tees representatives
asked for an extension I believe in in September. They probably
pointed that out and I missed it. >> Date backed. Okay.
Yes, that's right. And the court will take judicial notice shortly
after the extension. Did Mr. Robertson post again on social media?
Yes. All right. In fact, on December 12th, 2025 in exhibit 31,
what did he post? You've got no idea how hard it is to find a
woman that isn't a psychotic entitled [__] Men got
it
>> dude. Dude, all he had to do All he had to do is shut
the up. How hard is it to shut the up? >> All right. And
do you think did you take that as directed towards you? Yes.
Why?
>> Like just think about this in terms of like actual results,
actual things that are happening. Okay. Teto keeps complaining
about this over and over and over again, right? He keeps complaining
about it.
I'm going to tell you, I I believe like it's just a fact that
even if he won this protective vortic case, even if he got it
all dismissed, people would still call him. People don't care
like like the internet calling him this. This is what he's he's
trying to solve a problem, which is people who hate him on political
grounds and the fact that he's a right-wing grifter will call
him. He's trying to solve that by getting Pink discredited by
winning his thing against
He should understand no matter what happened with Pink. Now,
it came out that he was found guilty, right? He was found liable.
Sorry. He was held liable for assault in this case, even if he
weren't, it would never have mattered. People on the internet
would still call him rape because it upsets him. So, he is trying
to fix something that can't be fixed. He's basically trying to
control the weather by punishing Pinkchu.
That it's like nonsensical, right? He's blaming all of these
things that are happening on her instead of looking at his actions
and how they've created an environment where people will say
whatever they can about him to hurt him, right? He's not thought
about that. He doesn't care about that. He's not analyzing the
situation accurately. Even if he were to win all of this, and
he's not. But even if he had even if all this had gone well for
him, he would have been either way for the thing that actually
upsets him
and I just I don't know how else.
It's just it's insanity to me because he no matter what he couldn't
have won here. There was no way of winning. So blaming Pink for
it is just insane on its face. It's already insane.
Anyway, we >> It is the same verbiage that he used multiple
times when describing me and describing you publicly or in private.
I believe he just calls me crazy and psycho is what I believe
he said on his streams about me. All right, we'll pull up 32.
And on December 17th of 2025, what does he post?
No, we do. But modern feminism have convinced women that a man
wants to protect you, is manipulating you. Women have grown ungrateful
and entitled and expect you to be taken care of and protected,
but aren't willing to do their part of the relationship. And
they say you're abusive.
And that was all while there was that emergency protective order
in place. Is that right? Yes. How did this compare to what the
what he had posted before the protective order? Like what's the
difference between that? >> By the way, I don't think a
lot of these will weigh heavily in the judge's decision. They
they're putting them out here for evidence, but I don't think
these tweets, like the ambiguous ones, I don't think they weigh
very heavily in the judge's mind. I think they're like little
little coloring things that, you know, she can see they kind
of apply and it's probable, but I I doubt any of this stuff is
really the hard evidence that's going to get him, you know, get
this protective order extended for 10 years. >> Very tame.
Keep in mind, chat, that at this moment, Tee isn't streaming
for 7 hours a day and makes one comment. Tect is not streaming
and making a YouTube video a week about either me, Pokemon, or
Assan. And he's tweeting this. So, it's not him just having a
little moment and saying something about her in a 7-hour stream.
It's he's literally going out of his way to tweet this despite
not only having a restraining order, but having a protective
order against him now. And he's continuing to do this, but his
court date is in a month from now. And they're going to obviously
use this against him. So, his lawyer must have been bricks. And
I'm going to say this right now. His
>> Oh, I think that's where we came into the VOD. So, we're
uh we're we're cooking. We're trying to get through here. Hold
on.
Boop boop boop. Need to restart right now. Here we go. >> His
lawyer said we're back because his lawyer was smart. His lawyer
would tell him to never tweet unless you tell me what you're
tweeting. But and if and maybe he did, but Tech did it anyway.
I don't know. >> I'm guessing his lawyers told him. Almost
always the lawyers give you the advice you need. That's what
lawyers do. They've been in this situation a million times. They're
going to give him the advice he needs to hear. It's just a matter
of whether or not he wants to take that advice. But Teone is
so and just needs to try to get that small satisfaction despite
claiming that I care about viewership so much. You need to get
that small little win, that little slap to her face at the end
of this when you were so stupid and realizing that she's just
going to hate you 10 times harder bringing this into court. This
is a month before and you're still tweeting about her. You're
so
Okay. What were the ones likes before? He explicitly named me
and gave it a lot of threats. All right. No objection. So,
>> dude. Uh,
that's crazy being Te's lawyer in that situ. That's Tech's lawyer,
by the way. The no objection is Te's lawyer. Um, he explicitly
named me and gave me a lot of threats. No objection, your honor.
My honor is my my client is a psycho. No >> lawyer said
no objection to that. All right. That was applicants 33 34 36.
All right. 34 33 46 or admitted.
This is pink shoes
>> uh legal uh council back on December 20th 2025. So a
month ago. What else did Mr. Robertson post while this exparte
was in effect?
Any woman that lies about assault assault or rape should be punished
to the fullest extent of the law. They should be excommunicated
from every group they're part of. and people knowingly weaponizing
their lie should be held accountable as well. And then on 34
on 12:30 2025, what did Mr. Robertson post? Interesting. Doesn't
this mean that Te should stop talking to his father for the rest
of his life? Anyway, um,
lying women have far too much power today. Did you believe that
this was in a reference to you? Yes, >> Mrs. Lock. And
then, judge, I'll ask the court to take judicial notice of the
extension of the protective order that went into effect until
January 7th. the court will do. So, we had a hearing on the 6th
about the extension of it. That's correct. Mrs. Lock, who's Pinkchu's
lawyer? All right. And so, I'm going to show you A36. This was
posted on January 6th. >> So, her name is Pinkchu. Why
does everyone call her Pinky Chu? Uh, cuz it looks like Pinky
Chu. >> 2026 at 7:17 p.m. after we had court that day.
>> So, this is after Techone and Pinkchu had court on 7:17.
Do you recall this tweet? Yes. This is just three weeks before
he had a court hearing to to seal his fate. What does he say?
I have uh sorry, what does he say? I'm a patient man. No matter
how long this takes, I don't care. Justice will come. I WILL
NOT fall off. I will return to my life soon. And in the meantime,
I'll keep living, working on myself, and growing. I'm not worried.
I'm looking forward to the future patiently. And what did how
did you take that post? He's threatening this as some type of
criminal court case rather than me needing protection because
of his harassment and threats and the abuse.
What or what are you asking the court to grant the protective
order? Yes. Okay. And are you asking the court to prohibit him
from going within 200 yards of your residence or place of employment?
Yes. >> Yes. And are you asking that he be prohibited from
engaging in any conduct either online or otherwise that would
harass, annoy, alarm, abuse, or torment or or embarrass you?
Yes. >> Oh, that's crazy. 10 years. That's like um that
might be that's maybe sneaking in covert ahead of the second
amendment stuff, right?
But this is like really broad to get 10 years of like a first
amendment curbing, right? That's actually maybe even worse like
in terms of
like the judge having to weigh like how likely is this guy to
harass this woman or go after this woman if I don't do it. That
might actually be more of a curbing of your like constitutional
rights
than the gun stuff even.
I I do feel it cuz obviously he's going to say things on the
internet and he has to be incredibly by the way this is he has
to mention her directly in this. I do believe this is like directly
he has to directly aim at her. So, it' have to be basically uncontested
that he is directly aiming at her. I think a lot of those previous
tweets wouldn't count in the same way, right? But this is um
this is like a big one. Actually, this is a very big one.
Judge, I've got some video that I just need to queue up. So,
can we take a quick break? Why don't we do that? Let's take a
10-minute recess. Thank you, Judge. And there is a recess that
goes on. Uh I'm not sure what this video is. Uh, so I'm not sure
what it possibly could be, but we are now on to another one.
Okay, let's take our recess real quick.
>> Stick call from Miz. Yep, that's right. That's right,
Miz. >> I got a question. >> Okay, so this is Techone
talking about Pinkchu in the midst of their legal proceedings
where it's likely that Pinkchu can't talk because he's in the
middle of a court case.
Why you think Pink ain't talk about me no more? Y'all ever notice
that? Why? Why y'all think Pink don't talk about me no more?
CUZ SHE KNOWS she's
Cuz SHE KNOWS
she's
call this immediately. >> How's that working out now? You
>> Thank you, Ch. Yes. Let's go. >> All she'll do.
I need somebody with a British accent to call this matter immediately.
Thank you, Chud. Thank you. >> Pin. All she'll do is pin
old tweets. She won't tweet anything new cuz she knows she's
Yep.
Every now and then she tweets a little kitty face.
Won't say which is weird because before she had all this to talk
about.
But man, Pink, if only you knew the I knew. But don't worry,
you'll find out. And what's crazy is Ping and I'm gonna let you
know I would still forgive you if you apologized.
>> Oh, wait until Miz hears his next >> publicly.
Of course. >> That's what's crazy. But you won't. And it's
going to be great to see what happens. But it is a shame because
I hate how you have to act like things were bad. It's truly a
shame. And now you've built your entire image on lies. And do
you know what's going to happen >> Bro, her entire image.
Like I understand like you could say that for some people that
they've done that
but like
I'm going to show you something chat. These numbers don't lie.
Like she's massive.
What do you mean? Her her entire image is people that don't even
know who Techone is. That don't even know that this is Pinkchu.
You realize all these are normies that have no idea what the
any of this is and what's going on. Like this is what Pinkchu
is. is like she is a very very very Oh, you can't see. Sorry.
She's a This is WHO PINK CHU IS.
>> OH, it's just her Instagram. Jesus
>> 74,000 likes. 175,000 likes. And recently, she's blown
up even more.
She's massive.
>> She's not some like
her name isn't just tied. is like someone that I would say her
name is tied to it that I I that I can give an example of is
like Adriana Lee. Like Adriana Lee's entire career in life is
tied to the fact that she tried to accuse Slick of right. She
has nothing else going on for her besides she's a cokehead who
sucks.
There's uh nothing like Pink Chu's audience. >> I guarantee
you no one is talking about this and no one knows who Tech is.
>> I don't think that's totally true. Well, maybe she's
gotten it off of the people who likely popular on other platforms.
She doesn't need Techone. Once she left Teone, she started to
up. >> That's all true. All true. This is all true. Yes.
>> Was anyone even listening to me? >> Oh, that [__]
That is crazy.
I thought you guys You guys come at me for being a cooper when
I'm like when I'm like, "Oh, who is Pink Chu?"
>> Well, this is Pinku.
>> This is like not This is so tame.
So tame. She does self-publish that stuff. So it's like, you
know,
suffice to say, Tom Fury won. I think >> Lucari's girlfriend
went live and said the DMs he reacted to are fake.
Why would someone fake that? What?
The DMs are fake.
>> Oh, this Mujin thing. This guy I reacted to it and like
went crazy.
She's live right now saying it's from you. What?
Saying it's from me. Does that really matter? Like what did I
say? Like
it's lame. Does it really matter?
>> People are uh people are in Misgiv's chat just spamming
the Instagram link. >> Does it really matter? >> That's
crazy work. >> I talked about it for like 10 minutes last
night. It it really doesn't matter. Like
it's we're getting
>> Don't let him derail you. >> She's going to do
that because it would make no sense. Chat, I I really don't.
Back to the transcript. >> Let her She's someone that is
emotional. She's upset. Whatever. Whatever's going on. I do think
she should have reported the thing to the police. I like that's
just it. Like I'm sorry. Um like what I I heard her [__]
Yeah, exactly. I hurt her feelings by by saying that she was
for that. Like >> do not let them derail your >> There's
a lot more important things in that's going on besides me saying
that she was that Lucari had a notepad that had that link or
that >> Oh, is that the girlfriend is accusing Miz of harassment
or something? Maybe we can cover that later. >> I don't.
>> Back to No, Miz, back to the transcript. Miz, back to
the transcript. >> It's over. I That is not my thing. I'm
not talking about it anymore. I don't care. It is It's over.
>> Thank you, Miz. Let's go.
/ soda is illegal in Texas. Yes, it is illegal in Texas regardless
of what's going on. Okay. It's literally tried for as the same
thing as if you didn't know that is specifically in Texas. You
can go to jail for 2 to 10 years for having it. Let's get back
onto the te stuff. This is just completely getting one guy.
cheese beef, I think you're uh I do think you're wrong on this.
You can come in and argue it at some point in the future if you
want, but I actually I actually disagree on that totally. He
basically explains how he had a bias and it led him to like accept
things that led to it kind of being covered up sort of, but it's
a different thing, right? It's him saying, "I just wanted my
friend to be okay and I thought if we could talk about this,
we could figure out exactly what happened and I don't think my
friend like I do think at his core he didn't think his friend
insulted somebody, right?"
And he didn't want like a misunderstanding or going public in
a way that would blow up his friend if he could stop it because
it was his friend, which I don't think is inherently wrong. It
probably what it should be is a signal that you shouldn't be
the one making decisions that
>> All right, I got some video that needs to be queued
up. So, can I We could take a break. They take a break. Okay,
we're proceeding. Yo, Fiend Dog, thank you for the five gifted
subs. I appreciate it.
>> he still shouldn't have sent Mitch and Maya. I mean,
I'm not gonna take away all agency from Mitch and Maya either.
They both went, right?
I'm not taking I'm not taking their agency away. They both went.
They didn't have to go. Miz might have okay it. But the fact
that people think he's like some kind of mob boss who made these
people go, I don't think that's I I don't uh I totally disagree
with that. Yeah. Anyway, I I Yeah, I basically just disagree
with that. I think um everybody made mistakes there. It feels
like except
I guess >> uh but like I said, if I'm wrong, I will publicly
state I'm wrong and I apologize uh because I do think that I
shouldn't have said that. that uh you know if she's if she didn't
say that it's just stuff I will gladly apologize cuz I'm very
sorry about that but
link those DMs and say that they're real I I I don't know. Okay,
gross. Keep moving on. Um
what I'm going to show judge is the clip from what is A38. So
applicants 38 which we'll move to admit in its entirety. We are
not going to show it in its entirety but have a clip set up.
Any objections? Tecton's lawyer. No objections. All right. A38
is admitted. Permission to swag. Permission to publish. You may.
Thank you. The video is played. Mr. Borier, who's Tech's lawyer.
Actually, judge, I should clarify. I haven't viewed this. I don't
have any objections to authenticity. I should reserve objections
to consent, but for time's sake, I'll lodge those objections
if they're necessary. I understand. I Okay, no problem. Lance,
thank you for the
This is now back to Pink Choose Lawyer. And this was done on
and this was published on May 12th, 2025.
Do you recall seeing that stream? I didn't see the stream. I
saw the clips afterwards. They were posted online. Okay. And
these were the clips that were posted specifically. Do you think
these specifically related to you? Yes. He was speaking about
my case. All right. And what are your concerns about, if any,
about his comments of going nuclear? That was just based off
the police report. And so that's why he was publicly anticipating
and cons consistently attacking me. Sorry, can you repeat the
question? So she's nervous and she's on stage. Sure. When he
said what are your concerns about what he would do if anything
when he talked about going nuclear possibly most likely post
the revenge obviously threatening and harassing more and that's
when I got really stressed that it might get to the point where
if it get will get >> Oh, I I do hope that there is some
direct threat of the revenge. So, I don't remember. She said
it was his exact words before or something. Okay. But I
h it's like kind of interesting to me a little bit if that if
that was just going nuclear was that then that's one of the bigger
things that I would be sort of like disappointed by if he and
I don't think we got his own words. I think we got somebody saying
it was his words that he said that, but I don't know if we got
like the messages or the video. And if it was going nuclear,
I'm like, "Oh, I don't
I don't know." >> Dangerous for me to even leave my house
and Okay. And were there Let me back up a little bit.
Have these type of post continued uh the gra granting of the
temporary exparte protective order? Yes, a lot. So, Tecton continued
to post about her even after the temporary uh part protective
order. And are they as descriptive as these particular posts?
Yeah. Yes. All right. And this judge is August 16th of 2025.
It's applicants exhibit 45. Like we've indicated before, we'll
provide the entirety of the recording to the court reporter.
We're just going to show a little segment today. Okay.
The video is played and that was published right around the time
of the protective order application that was filed. Is that right?
I believe so. So, Tech even though even though he has a protective
order, even though she said that she had sent him a cease and
desist 6 months before, he is still talking and on her in August
16th of 2025 with video proof.
I'll move on to another one, judge. We're going to show another
portion and we're going to go mark it as application 46 judge
which is any objections again I at least to authenticity at least
authenticity to the last clip I guess I don't this is Tectton's
lawyer I don't understand what the relevance of any of this was
worrying about being schizophrenic I just I understand the desire
to well I'll strike that I just don't know how this applies over
here >> hold on hold on worrying about being schizophrenic
I just I understand the desire to well I'll strike that Bro,
he was about to say, "I don't know why you would bring up this
guy's mental illness. It just doesn't seem relevant." Then he
like looks at his whole case that he's going to build when he
directly examines her and he's like, "Wait, my entire case is
talking about her mental illness." Oh, I'll shut the [__]
up. Actually, I'll shut my fat mouth right now. Never mind. Withdrawn.
I'll shut the [__] up. >> Here for Okay. How
does this How was that? I think that was the applicant's 45.
How was that? >> Get the [__] out of here,
man. So, >> sure, judge. One of the issues at stake is
that he got untreated mental health condition. It's schizophrenia.
It's pretty serious. He carries firearms. He's bragged about
it online and that he gives her concerns for her safety considering
the continued pattern that he has. In addition, that he's paranoid
about her and admits to seeing hallucinations that he's admitted
to publicly online to over a million streamers. Damn. A million
streamers.
>> A million little streamers. >> Streamer University
is going to be packed this year, boys. a million streamers heard
about Tech. She obviously meant a million viewers, but she said
a million streamers um that he's got following him or followers.
It gives real concern for his her personal safety and >> to
be fair, Tech may actually literally believe a million streamers
are >> Grounds for the protected order to be >> All right.
Objection over rules 45 is admitted. All right. This one is from
January 14th of 2025, two weeks before >> or a year a year
and two weeks before. Judge, I'm trying to move to the next part,
but my it's not timestamped.
All right. When you listen to that, what did you hear know him?
What did you know him to be referring to? Me. So, this is Pinkchu
saying that whatever video was played was about Pingchu.
And how'd you know it was a case? He was talking about the case.
And this was done in January 2025. Yes. And this is the kind
of content that has been harassing you. Yes. And tell the court
what it does to harass you when you post this kind of content.
It's degrading. It's scary. It's embarrassing. And I think that
actually might be uh the one that we just saw, which is the one
that
I think it's this >> those lies crumble pink. You lose
>> Oh, because you're Oh, dude. Oh, watching this back
now is just so so >> I think this is this moment >> delicious
to watch this back now. >> So, Tee basically threatening
Pingchu that she's going to lose the court case and he's going
to be uh winning and that she's screwed. This guy has schizophrenia
and guns and she's scared for her life. Okay. And tell the court
what it does to you when he posts this kind of content. It's
degrading. It's scary. It's embarrassing. Like I don't think
anybody wants somebody consistently just calling them these things
publicly for everyone. They're
basis. And did he
this stream was really bad. Is this the whole [__]
stream? >> Is this This is like the whole stream. Dude,
we should maybe just go cover this whole stream. This whole stream
where he's got this picture of what appears to be Jesse Lee Peterson
on his stream. This whole stream right here is like rough. Or
is it m Maybe it's even multiple streams. Hold on.
Cuz I've got this one right here. These are different >> You
got lies trying to ruin your life BECAUSE SHE'S BITTER. >> OH,
LOOK at that,
>> Man, I'm shocked. >> Now, here's hoping you you
don't have two exes that talk. Then people will say, "Well, if
two people that hate you both say the same thing, it must be
>> in February 2025."
>> MAN, IMAGINE THAT.
>> OH, THAT'S why Hold on. >> It must be >> That's
why he's That's why Chippy Reviews is defending him.
>> Oh, let's go. This is not something I ever want to talk
about or make public because nobody wins with me making personal
my personal life public. However, allegations have forced my
hand. I have evidence to prove I was physically and mentally
abused by my
I'm done.
Oh. Oh.
Uh, that's why Chippy Reviews is is getting him on the flip side
here. He's get catching him on the flippy flop.
One one allegation defense for one allegation defense. Trade
deal offered. Okay, let's go.
Very cool.
Sorry, this I think it's the same stream. Let me see here. Does
he have that same thing when he goes out to his full view? He
does. Interesting. Okay,
dude. This guy This guy was seething a lot all the time. Just
constantly seething about >> Did he ever I'm sorry. >> Do
you believe that he was doing this intentionally knowing it's
going to harm you? I believe he is doing this to harm me and
because I went to the police, he just wants me to let it go.
So, Pingchu and rightfully so, believes that Techone is saying
these threats online because it's like he is going to lose. Um,
and she's going to win. So, he's basically like, "Look, I'm not
going to release everything I have on you." He's not showing
his hand. He's going, "Look, I have some crazy [__]
on you, Pink, and I'm going to ruin your life and prove everything's
right. So, you better drop this case or I'm going to show the
the truth and the reality of who you are." And the truth and
reality that Teone hand the entire time was actually just his
hand alone. Techone uh provided 15 minutes of tweet. >> Yeah,
but Miz Teone's empty hand could be anything to Tech. It could
be all the proof. Listen, man.
His hand was melting. It had the proof there and now his hand
is melting. Miz >> to the judge. So, we'll keep going on
that and I know that's going to be coming up very soon.
>> Okay. In fact, and we won't get into all of it, but
you actually created a timeline that has everything that he actually
posts on you over the course of a year. And it's how voluminous
is it? 200 pages. And that's just a timeline, right? Yes. And
do you believe that you will be safe if the court does not grant
you the protective order? Absolutely not. Do you believe that
he will engage in a continued pattern of harassment or if you
this protective order is not granted? Yes. All right. I passed
the witness. All right, Mr. Porier. Thank. >> Okay, this
is where the cross starts with Tectton's lawyer
Pinkychu or Pinkchu. So, we're gonna listen to that. Do we know
did Legal Mindset do her whole examination, too? Cuz I could
have sworn when I was watching Legal Mindset. I thought he basically
I thought Tees lawyer went first, which I thought was weird.
So, I don't know. Did he not do any of the the pink stuff? It's
fine. Here, >> Thank you, your honor. I'll be >> So
now this is Tee's lawyer interviewing Pinkchu. Okay,
>> this is now it has changed. It is now Tech's lawyer
is interviewing Pinkchu.
Pinkchu, I'm going to ask you some questions. If I ask you something
that's confusing or in any way doesn't make sense, just let me
know. Okay. Okay. And you go by Black. Black was a Runescape
streamer. I go by Pinkchu. What's that? I go by Pinkchu.
Huh? It's my middle name. Is that how you want to be addressed?
Yes, please. Okay. All right. Pinch you wide hard. Rinado. I
want to take a second. All of those exhibits that your attorney
just admitted, can you point out to me where in those exhibits
it mentions blank blank Pinchu pink or blank? So, he's basically
saying, where does it mention you at all in a lot of these exhibits?
In in my timeline, there is multiple situations, pages blank.
I want to take a second and review all these exhibits. Can you
tell me where in those exhibits it mentions Pink Pink Jew or
anything about you at
>> Are you speaking uh are you speaking of those printed
ones
>> or the ones that were on screen either? >> I do
not believe in the short clip
>> chat. Check Pink Chu's latest Instagram story. Hold
on. Link
>> was mentioned in the clip section. Okay, I agree with
you. Can you point out for the court any time in any of these
admitted exhibits where it mentions pink pink chew or pink not
that was shown? Okay, I agree with you. You would agree with
me that well strike that. Has John ever text messaged you since
the application? Well, have you ever >> is he going to
wait
>> with you? You would agree with me that well strike that
>> I feel like he was about to argue as well. He might
have been about to argue, wait, like because he you weren't mentioned
by name, how do you even think it's you? Why why would we believe
it's you? When
another big part of his case is going to be that when she didn't
tweet about him specifically. Oh, that's where he's going to
go. Okay. I don't even know. I don't know if this favors anyone.
I don't know why you take >> until the protective order
was filled that you didn't want him to contact you. >> Yes.
Okay. How did you do that? How did you communicate that from
my own mother? Okay. So, you had your mom call him and say, "She
doesn't want to call you anymore." He called my mom. Okay. And
was that conversation recorded in any way? No. But I believe
there were was it memorized in text messages in any way? Yes.
In writing? I believe they were in text messages. I don't know
if that's what she said it over the phone or through text. Picture
should have had that ready. Okay. And I would assume if it's
in text, you have a copy of them. No, they're going to use that
against her. Okay. until the strike that since the protective
order has been filed. Has John texted you? No. Has he emailed
you? No. Has he called you? No. Has he communicated with you
by social media? Are you speaking of since the temporary order?
Facebook Messenger over direct messages on Instagram. >> So,
no direct messages, which I don't even think any of us deny.
Hold on. This is Pink's latest story. Okay.
>> Wow. Wow. >> Any communications at all? My confusion
is are you a protective order?
>> Correct. Since you filed the application for protective
order and the temporary protective order was granted. >> No.
Okay. I do not believe so. Has he talked to you through LinkedIn,
WhatsApp? Just going through all the social medias. Has he have
you seen him outside your house in your neighborhood? No. Has
he approached you? No. Okay. I want to ask you again. How did
your relationship with John start? Who contacted you? I reached
out to him because his friend asked me to reach out to him. Okay.
But your friend didn't type out in media messages the social
media to John. Correct. No.
You messaged John. Is that Yes.
And when you message John, you all begin a romantic relationship?
No. In December. What was that? Oh, no. When I messaged him,
no. At some point following that message to John, you entered
into a romantic relationship sometime between December of 2022
and let's say July of 2024. So two and a half years. Yes. >> At
some point.
>> You guys were a couple. Is that fair? Yes. Okay. Well,
I just want to clarify because you provided some testimony on
You think she was eating spaghetti to attack so you would hallucinate
and see her eating intestines? Jesus Christ. No. The only reason
you slept together was because he was he had a mental health
diagnosis where he didn't want to sleep alone. I mean, you guys
were a couple. Is that fair? >> Yes. Okay. I just want
to clear that up because the implication from that was that you
were roommates, but you were only sleeping together because he
was scared of the dark or something like that. I mean, you guys
were a couple and you slept together in the same bed like couples
do. I preferred a lot of times to sleep upstairs. Okay. Have
you ever expressed something different in a text message to John?
I believe it was over Snapchat. I would tell him, "I'm working
or I'm going to sleep upstairs." Okay, I'll just say it for the
purposes of our
I'm familiar with the text message history between you guys.
I mean, you guys again, you were a couple and you slept in the
same bed.
>> This is going to be I don't know where you're going
with this cuz I don't I don't think you'd ever be able to determine
something here. I feel like he's gonna say like, "Didn't you
say I I feel like he would have messages possibly of Pink saying,
"No, no, no. I like sleeping with you. Like, it's all good. I
just sometimes go up to my like she would explain why it wasn't
a problem that he would ask her to sleep with him." But it sounds
like it could easily be the case that she likes sleeping alone
or she had an easier time sleeping if she was alone. Right. But
then if he says, "Well, I have schizophrenia. I'm scared to sleep
by myself." Then she's probably going to try to soothe that that
anxiety, right? Like, "Oh, well, I it's cool. I like sleeping
in your bed, too." >> Yes. Periodically we did. It was
both. Okay. Did you engage in consensual intimate encounters?
There were times before I moved in. Yes. Okay. And I think that's
fair to say. Well,
strike that. Your date of birth is blank, right? Yes, that's
correct. You made a statement. Well, strike that. From a personal
perspective, do you want partners to be invested in your career
goals? Supportive. So, Pinchu wants a supportive person in her
life. Okay, great. Thank you for clarifying. Do you want them
to be supportive of your career goals? Yes. And John was supportive
of your career goals. Is that fair? You testified about him wanting
to kind of promote your presence online to try to help you achieve
more visibility, more popularity. Those are all things you wanted,
Pink. Is that fair? I think so. Yes.
Okay. And John was supportive of that. Yes. Okay. If you had
a partner that wasn't supportive of your career goals, that wouldn't
be a very good sign of a mutually supportive relationship. is
that >> so building the direction of like this was a real
relationship where he cared about you and was not one that was
coercive, right? But unfortunately
like if the judge is up on stuff I I don't think you know being
supportive is necessarily
dispositive of being coercive in some way either. Right. >> That
correct? Yes. Okay. But the inclination on direct was that him
wanting you to help you out that was a bad thing for whatever
reason. It was the dynamic. It was about the pi power dynamic.
Okay. That he had more fans online and you didn't. He had more
control over not just online but also with companies and stakes
and companies and partners. She's talking about mythic talent
friend groups in the Austin Circle because of that sense and
um >> in general just basically streaming as a >> Okay.
I mean it could correct me if I'm wrong. It sounds like he was
leveraging that influence he had in your industry to help your
career out. Is that fair? Yeah. Okay. >> Uh okay. I It's
funny that this guy's going like, "Uh, would a real boyfriend
like would a real boyfriend like help your career in exchange
for Would would a guy just do that? Would he like would he Isn't
it like proof that he cared about you because you know you help
he helped your career? Um, I mean, he might have been doing it
in exchange for something like you don't know what his motives
are necessarily." Anyway, I just it's not necessarily that. I'm
just saying he's building this direction. I hope he builds something
out to like make some conclusive statements cuz he's just asking
questions that sort of cast out doubt but don't actually build
in a direction and help. >> Was John physically abusive
to you in what way? Would he hit you? He did shove my head into
his crotch one time. Okay. Would he strike you with his hand?
No. Can he kick you? No. >> How could you possibly say
he helped you in your career for for
when he helped you? Didn't he help you? How could you possibly
say he helped you in exchange for favors? How could you possibly
what?
>> Okay. When did this this alleged abuse
>> The coercion began when I moved in and it got more aggressive
as time went on. >> Okay. When I moved into the Chestnut
Ridge Road. So, is this December of 2022?
No. That's when you guys met? Yes. Okay. When did you think you
started dating? I believe a couple weeks after we met. Okay.
So maybe at the end of December, beginning of January, something
like that. Sometime in December, I can't remember. Okay. And
when did the alleged coercion, when did that begin? When I moved
into Chestnut Ridge Road address, which is exactly what she said
before. Okay. And I apologize. I don't know when that was. Do
you remember like a month and a year? I believe it was possibly
February of the next year of 2024. So she's saying basically
uh the alleged coercion and things didn't really occur for the
first year. It really got bad when they moved into the their
house together.
February of 2024. Okay. That's when the coercion began. Yes.
When I wasn't paying rent and we were into a new home.
Okay. And in your
>> interesting that basically cutting off before February
of 2024 is like cutting off the entire of the relationship before
that where she thought it was
>> you state that around February or March of 2023, you
told John that you didn't want to live by this agreement anymore.
What agreement was that? I wasn't paying a rent in my perspective.
I thought it was because I was going to help him with the thumbnails
and graphics. And then he started during intimacy that it was
for not that I wasn't paying rent because I was giving him. And
he stated in quotes, "Do your job. You don't pay rent." But it
sounds like it sounds like you guys were already in a romantic
relationship by that point. That's why I was disgusted and confused.
It's a fair point. Okay. What was disgusting? >> Dude,
this is it just me or does this lawyer suck at crossing?
This lawyer like sucks, man. >> And confusing. >> Techto,
YOU PAID TOO MUCH MONEY. TECHTO, you up. >> That I thought
I was his girlfriend, but he's treating me like a prostitute.
Pretty fair to say they never had in two years of dating. Um,
and at that point, she didn't have sex with him. He never pleasured
her. He was only wanting the entire time. So she fought back
on the lawyer saying it is just disgusting and confusing. And
did you break up with him at that point? I told him I wanted
to pay rent. I hoped it would stop after that. I had already
Oh, I forgot a lot of this. So I watch a little bit of this through
legal mindsets point of view. This is often going to break down
to wait. So you had a problem with him and you didn't break up.
Well, that why would you not break up? If you had like if you
thought this was disgusting, why wouldn't you break up with him?
It's like well hold on depending on they were in a relationship
for two years honestly in a relationship for two years sometimes
one partner like I don't want to I don't have personal examples
of this but I do know people who have like one of the partners
create commits what is obviously a crime against the other one
okay
and in a two-year to plus relationship sometimes you like go
to counseling you get help you figure out how to move past that
right
like in terms of mutual like mutual abuse partner like messy
relationships that do end up stabilizing
can happen. It doesn't a lot of people don't break up their long-term
relationship because somebody did something bad to the other
>> Sold all my items in my home, canceled my lease like
he asked and I felt stuck and it's not that easy to just move
out. Okay. Did you you were you were working online. You were
I think doing some modeling, doing some acting and I again I'm
not deeply familiar with the kind of this world but there's is
that genuinely what you were doing?
I was doing Yeah. like streaming modeling. Okay. And your income
streams from that? It was not as high as it got later on than
I began and only fans. Okay. But there was an income stream.
Yes. But it was not that high. Correct. But my question was there
was income as a whole. >> Huge. You were making money.
And that's certainly if the situation was coercive enough. If
it was bad enough, you could have moved out. Is that
>> And certainly if you were being like
you would have just left, right? And certainly if you were being
like groomed or manipulated in some way, you would just leave,
right? And certainly like if this guy was manipulative in any
way, you would have just left. No, that's not how it works. There's
literally tons of documentary evidence showing that women in
abusive relationships don't leave. They they often do not leave.
>> Fair? No, because like I said, he does have a lot of
power and control in the power dynamic. >> Like, and this
is something you have to take. I understand people think the
power dynamic thing is cringe. It's not. This guy's like the
OTK streamer. It's why probably
It's why it's actually difficult as like a big streamer to date
like a small streamer or something, right? Because you don't
know exactly how that works when things go and get bad. Like
that small streamer might be trying to make it in that industry
and then you they might be scared if I break up with this
I might just like be I might be done.
It's what makes it really difficult,
right? So just dismissing it is probably stupid. I just felt
like I was just doing to start paying rent and you know that
was going to stop and I was going to hopefully move on from that.
Hassan got banned.
Zon do be getting banned. Okay, back to the transcript. Miz,
>> he said Zionist pigs.
I don't know what that means. Okay, let's keep going.
>> Because like I said, he does have a lot of power and
control over the power dynamic. I just felt like I was going
to start paying rent and you know that was going to stop and
I was going to hopefully move on from that. >> Okay. But
John wasn't keeping you in the home. He wasn't physically keeping
you in the home. How so? Explain the physically keeping. This
is Pingchu.
I'll strike that. And you
>> This This looks so bad when you read the transcript
where he's like She's like, "Wait, what do you mean? He kind
of was keeping me." The guy's like, "I'll strike that. Wait,
I don't want to go down." Dude, I I feel like it looks
It looks like bad. I don't know if it is bad. It might just be
like, "Oh, I'm not getting the answer I was looking for." So,
that might be a really normal thing. I don't know. >> Reported
this alleged sexual abuse to the Austin Police Department. Yes.
When was that? I believe it was early 2025.
And the detective, James Thrift. Does that name sound familiar?
Yes. He was the detective assigned. Is that correct? Okay. And
what is surprised you of the investigation that has been suspended?
I suspended it. You suspended it? Yes. Okay. So, what it was
your request to suspend the investigation?
Due to all the threats and harassment, I couldn't do what the
officer was requesting for my safety. >> Okay. But you
proceeded with filing a protective order. Yes. And hopefully
after the protective order, if I feel safe and comfortable enough,
I'll probably most likely reopen the case.
Damn. So, she is saying that
>> I feel like
as much as she could do that, I feel like she's going to move
on personally.
Um,
like I said, despite unless unless the evidence they have, right,
unless the evidence they have is literally the videos from Tetto's
phone where she looks like she's super not into stuff and he
like as accidentally like kept recording the ones and kept the
ones where he asked her to like smile or something. Unless it's
like that bad, I feel like it would be difficult to litigate
that case. It would be very very difficult. Um, I'm not saying
I'm not trying to say she shouldn't. If she feels like she wants
to, she absolutely should, right?
She moves on. Tectone one. Uh, Teone is raped no matter what.
Tectone is eternally raped. He is eternally and rape tone. Hero
is overdosing. But,
uh, anyway,
it's
I I feel like she'll just move on. I feel like she doesn't want
anything to do with this guy. And it she could get justice. I
just I in a lot of these cases, it's just like, dude, what are
you It sucks. But it's like, dude, what are you what do you get
out of it? Even if you even if you win, what do you get out of
it?
Just the idea that you could like say
I think she literally wants to forget this part of her life existed.
I don't necessarily blame her on that
right >> after this that she's probably going to go for
criminal on techone because she's now going to finally feel safe
of not the harassment and relax a little bit. So, she's going
to open the case again for criminal.
Whoa. She might.
Well, because she filed the case two years ago, so she might
go criminal. Um, that's crazy. >> Full full support, by
the way. If she wants to go criminal, full support on that one.
>> That's That's big.
Okay. I want to ask you about another police report that you
filed. This one was back in February 12th, 2024. And you called
the Leander Police Department. Is that correct? Yes.
And at the time of the report, you were residing with John at
Oh, is it Venzia Au? Does that sound familiar? Yes. Okay. At
the time you're residing with John? Yes. And you made that report
because John's ex-wife Jessica who's frame has messaged John
something like, "Is she better than me?"
That is not why I made the police report. That wasn't my question.
Okay. Did John's ex-wife message him something like, "Is she
is she better than me?" That is what I was told. I didn't see
it. So Tech told uh Pinkchu that Freen said, "Is she better than
me?"
>> But that's what you were understanding was was Jessica
told John. Was that
>> Do you see how the lawyer I pointed this out earlier,
he's trying very hard to stay away from the fact, the material
facts, and just focus on what she thinks, right? >> Yes.
Okay. And you made a report on the biased of a suspicion that
Jessica had videos of you and John engaged in intimate activities.
Yes. And you believe that she had those recordings from what
I was told? Yes. So, Teone told Pingchu is what Pingchu is saying.
She told he told Pinchu that Fe has recordings of them and that
she needs to be stopped because they were while they were engaged
in intimate activities that they need to stop Fe.
Okay. And you believe that he told you because your next actions
was to call the police. That was not the timeline of events though.
Correct. It was about 14 months after he told you. Is that fair?
It was after multiple people have told me that they were sent
that after multiple people were sent were what? Stated that they
went or were sent
So this is the whole thing in that like
apparently
so what I think happened what I think the confusion is here.
What I think happened was the footage that was sent was the same
footage we all saw. We all saw this at some point maybe a couple
months ago, right? Where it's pink and techone going to the house,
getting to the car, and going into the house. I think that Pink
was essentially told
that a video view was sent by Free to a bunch of people. Intimate
video, right? And I do believe it was Free saying, "Tectone's
cheating on me," which also might not have been true. Like she
might have broken up with Teone at that point, but that video
was was communicated to Pinky as like a video, something like
her giving a [__] or something and that's why she
filed the case. Okay. Did And those multiple people, did they
ever provide you any of that footage? No. Okay. So, you don't
have any independent video or verification that anybody had any
footage ever? Is that fair? No. There was some footage. It just
wasn't.
>> Okay. But to be clear, you never saw any footage. No,
I was believing John and his friends. Okay. When did when did
Jessica tell message that to John to your understanding?
>> So what happened here, right, is
basically Frame was upset that when when Tek was supposed to
go to Frame's house for like Christmas or something, she was
supposed to go with with Frame to her families,
right?
I believe Teetone canceled
and then on their Ring cameras you could see Tectton and Pink
go to Tecton's house and so she messaged and was upset and said
something along the lines of that's huge. That's that means mythic
talent was literally lying about this. Oh, if you want to explain
that to me, Shimu, I' I'd love to hear more. But
so Taton lied to Frame about what he was doing that night, why
he was busy, and I think she would have messaged and said something
like, "Oh,
um, is she better than me?" Right? And so what Teton did was
I believe this this coming out. I believe this is the case that
he took that to say, "Look, she sent me some like she she has
like videos of us doing something crazy like like us or obviously
not actually you blowing me. It's the only thing they did." And
he told Pink this. And Pink didn't ever get a chance to see the
video. You talk right now? Okay, hold on. I'll hop on here just
a second. I'll call you. I'll call you.
Shimu is calling in. This is apparently a revelation.
Very interesting. Okay. What's up, Shimu? How's it going? >> Hey,
can you hear? >> Hold on. Uh, you're not coming through
my Discord. My Discord's Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait. Hold on.
>> Okay, you should be able to hear me now. Sorry. I had
a
but >> so the so this was always like my hypothesis that
it was like them coming out of a car something like that but
if it's in a court filing she's saying in a court filing that
there was no revenge the reason why that's so huge
is because there were several people in the court filing of her
suing Frame that were basically added as witnesses that Fe had
sent revenge forms to all these different people. Yeah. And one
of them includes the CEO of Mythic Talent.
>> Sure. Yeah.
>> The CEO of Mythic Talent, Cuco, who's like Lucari's
person, she also said that she had was sent this stuff. >> And
then there was one other one. And I I asked them about this,
all of them that were listed. I never got a response
>> um
to to say like, "Yes, this was true. No, this is false."
So, I mean, like, if this is in a court filing now where she's
saying like, "No, it never existed." I mean, does that mean,
you know, that possibly like the Mythic Talent CEO like lied
about this? I mean, I don't know if they would just put it on
a court filing that, yeah, he, you know, got received this material.
That'd be pretty crazy just to include that in a lawsuit.
>> Well, I also think she's probably talking about what
Tech said to her here. So, I don't know how much of this is reliable
about other people seeing it. But with let's say Qo is our example
here because I think I know what Qo got sent and it's this video
of them in the driveway or whatever, right?
>> But I think what Pink was told was it was sent to other
people. I think Qo is one of them, right? And when we remember
this, what I think happened is the lie Quo is referring to here
is that Tee was cheating. That she didn't realize that technically
Teone and Frame had broken up and maybe they were trying to get
something back together, but this wasn't really cheating. And
I think that's the lie she's referring to here. And I think the
video she got sent to show Quo that Teone was cheating was the
video of them walking into the house,
right? And then after people are hearing about this video and
everybody's getting upset with Teone and it's all getting litigated
behind the scenes, I think somewhere along the way he basically
tells Pink it's a video and uses the message from Frame to back
that up to get her to go after Frame.
>> Okay. But you're not referring you uh cuz you pulled
up this says cuco called frame and scoldled her for lying and
frame admitted that the serious false al I mean that's not what
you're talking about right like that's different from the recording.
>> No I think the serious false allegation against techone
cuz this is pink reading this out or writing this right this
is her filing. I think the serious allegation that was a lie
was that he was cheating. He was a cheater. He cheated on >> No
no no. the serious and false al if you read the court paper the
serious and false allegations were going to be allegations that's
why this was like so serious with everything
>> so I that's what I thought too >> I but here how
do we how do we know that cuz I I think in here they're trying
to paint that picture >> I do in this civil filing I think
they're trying to paint that picture they've retracted this civil
filing right like Pink took this back so why didn't Pink pursue
this if this were all the case would be my
if this like if it was actually the case that Frame had like
I guess maybe no
I I think at some point we realized >> I think this is
just later in the law this is just later in the lawsuit. Yeah.
No, there was but I think this is later in the lawsuit than the
recordings and stuff cuz this was when that they talk about that
Frame was going to release a serious like Google document over
Yep. >> Yeah. So, but I think that's what's they're referring
to because Cuco was under the
>> That's what they're trying to say.
>> But I >> that's what they're trying to say. >> I
unless Unless
Unless you have some information or reason to believe that Frame
was making that up beyond this is this like do you think Frame
totally made that allegation up?
>> Is that your belief now? >> Free No, I don't believe
that Free made up her ala.
No, I don't believe that. These are so right here. >> Sorry,
you're confusing me with the revenge stuff and then the the allegation
that Frame was going to make against Tech.
>> So the allegation that Frame was going to make against
Teone. Do you think Frame made that up?
>> Okay. So that's I think they're trying to paint this
as the allegation that allegation against Tee is false and that
>> like intimated to Cuo that she lied about it. I I am
lying about it. I made it all up. Yeah, but we don't believe
that, right? And so I think the thing that
is probably acknowledging that she lied about was
one possibly the idea that she had the video, but I thought it
was more that she was alleging that Teone was a cheater. That's
in my opinion what she was um probably lying about. What do you
think she was lying about that she acknowledged to Qo that she
was lying
Admitted to lying and manipulating me about the whole thing.
>> I don't know. I mean, they have DMs in there, but does
she say like that she lied? Like Ko is claiming that, but I maybe
it is like the cheater thing. It's It's kind of weird because
the timeline's super weird. I mean, Free filed for divorce well
before like I think that Free filed for divorce in like uh November
and then uh Pink and Tech started dating in like December or
something. But >> yeah, but I think Frame like Frame So
if I'm remembering correctly, Tee and Frame wanted to meet up.
There was something they were going to go to her families or
something, right? So, is it possible they were trying to reconcile?
>> Maybe. Yeah, I guess that's true. There was there was
supposed to be some Christmas meet up or something, but just
for Christmas, I don't really know. >> He cancelled literally
to hang out with >> And that's the video is that day Pink
and Tech going to the house on the day that he canceled with
Frame.
>> And so to me, I think Frame was telling people we were
trying to reconcile. We were trying to fix it and Teone or maybe
not even reconcile. She might have left that part out. She could
have maybe just been saying he cheated on me. He's a piece of
he cheated on me. That's what I think happened here is I think
but in the document it appears to me that they're trying to say
that they're trying to use this as proof that Frame lied not
about that but about the allegation that that allegation is a
lie. I think they're trying to paint it that way in this document.
>> Okay. I'm on the same page with you now. I understand.
Yeah, it took me a minute. Sorry. Um >> no worries. But
yeah, no, that that's possible. Yeah, because I always found
it weird like, you know, a rape allegation is very serious and
if this person had DMs of them like talking about this, like
why weren't those included? You know, if Cuo sent over like all
this stuff,
why
wasn't any of that included in this suit? Yeah, I do think that
if if Teone truly believed that he was, you know, because this
is how Legal Mindset presented it was that the allegation is
Frame made the whole thing up, right? That whole thing made up.
If Tee truly believed that, I don't know why. I mean, maybe it's
the NDA.
Maybe it might be the NDA, right?
I don't think that it's entirely made up. Or I think the fact
that Ko's never come forward and like cleared his name on it
is a little weird, too.
I think people involved with this mitigated out.
>> Yeah, there's several people that should like actually
clarifi I like I asked them for clarification
and there's they're stated in a lawsuit, right? They're stated
as witnesses for this and like none of them, you know, it's none
of them want to like clear it up at all, which >> I mean
at this point I feel like you should, you know what I mean? I
don't know. But >> yeah, um, Kuroko says, "This case is
so twisted up in Thory." No, it's not. This is actually a separate
issue almost entirely. Yeah. The only way it's related now is
that because of what Tee told Pink here and the fact that Pink
filed this lawsuit, I think I think they're going to use this
lawsuit and Pink trying to help Tee as a basis for saying Tee
couldn't possibly be abusive. That's the only way it's related
now. But this is something else that's interesting on the side
that I do think should be like actually somebody should get to
the bottom of it because somebody here is like lying really badly.
Somebody here is like a totally manipulative liar and now it's
like starting to get, you know, everybody's litigating this publicly.
I think it should be figured out. And it's pretty easy if you
just had everybody in a room here, you would know for sure who
the liars are,
>> Yeah. And there was another person on there too named
um >> it was like sin something and she was in this lawsuit
uh
>> supporting Pink. But then later when Pink came out and
said that she was manipulated to attack Teone's ex-wife and she
made her own allegations then Sin said that like well these were
the exact same stories that I was told. >> I was looking
for that tweet. >> Yes. Um that I she didn't know the two
people were connected. She didn't know they were talking about
the same person. Why can't I remember her name right now? It's
like uh >> it's sin something. I've got everything >> It's
sin. Yeah, she says like she's the sinful VTuber. The V the Ah,
god damn it. Why can't I figure this out now? I just had this
up yesterday. >> Give me a sec. I'll get up.
>> It's Oh, kitnetic. Ketic the sin >> Yeah, it's
kinetic. The sin influencer. Yes, kitic.
>> But I couldn't find the >> kinetic damning.
She says, "It's pretty damning that two women I was very close
to told me that the same exact story about the same man without
having ever spoken to one another to the last detail going back
years before they ever even knew the other woman existed. The
same gaslighting, narcissistic, manipulative cycle of abuse.
So, it was really interesting and I never got that uh totally
cleared up either, but I have like a better idea with that."
But um it was interesting that she was in the lawsuit with Pink
and everything and then once that happened it kind of seemed
like she was like oh she believed Frame kind of thing, right?
Maybe she didn't believe Fe at first but then when Pink went
through the same thing she's like this is the exact same [__]
But >> Yeah. I mean, >> go ahead. >> That I
really wish like Mythic Talent, like the CEO of Mythic Talent
would clarify whether he had not because listen, if they knew
it was a lie, right? And they knew that they were involved in
this lawsuit, they're literally like lying about one of their
own clients cuz she was still contracted with Mythic Talent.
They're making up a lie in a freaking lawsuit to like go after
somebody like if they knew it wasn't revenge or whatever. They
were like aware of that. That's insane that a CEO would be included
in that and and not say anything. You know what I mean? >> Mhm.
Yeah. I do think it would be weird. Yeah. But I again it's also
they're in a business, right? That's like could actually be really
bad for their bottom line. Uh so I I get it. It's like obviously
morally bad though. >> Yeah. But anyways, I that's all
I wanted to talk about. I just I just uh hope that one of those
people that are involved in that can clear that because that's
the one thing where it's like okay, what exactly happen? And
if if Pink is saying in court, this never happened, da da da
da da, then it's like, okay, then what exactly was going on with
the previous lawsuit? What did they know? Did these people cuz
they were sent the video, they know what's in the video. You
know what I mean? So >> yeah, it is it is actually important.
Yeah, it's I don't know. It's it's quite po important. It's not
frame sister. No. Um, if anybody has the kitetic time stamp as
well, can I get the kitnetic call with Miz? I would like to see
that if we can cuz I am now
I am
I feel like my read on this is totally correct. I that's how
I feel is I think I think like the previous lawsuit that's being
used to sort of like muddy the waters right now. I don't think
it means what it means or what they're saying it means. And I
feel like I want to get to the bottom of it. Sorry, I'm repeating
myself. And it's so it's so disingenuous to use this
>> because I mean she came out after they and she said
I was manipulated to attack your ex I mean and in the lawsuit
you you can see that like as soon as the
allegations are going to be made public that's when Pink files
a police report like that is the direct response to the allegations
possibly coming out. Like Tetone freaked out. He went to all
the creators that knew behind the scenes like Soda Poppin and
all these people to try to say, "Hey, you know, I didn't I didn't
do anything to this girl." D Pink files a police report and then
shortly after all this lawsuit stuff happens and it's all in
response to the allegations against Tech.
So, it's pretty obvious when you watch Pink's stream and stuff
that she's attacking Fream for Tech. She's doing this for Tech.
It's not like she had any allegations against her. She's never
even met Frame or talked to her at this point. So, uh, it's pretty
obvious that Teone was using Pink to attack his ex-wife and like
do these things to try to mitigate any possibility of that Google
Doc becoming public of her talking about, uh, her alleged abuse
and from Techone. So, but >> talk to you later, Jere. >> Yeah,
we'll talk to you later. Well, I was just going to say ND was
successful because they signed an NDA. So, like Pink's never
going to be able to discuss it or not for a while. So, >> unfortunate.
Yeah. >> Anyway, yeah, thanks for coming on. >> Talk
to you later. >> Yeah, later, man. See you.
Okay, we continue. We continue. We continue. Thank you, Shimu,
for coming >> the first time. So, Pink Shu is basically
saying
Teeone and his friends told her that Fe has really bad videos
about them and that she needs to do something about it and that
it's disgusting and he needs she needs to stop him.
>> Okay.
Yeah. I that's that is my impression as well is that and it seems
like what she's trying to get out here and the lawyer doesn't
really want that right that she's been told that and I I believe
this message that the lawyer is bringing up the message where
she says is she better than me I believe that was spun to manipulate
Pink into believing that it was nature or nature when it was
So this was in December of 2022. Okay. And is that when you learned
about it? I didn't understand the full context. I just knew it
was some footage, something going on, but I didn't understand
the full context. Okay,
this is Mr. Foyer. This is Tech's uh lawyer. Judge, may I approach?
You may.
Have you ever had a different position on that or when you learned
about that footage? I was just told or that message that it was
me giving him a [__] but I didn't. Like, how if I
I was inside the garage or that it was outside the garage, like
the full context of it because I've never seen it myself. Okay,
let me back it up. When did you learn about the messages that
Jessica sent John? Something to the effect of, "Is she better
than me?" When did you learn about that? December 2020. I can
I see I have the whole the whole thing in my brain. Exactly as
I laid it out to Shimu.
It's exactly what it was. That they were probably talking about
reconciling in some way. That Tetone cancels on Christmas to
hang out with Pink instead.
They go buy the ring camera. Pink sends that video says, "Is
she better than me? Is she like she's jealous?" Which I understand.
Even if you think techone, you think your partner, you will still
get jealous about somebody you're in a long-term relationship.
Moving on, right? So, I I get it. And she sends that message.
And at some point, that message is twisted in a way to make it
seem like, oh, actually, this person's going to accuse me of
something. Well, I hope you know that this is she's basically
threatening you with revenge. You should hate this woman. You
don't hate this woman enough. >> 22. He said that she called
and said that. So this is right when they started hanging out
and right when they started
>> Just more examples of Teone, in my opinion, examples
of Teone being
It just the the examples they keep popping up. They keep popping
up over and over again.
>> Okay. I believe. And when did you take what did you
take from that? I was disturbed. And was Jessica there? Jessica
there? Was Jessica in the home when you guys engaged in intimate
activity with each other? No. So, the implication from that message
to John was that she was viewing what you guys were doing in
the same house uh house, same place else. Is that fair? Yes.
Okay. Did that concern you? Yes. Okay. And you learned about
that in December of 2022?
Yes. You didn't report it to the police for some 14 months until
February of 2024?
Yes. Okay. And on that date, you spoke with officer Alyssa Hoffman.
Do you remember that name? Yes. And she's an officer with the
Leander Police Department. Is that correct? >> So, what
was that? Until 2024. Okay. >> Yes. And you reported to
>> So, they're they're going to try to use this where I
guess Frame didn't think about going to the cops. She wasn't
sure what her rights were or something,
What happens around February 2024
where it becomes critical for FEM
to file this report
right where that becomes critical
I think Shimu just gave us the answer it seems to be the idea
that behind the scenes
well actually I don't even know for sure
bro when when was Frame talking about this with the document
stuff man we got to hammer this timeline out seems like for some
reason around this time things had to be
Pinky Pink had to be deployed to deal with Frame, right?
When When are the dates on a lot of these YouTube or sorry the
the like live stream stuff where Frame made some comments? God,
we might have to go back to the Shimu video and get some timestamps
on this stuff cuz
Techone weaponizes his girlfriend. Okay, wife leaves him.
>> After a back and forth on Twitter about Frame being
>> This is February 2024.
No way. You cannot make this [__] up, man. You cannot
make this [__] up. February 2024 is around the time
we're seeing this stuff being deploy being brought up again.
Okay.
And then we go over to the lawsuit. February 2024.
You suddenly are talking to this officer
Absolutely
crazy.
So, I wonder if we're going to hear anything about how TeeOne
suddenly was like, "Wait, you she like she she's like a of you.
She sent it around to a bunch of people. You got to do something
about this. She's going to destroy us." >> To officer Hoffman
that John's ex-wife quote had recorded you and engaged in contact
with John. >> I see all of it. I see everything. Okay.
I wasn't even there. And I probably have a better idea.
>> Yes. Anyone? >> I know. I know what happened better
than Tech does. Okay. I wasn't even there. And I know what happened
better better than techto that police report see his own manipulations.
>> You believe she had been monitoring cameras in the house
and recorded you engaged in the conduct.
>> It is because she was sending it to multiple people.
Okay. And at the time when you were speaking with officer Hoffman,
you believe that Jessica still had videos of you and John engaged
in intimate activity? Yes. And I'm sure with officer Hoffman
standing there by your side, a badge and a gun and handcuffs
ready to arrest John if he had broken the law. It was over a
Sorry, hold on. My apologies. So this is Pinchu apologizing.
She's had a moment.
This is Tech's lawyer still. You certainly would have told officer
Hoffman 14 months afterwards. It's extremely important that we
get these videos. Not only because Jessica has done something
wrong, but these videos contain powerful evidence of coerced
activity that I've been forced to perform.
No, you probably would have told her I've been coerced into performing
oral wrong. But hold on
would have told it's extremely important that we get these videos
not only because Jessica's done something wrong, but be these
videos contain powerful evidence of course activity. Oh,
wait. No, I don't think you'd know that yet. I don't think you'd
know that at all. Oh, this is like a total
right? She might not have any idea. In fact, I believe she doesn't
start talking about it becoming non-consensual till February
of 2024. This is these videos would be from December of 2022.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Hold on. Hold on. That's what she's trying
to say. That's what the lawyer is trying to say, but I don't
know. I thought Pink said the coercive activities didn't start
until February of 2024
when they moved into a new place. I thought that's when it started
to become coercive. Is that not testimony from earlier on that
sort of totally undercuts this narrative? No, I don't think so.
Cheese Beef, all all of the reported events are from March or
May of 2024
and that the coercion started when they went to the new house.
That that was the new arrangement. I I I could have sworn this
was the case. >> But these videos contain powerful evidence
of these activity that I've been forced to perform. >> We
need these docs. You probably would have told her, "I've been
coerced into performing oral sex and these videos will contain
evidence of that." May I explain? Sorry. Or can you if your attorney
asks, "But oh, my question is that's not what you explained to
officer Hoffman, is it?" Those videos did not contain coercion
because it was before it began. So remember, Pinchu said that
the coercion started a year later. So the what he's talking about
is December of 2022 when there wasn't coercion. This is when
they first met.
Okay. Again, this is in February of 2024.
So, what his lawyer is saying is, "Sure, you're saying that's
true, but you filed it police report." >> Oh, dude. I think
this guy's cooked. I think he's totally cooked. >> 18 months
later,
and you still didn't say it was coercion or anything. And her
argument is, well, the coercion didn't start for a year
>> Well, I don't know if she actually says that, but >> the
footage was from December of 2022. Hold on. >> Okay. And
you had but fair to say the coercion according to your testimony
has started by then has started about February of 2024.
Yes. >> This lawyer is a techone. Get your money back from
your lawyer. This this lawyer is a
this lawyer is actually going to make sure. Dude, don't appeal
with this lawyer. You appeal with this lawyer, it's going up
to like 20 years. Okay? Do not keep this lawyer. He totally up
the timeline and his own questioning. He's totally embarrassed
himself now,
right?
Jesus Christ, man. >> And you had every opportunity to
tell officer Hoffman on February 12th that John abusing you and
she should have acted on it. Is that fair? We only spoke through
email and specifically about the case. So, Officer Hoffen never
responded to V the Venza of you. No.
>> Wait,
what
is this guy lost? Is this lawyer lost? This lawyer is either
playing like 5D chess. He's like the He's like the most intelligent
person ever. Or
he's totally this up like horribly. It's clear Teone did what
Trump did. Well, he talked about this evil Johnny Bravo. He talked
about this. He he literally there is a log of him saying, "I
finally found a lawyer who can help me with this." >> She
reduced her interaction with you there at Benazia View to an
offense report that was filed. Would that be incorrect if she
represents in that offense report that she spoke with you?
>> Oh, if she reduced her interaction with you there at
Venzia. Oh, from what I remember, we gone through email. She
had reduced what?
So, basically what he is implying,
she's saying is that techone
uh or not techone, this officer is going to say that she actually
spoke to Pink and didn't just email her. Oh, is this going to
be is this gonna play badly for Pink where she says, "I didn't
meet this person in person." >> I remember. >> Oh,
Riyle found it apparently. Hold on. Let's see. Let's see. Let's
see. Let's
>> The lawyer said he would help you find one. I found
one.
>> Um I had a long call with a lawyer yesterday. Oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah. And it went great.
Hey, hey, hey, hey. To be honest, it went really good.
>> This This is hilarious, by the way. Just every one of
these ones is hilarious. Okay,
not precisely the one I'm thinking of, but awesome. >> It
went shockingly good to be honest. It was insane.
So, uh, don't worry, man. Things are moving.
Yeah, for the first time in a long time, things are moving. And
this lawyer that I talked to,
oh man, I can already tell he's a shark.
I can already tell bro is good as
at his job.
And I know who I'm coming at
Oh. Uhoh.
Uhoh. That Skitso poster.
this guy is so deranged. It's hilarious. >> And I know
who I'm coming at first.
Ooh. Oh. Uhoh.
Uhoh. That Skitso poster about to realize what happens when you
around this long.
Yep. Oh, they about to. >> This is him talking about pick
again. >> Find out. Yes, sir.
>> They all think he's talking about denims. He's not talking
about denims. >> Yes, sir. And then once we get one, the
rest will follow. It's going to be great. Yep. Uh, how we all
doing, boys? How we all doing?
How we all doing?
Uh, I can't wait to watch Their Downfall in real time. I hope
it's true to trial. True. Yep. Yep. >> I want him to talk
about denims. I want him to say denim. It's going to be >> I
want him to rule denims out. Be dumb enough to rule denims out.
Please. >> Actually got 6 and 1/2 hours of sleep today.
Yesterday I only got an hour and a half. Uh, [__]
is doing >> amazing. Um, still no accidents, still none.
We're on day three. Day three. Day
three with the golden retriever puppet. [__] Okay,
too bad. All right, we're back to this. Yes, he was very likely
lawyer shopping and this lawyer I think is up the timeline completely.
Even if they talked in person, that's not as material as the
fact that this lawyer is trying to ask about this officer
when what is it? What does this officer matter when
Pink's testimony already is that there wasn't course of action
like back then? So, the video she was talking about couldn't
have possibly been about that. >> Remember us going through
back and forth through email and phone call. So, I couldn't recall
if I had met her in person. How many interactions with law enforcement
have you had in your life? How many times does an officer Strike
that? How many interactions with law enforcement have you had
in your life? Possibly three. Okay. So, fair to say that if an
interaction with Officer Hoffman on your doorstep, in your house,
on the sidewalk outside, that would be significant to you. I
can't remember. It was so long ago. It was a couple years ago.
Tupi talking mad about you, brother. Holy [__] Do
you want me to pull up her?
>> Don't give a Who cares? >> Who cares, man? Don't
bite the bullet on this one, miss. Dude, like what? That person's
irrelevant. You got to stay on target right now. Okay, focus
up.
Lock in.
We got a lot more document to go here. Okay.
A lot more.
>> I just can't remember. It was so long. It was a couple
years ago. So to go back to what we were talking about, chat,
Techton's lawyer is right now
Pingchu and saying, "Hey, just want to let you [__]
know.
>> Focus up." >> You said that you only talked to
Officer Hoffman uh through emails when Officer Hoffman was the
person that you were supposed to be directed to about how bad
Teone was and how TeeOne was lying and had he coerced you. You
claimed that your coercion started in uh a year later, but the
coercion began and you had an officer with you and you didn't
say and not only did you say his lawyer saying, but the officer
did meet you in person and you're lying about it. So, let's see
what happens. At the time, I didn't know what to call it. Uh,
so she didn't know what to call it about suffering in with techone.
Okay. And did a detective with the Leander Police Department
ever follow up with you about these allegations? I it was very
difficult going back and forth over the phone. I got to so I
don't remember. I'd probably have to look at my emails. To your
knowledge, was Jessica ever arrested? No. Did the Williamson
County Prosecutor's Office prosecute a case against her? No.
So, the case went nowhere? Yes. Jessica being free? Okay. And
because that case went nowhere, you filed a lawsuit in the Williamson
County Courthouse against Jessica. Yes. It was a civil lawsuit.
Yes. And judge, may I approach you? May.
All right. So,
while she's looking through these records, just from big picture,
this lawsuit again dealt with Jessica John. >> Bro, Msk
should wear a suit for this stream. Ms. Kev's got to go get like
a suit, like a like he's a lawyer at a highowered law firm. He's
got a He needed a suit for this. I'm I swear to >> Allegedly
videotaping sex interaction
>> encounters between you and John. And that's that's again
big chick big big picture of what kind of was involved with her
alleged distribution of those videos.
It was also defamation. Okay, good.
Judge, at this time will will officer respondent exhibit one.
I don't have any objections. All right, respondent one is admitted.
I'm going to publish portions of this judge to the court electronically
if that's all right. Sure. All right. Here we go. All right,
Pinkchu. So, I want to ask you a few questions about that lawsuit.
And in that lawsuit, you alleged several differences causes of
actions including unlawful disclosure of promotion or intimate
visual material, common law defamation, statutory liberal business
disc disparagement, torturous interference with business relations,
intrusion on seclusion and stalking. Is that correct? These are
all things that Pink was accusing uh Free of in that >> And
he filed this lawsuit. By the way, um, some of this stuff I would
kind of lean towards possibly being true.
Now, did it rise to criminal? I don't know. But I do believe
I I've never seen anybody really kind of come out and say, "No,
no, no. Frame never said bad things about Pink." I do think that
did happen. I think it's very likely that that did happen. Not
good, obviously. Quite bad. Shouldn't make things up about people.
on June 25th, 2024 in Williamson County. Yes. And that what we
just published as response exhibit one. >> I like the Penguin
avatar better than the judge avatar to be honest with you. >> A
certified copy of that lawsuit. Okay. Is that fair? Yes. And
I didn't see it. Yes. And you described your relationship with
Techone as a private romantic relationship on page six. Is that
a law of that lawsuit where I can make it a little bit big bit
easier for you. Pinkchu. Okay, thank you. You got it. So, this
this lawsuit and this a front page of that lawsuit.
Is that fair? Yes. And on page six, you refer to the relationship
again with Techone as John. Is that fair? Yes. In Pinchu, that's
you. Yes. Okay. So, in your lawsuit, as kind of the background
of the relationship between the parties, you describe the relationship
that you had with Jon as a private romantic relationship. Yes.
And again, this was filed in June of 2024.
Yes. I also want to direct. >> So basically
instead of why didn't you in this lawsuit say that this guy was
like you that's like well that didn't seem like it would help
my law >> your attention to a second page in that you at
various points in this lawsuit discuss or characterize interaction
between you and John. Is that fair? The interaction from December
of 2022.
Correct. And you describe these in various points as private
intimate moments between Pinkchu and Tech. Yes. Oh, so she describes
it as interactions that are intimate between Pinku and Techone
in her lawsuit against Fe and a romantic relationship between
Techone and Pingchu.
>> Yes. And you talk about some of the false statements
that people have been making about you and John and the videos
that have been allegedly distributed. Yes. And then some of the
I think you call them rumors that are online. I believe so. That's
what it says. Okay. And you said that there were some quote toxic
lies being distributed and distributing the intimate videos involving
you and John. Yes. And how these videos these >> So toxic
lies. So I think basically calling Pink a home wrecker, calling
Techone like a cheater,
this kind of thing, right? There was also a lot of other goofy
like
uh from what I remember of the lawsuit I think she she Pink said
that Frame
was spreading a rumor that Pink had gag reflex surgery to get
rid of her gag reflex. Okay. >> Intimate videos allegedly
being distributed have negatively impacted your career prospects.
Is that fair?
Yes.
How you weren't getting signed to Mythic Talent as you might
have otherwise? Yes. So, fair to say from that experience, you
have a good understanding of how a allegation or rumors online
can affect somebody's career. Yes. Because you experienced it,
Pinku. Yes. When you went through with this with Jessica, is
that fair? >> Apparently, that's a thing for people who
have like chronic gags from like nothing. So, some people can
just like have gagging happen because they're like, I don't know,
somehow with how their throats construct, you get like a surgery
to fix it. I don't think it's like a surgery. >> Yes. And
you're extremely aware from the experience that an al allegation
like that can influence ability to get
Yes. Okay. In business deals that may >> Hey, if you say
if you say bad things about somebody, you know that with them
professionally, right? Yes.
I I just did his whole line of questioning right now. >> May
affect how many followers you might have and any of your social
media streams. Is that fair? >> Not entirely. Okay. What
was incorrect about that or what would you disagree with? I would
say similar to kind of how John has dealt with it is you just
go make a pivot to very hateful and opposite type of content
to garner new audiences in that sphere.
>> There's about 50 different people in my chat right now
spamming the same joke about how that's obvious obviously a lie
because you wouldn't need throat you know you would need gag
reflex surgery for microone. I get it guys he's got a all right
Jesus man. >> And you can actually grow is what I've seen
people do. So, what she's referring to is that Teetone started
right-wing grifting when he got attacked from Genchin and when
everyone in the Austin circle started to really not like Tee
uh because people started to realize he's a piece of not just
because of Pink, but people really just
>> Well, it doesn't happen. It doesn't help with that part,
Mr. Holtz. It does not help with that part. But that is a that
is a fair retort. Okay. I didn't think about that. I didn't take
that into >> Didn't like Techone. Um not just from Pink.
People heard bad stories. Everyone got burned by Teone because
he did this thing and he would always do this where Teone would
love bomb the out of you for three months and then just throw
you away. And it was just this weird thing that he did to everybody
that we all kind of realized that TeeOne kind of just [__]
ducks.
Like I said, when I first met Teone,
when I first met Teone, Teone came into my house with Frame and
it was me and Emmy. And this was when I was playing Mario tennis.
Anyone remember that days? Mario N64 tennis. This is like 2022,
I think it was. And Techone, >> I have like a bunch of
stuff that's being built in the X room that >> Mitch time.
>> And I'm like, damn, dude. That's a lot of stuff that
has to be built. Techone goes, "Oh, Frame will do it."
>> What? Oh, yeah. Free loves building [__]
dude. She'll do it all for you.
>> Really? Yeah. Don't. She loves it. Like, say it like
you love you. Okay. And Fe was like, "Yeah, I'll do it." I'm
like, "Okay, thank you, Fe. I appreciate that." Yeah. Fem, get
to it right now, honestly. Let's go play Mario Tennis. So we
would like hang out and Frame would be building and I'd be like,
"Dude, thanks." Months later, I kind of found out that Frame
hated doing that and she kind of like I think resented me a little
bit cuz she thought I went with
>> Oh, that's I mean this is just a like little side story.
That's incredibly
dude. I'm just p I'm just picturing Listen, Frame's like a Frame
was like Tee's house elf, okay? He like goes to just just like
Lucius Malfoy when he when he goes over to Well, I guess when
he goes anywhere. Okay. Got like his little dobby with him. Go
put that together right now. Frame. No, it's okay. She doesn't
have to go that Frame. Go get to it. Get to it. Get to it right
now. Get the out of here. Actually crazy man. Yeah. Dobby 2.0.
And she got given a Kim Possible outfit. Okay. For her freedom,
which I don't blame her, but I never knew. And then I realized
that and we kind of were like, "Oh, this is bad." And I told
people about it. I'm like, "Dude, he's kind of telling people
to use Frame to make us like him." It was weird. Uh,
I still beat him in Mario Tennis every time. All right. And can
you actually grow is what people can do. And since you Well,
strike that again. You characterize those interactions between
you and Jon as recorded intimate recorded
intimate interactions between Pinchu and Tech. Correct. For December
of 2022.
And among those false statements that you identified were that
techone was grooming you. And then you go on to say that grooming
is defined as the practice of preparing of training someone for
a particular purpose or activity in that connotation
dream. Who is that? His ex-wife Jessica. Yes.
Was implying that tee was preparing pink as a slave because she
was
however this is not the basis of the relationship between Teone
and Pink. This is um this is what's alleged in the lawsuit that
basically Frame was spreading this rumor or saying this to people
behind the scenes, right? This is alleged in the lawsuit. Now,
I don't understand where the lawyer's going with this cuz he
seems to be going down the track of like, wait, would you have
exonerated Teone in June of 2024 on him training you to be a
slave if he was
It's like, well, probably if you want the
if you want to say that it's, you know, the idea that you can't
possibly consent to something, if you want to say that that's
defamatory,
then yeah, you probably wouldn't also say, but he is also manipul,
right? Like you wouldn't, you wouldn't include irrelevant details
in the lawsuit anyway,
right? But he is like a real piece of No, you're trying to say
this person's lying about you. They're saying bad things about
you. You're not focused on I don't know. you shouldn't be focused
on protecting Techto even though she was unfortunately too. Is
that correct? That is what's >> Yeah, I see Hassan's gonna
stream on YouTube tomorrow, guys. >> His lawyer saying
you imply that um that that wasn't the case that Techto was fine
at the time. >> I'm trying to focus up because we we do
have to get through this. Okay. And we have like two more hours
of this to go. We have a lot more of the documents to go. So,
I'm just trying to I'm trying to get it all out. All right. We're
trying to figure out all of this stuff cuz I have a feeling I
should go do some tweets about that whole timeline or whatever.
Oh, do I need to chill? Where's the timer at? Oh, [__]
The timer ran out. Guys, guys, subs.
We got to have more time. I I totally [__] myself
by saying I wasn't going to end the stream today. >> Everything
was fine. You had this whole case written up and you basically
said everything's great, but now all of a sudden you're changing
it. And again, this lawsuit was filed in June of 2024. >> Yes.
Okay. Both of the specific interactions that you list in your
application for protective order happened before that is that
fair of March 2024.
Some of them, but the ones that you list were specifically in
your application for a protective order happened in March of
2024 and then in May 28th or 29th of
>> Yo, ADHD runs me. Thank you for the gifted sub. >> Okay.
This lawsuit was filed less than a month after this incident
of abuse allegedly per perpetrated by John on you. Yes. Is that
fair? Yes. Okay. But despite that, you were calling the allegation
that was John was grooming you a lie. Is that fair? I was not
aware of being abused at the time. So she is saying that she
was not aware of the sexual abuse when she was filing this thing.
I did not until I confined to a friend after I knew I what was
going on was not good and I didn't know what to call it. Okay.
And that did not happen until after I moved out and confined
into someone. But you described for Mrs. Lock on direct that
both of these incidents caused you pain. Yes. And was that without
your consent? Yes. Okay. But it wasn't until you talked to a
friend after you in
>> King of Wit. Thank you for the five gifted. Is that
five on kick? Five on Twitch? Five on kick. Thank you so much.
King of wit. Really appreciate it, man. Thank you so much.
Okay, but at the time you filed this lawsuit, you believed that
the idea that John was grooming you or that you were his ex slave
or that was this basis of your relationship, you believe that
to be a lie. I was highly manipulated at the time. So, Pinkchu
is basically saying that for the year, year and a half, she was
completely manipulated by Teone to attack Frame and that all
the stuff that she wrote was not true and that TeeOne was basically
telling her what to say and that Tee was uh, you know, manipulating
her into believing that this was true. My question was, at the
time you filed this lawsuit, you believe the idea that Jon was
grooming you or that you were his slave or that was the basis
of your relationship. You believe that was a lie? Yes. Okay.
At
>> I I still don't understand what he's trying to cook
here at all. We'll see. Maybe we're gonna get there.
>> I know. When Legal Mindset got to this part, Legal Mindset
was like, boom, boom, guys.
The fact that she said he wasn't grooming her into a slave, a
mindless slave. That's proof that he couldn't have sexually assaulted
her, guys. Boom. And I'm like, bro, what are you
are you are you good? I What do you think that proved right there?
>> Disgusting lies. These rumors that were spread about
you and John. Yes. >> Oh, maybe maybe this is what you're
saying, Cy. You think that this guy's not trying to win this
case. He's trying to put stuff in the document that he knows
is going to be read on a stream. >> And further,
you believe the idea or the rumor that you were going to have
gag reflex surgery. You believe that was a disgusting lie. Yes.
And in June of 2024, you believe that the idea that John was
grooming you as a sex slave, that was a disgusting lie. At the
time, yes.
So,
she's basically saying that she was never she was never going
to get gag uh surgery and that the John was grooming her as a
slave was a disgusting lie when she was at the time. >> I
didn't even know that exists. >> Okay. And again, >> oh,
you didn't read the other part. Okay. Very interesting. This
>> you didn't watch the legal mindset stuff at all. >> This
is less than a month. Why would Teto need someone to not have
a gag reflex? I don't understand that. Okay. And again, this
is >> it's such low hanging fruit, but okay. >> This
is less than a month. Microone 29th incident that you put in
your application for a protective order. >> Yes. Okay.
in this lawsuit despite according to your testimony had been
abused by John or at least in March of 2024 and then in May of
20 28th or 29th of 2024 in this lawsuit you didn't describe your
relationship with John as one of an abuser and a victim. At the
time I did not I wasn't fully aware of what my situation was.
So she is still saying that Tee lied manipulated her into believing
that it was not problem and she didn't understand it was a problem
until she talked to her friend. By the way, by the way, Teone
let her file this case, right, where she was alleging that Frame
had revenge of her. Teone knew that this was because of what
he said, right? He knew exactly why Pink
that Frame had revenge that she was sending around.
Teto knows all this. Let her file it anyway. Do you think that
once Pink realizes that Teetone was letting her file a totally
frivolous, totally incorrect lawsuit, do you not think that that
might color the way that he interacted with her and communicated
with her in the past? That undeniable obvious proof that he is
a lying piece of [__] You don't think that that would
have colored the way she sees things in the past? You don't think
she go, "Oh, wait, wait, he lied about this." Like the thing,
wait, what? Wait, huh? Right? Like obviously that's going to
change so many things about your relationship. It just seems
very clear to me. >> Way after all this, this lawyer is
going after her saying, "But why did you never say anything in
14 months? Why did you never talk about this when you got the
the when you sued Pink uh Fe? Why did you sue Fe? What is going
on? Why did you do all this and plan all this? But you didn't
understand in your head that this wasn't abuse assault that when
you got hurt giving him head that your lips got that you didn't
go after him and kind of funny how quiet all the people that
claimed Teone didn't lose the case are right now. How quiet they
are. I don't know if they are quiet. I do think a lot of them
do want to come on and argue at some point here. And we'll see
if that happens. if those people do come on and argue because
I I want to say if like if people really think this is
I would just be interested to have that conversation with them
walk through this
>> and talk about this with the police officer you just
>> I don't see that as the case
in the writing yes that's what I wrote yes or the lawyers wrote
put together where in that lawsuit do you describe your relationship
with John as one of an abuser sorry I think I'm confused on the
question
okay in any place in that lawsuit do Do you characterize your
relationship with Jon as one of an
Um, someone's saying someone in chat was saying that she needed
to get teeth surgery to uh so his wouldn't get stuck between
her teeth. Um,
let's >> I think that's just braces. And realistically,
if she got braces, Tekone would only become more attracted. She'd
be in a lot of danger. So,
okay. >> See, um,
>> teeth surgery. People forget what braces are. remind
me of this. So this we have this on film chat of techone
>> uh of of >> Pingchu or any girl sadly having to
>> give techone
had with his
>> This is very immature. Miz I thought this was a professional
stream. I thought this was a professional stream where professional
[__] went down and Ms. Kiff is making a mockery of
this whole thing.
Um, dude, wait. Where is it? Yeah, hold on. I'm looking for the
Never mind. Missed my chance. Missed my chance. We just hit play.
>> All right, moving on.
Where in that lawsuit did you describe your relationship with
John as one of an abuser? Sorry, I think I'm just confused on
the question. Okay. In any place in the lawsuit, do you characterize
your relationship with Jon as one of an abuser or an a victim?
Me or you don't? No. Is that fair? Okay, I don't. Right. Is it
fair to say that at no place in that lawsuit did you describe
your relationship with John as abusive?
No.
Why would that go in that lawsuit?
Again, I'm just going to say
that you have a view of this person. She has a view of this person,
but this person is telling her the truth. Okay? This person is
is telling her the truth, trying to advocate for her. And then
she slowly comes to realize that he wasn't doing that. He was
actually manipulating her to try to silence somebody who was
going to make an allegation against him. When she realizes that,
she starts to replay like, "Oh, oh, how did my therapy go? Oh,
it was all my problems." And Right. And you start to realize
that this guy's manipulative and that all of those times you
go, "Yeah, he didn't ask for my consent, but he really cares
about me. Yeah, he he did something I didn't want and I didn't
consent to it, but he really cares about me." And then you lose
that. He he really cares about me. He really loves me. I'm really
important to him. You lose that part and what are you left with?
Well, actually, he just violated me when I didn't consent to
it and he doesn't care about me and he was manipulating me. For
real. For real. For real. >> And is it fair to say that
in the lawsuit you didn't describe your relationship with John
as a coercive one? Wait.
>> Yeah. I Does that not make sense to people that like
she could be letting that go? She could say, "Hey, I don't like
this." She could she could say no. She could
be coerced into this stuff. She could she could basically not
consent at all. She could go, "Oh, well, he really cares about
me. I, you know, I he's going through a lot right now. I'm not
going to make this a big deal." And you find out that you were
being manipulated for all this time and you go, "Oh,
this guy didn't care about me. He's actually just a piece of
>> Sorry, repeat that question." >> Totally understandable.
>> At no place in this lawsuit do you describe your relationship
with John as coercive? No. And despite you filing this lawsuit
on June 25th, 2024, less than a month after John allegedly abused
you. Yes. In and in cause of action November number two again,
you describe this characterization of John grooming you to be
a slave as false at the time. So basically, they're still going
through this and this lawyer is really just trying to hone in
on the fact that in this lawsuit towards Frame, she admitted
or she never said any of this was a problem and that Frame was
actually the problem. Um, so we could just go through that. >> Hold
on, hold on, hold on.
>> In this lawsuit towards frame, >> it was false
that he was grooming you. No, just what I had written and not
and I was not aware of what to call what I was going through.
And then what you that is false that John was grooming you. Is
that correct? >> She admitted or she never >> and
your lawsuit of June 2024, it was false that John was >> said
any of this was a problem and that frame was actually the problem.
Um,
so we could just go through that. >> That's what's in the
lawsuit. And on page 13 of that lawsuit, again, filed on I assume
the I assume there gets to be one more like um one more question.
I assume her lawyer comes in and says basically the whole thing
about like you realize I I'm assuming they'll actually add more
to this cuz I I do think they can add to this >> that you
filed in June of 2024.
>> Sorry. I expect the lawyer to come in and say something
along the lines of like, "And why did you withdraw that lawsuit?"
That's basically the question. >> False that you were John's
slave. That's what it was in the lawsuit. Is that correct? Yes,
that's what was in the lawsuit. And on page 13 of that lawsuit,
again filed on in June of 2024, less than a month after John,
according to your testimony, brutally orally assaults you, you
call the notion of you being John's quote John's and end quote
a quote lie without any subst sub
So what this
>> what you're saying now is you just basically a month
after you filed the lawsuit against Tecton and started going
after him, you were saying that it was
And again, this is less than a month after that May 20th 29 incident
that you put in your application for a protective order, right?
So this is a month after.
Yes. Sometime in the early summer, you and John end your relationship.
What type of relationship? It was you end it. Yes. And what kind
of of an extended process is that fair? >> How so? Well,
you didn't break up in an afternoon. You move all your stuff
out that afternoon and you never see each other again. Okay.
Yes, it was extended. Yeah, it was pro protracted. Use whatever
word you want. It took a while. Is that fair? It took a while
after. It was fairly fast after I got out of the hospital. So,
basically, she's saying she got out of the hospital. She grabbed
all of her stuff and she left. You mean Austin Oaks? Yes. Okay.
But throughout that time, you guys were continuing to communicate.
Yes. And you and John continued to be intimate. Yes. Co uh consensually
intimate. What is the timeline of this? Let's just say
>> I love that. It's like, dude, if you feel like there's
a non-consensual thing that happens and then you have consensual
afterwards, that actually those cancel out. Okay. If you can
convince somebody you just raped that you that you can have now
and it's fine and they they consent to it the second time, actually
the rate doesn't matter anymore. Turns out >> June and
July of 2024. >> Very cool. Very interesting. >> I'd
have to look at the what was going on at the time. Okay. On July
23rd, do you recall discussing a encounter you had with John
and describing how hard it was to be quote friends with benefits?
Do you remember that? Yes. Okay. And what does friends with benefits
mean to you? That was my first time ever having that. So, I didn't
that just wasn't the term he used. Well, if I represent to you
that's what the text message between you and John and that's
a phrase that you used, what would >> Exactly. Yes. Oh,
wait. You guys were in like a weren't you guys married? How could
he rap you? You're married. >> That mean to you? I guess
friends who are active. Okay. And you and John were active. Yes.
Consensually active prior to that. No. Prior to what? Because
there was I do remember there was one consensual action from
the friends with benefits situation. But the other times there
were not. There were many times that were not consensual. At
some point in June or July of 2024, did you engage in consensual
in a consensual encounter with John Robertson? One time. One
time. That's probably the time that you're maybe referring to
in some of these text messages. Is that fair? Yes. Okay. All
the other times were non-consensual.
No, there are specific times that were and there were many times
that were not. It is very nuanced. Okay. But you guys were broken
up at this point. Yes, I broke up with him. Okay. So what I mean
how would these non-consensual if you guys are broken up how
would these non-conentual encounters come about? No. Had you
moved out of the out at that point?
>> Wait. Oh, hold on. How would these come about? No. >> No.
I'm speaking about the time that he wanted to be friends with
benefits. There was one consensual time and then that was it.
Okay. And from what I can remember and you remember going to
Austin Oaks on June 29th? If that's the date that's on the file
and your phone number at the time was um 8775309.
Yes. Is that correct? Yes.
Do you recall texting John the day before you went to Austin
Oaks at 7:44? Sorry. Last thing as a thank you. Can I sucky your
tonight?
This is what he instructed me to do. Whoa. But you did send that
message. Yes. So, just to be
>> this is what he instructed me to do.
hold on.
>> So, I understand your testimony.
>> He's bringing this up like this. Wait, did Techone tell
her to to ask that? >> John instructed you to send him
a text message asking you if you could suck his dick that night.
>> Yes. He told me I need to ask to suck his dick to show
he could trust me before I tried reaching out to another girl
and talk about what he has been doing. Told me I needed to ask
to suck his dick to show he could >> Wait, wait, wait.
There's no way. I'm not reading this correctly, am I?
I I have to go back >> to show he could trust me before
I tried. John and your tonight
>> went into Austin Oaks at 7:44 p.m. Sorry, last thing
is a thank you. Wait,
>> the day before you went in? Okay. The day before you
went in?
>> Do you recall texting John the day before you went to
Austin Oaks at 7:44? Sorry, last thing as a >> skip forward
again. Um, but I will say as someone point out, >> how
do I explain this? Uh, hold on.
oh, I don't know how to explain it. Insane manipulation.
It's like a little bit of manip It's manipulation. Yes, insane
manipulation. I'm trying to think of like It's just weird that
she was in like such a
I don't know, like such a bad place. I don't know, man.
I It's bizarre. It's just bizarre. that that he would frequently
do this with pink and frame. Okay. Um he would frequently do
this with pink and frame. Ways it's black. >> Hold on.
Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on.
>> Whenever this all came out that the last thing that
she said was, "I want to suck your dick."
>> Yeah. So that's basically what this is, right? Is like
you have to tell me this. You have to say that you want this,
man.
Oh,
I wonder
my question would be did she ever hint to Techone
that it was non-consentual at the time?
Cuz would he have decided to do this because she had hinted that
they had non-consentual relations at some point and then he was
like, "Oh, I need I need something on the record."
Right? Cuz I I haven't heard her say that yet,
but it almost sounds that way. I don't know. So, in ways it's
blackmail, but is it definitive blackmail? No, because we don't
have a a >> I don't think it's blackmail. It's um >> it's
like one of those things where you're like intentionally
it's just one of those things where if you care about this person,
I just don't think you're collecting a lot of this information
to try to basically here's the thing. If you're going to have
a um encounter with somebody and you think you need to do some
like this Oh, this is kitnetic in the chat. I see this kinetic
kinetic person was in the chat.
If you feel like you need insurance on having a encounter with
somebody, you should not have with with sex with that person.
You are insane to have sex with that person. If you do not believe
that you can have consensual sex with somebody and without getting
an insurance policy,
you you just need to off. It's crazy. It's like I need to enforce
a an insurance policy here to make sure that I could do this.
I see he's reading the >> one other person. So, it is a
he said, she said at this point. >> Um, but I will say
as someone point out in chat that he would frequently do this
with pink and frame.
>> This isn't the girl that Darius used to watch, is it?
No, that's a different person.
Jesus, those are old clips. Okay, it looks like they haven't
streamed in a while. Jesus. >> Okay. Um, he would frequently
do this with pink and frame. Uh, I'm pretty sure
you know Teone, right, Kinetic? How do you know Teone?
I'm the girl that's been messaging you, doofus. Yeah, I know.
I'm just like
the one who dropped a dock. >> I don't understand. Like,
how do you know? Techone. >> I I know.
And I am a doofus. You're you're a witness. I'm I'm bringing
you on the stand right now to be a witness. La. Well, Frame was
my best friend and I knew Pink from GTRP. I was a diary of sorts
for both of them.
Whoa. Damn. That's interesting stuff. So, you were saying that
you knew
So, you you heard from both sides about how bad it was and it
was very similar. Basically, identical. Damn.
>> Yeah. She is the one. She's the one who did the tweet
that said, "I heard the same story from two different women where
they didn't even know that they're talking about the same guy.
They didn't know each other, >> right? This kinetic person."
>> Bring her on a Discord call. I would be happy to call
you if you're if you're down, but um I mean, you could just It's
not illegal for you to talk about your experiences. You could
say whatever you want. Um it's up to you.
That That's crazy. So I So someone that is that was friends with
both of them knew them both said that they had identical stories
despite the fact that they weren't really she was a diary for
both. So they didn't even know they were talking and they had
similar stories. I was never under DA. I was pulled into the
first lawsuit against my wishes
Damn. If you if you want to talk on stream I think I've been
I've been messaging you. I I have you on Discord, right? It's
not Twitter. It's or no it's on Twitter. If you want to talk
uh or say your piece about techone or frame or pink, go ahead.
You can go ahead. Um totally up to you. But I appreciate you
saying that because that does give some context. Okay. Just to
be clear so I understand your testimony. John instructed you
to send him a text message asking if I could if you could suck
his dick that night. Uh I just have one small thing I want to
clear up. Go
You got the floor.
>> But I hold on. >> A lot of death. Hey, can you
hear me? >> Yeah, I can hear you. >> Here we go.
>> Okay, so the one thing that I want to clear up, I've
been getting like a lot of death threats on Twitter lately, which
has not been fun. Um cuz I never
So, okay, very long story short, but I
felt kind of
I don't know how to explain this without hurting anyone's feelings,
but um I was really pressured to provide the screenshots that
were
uh included in Pink and Frames lawsuit. M >> um it went
on for a couple of months of like a lot of people crying and
and pressuring in spite of me not wanting to be involved, but
because I don't want to like say too much, but because someone
um
got upset and made a tweet, there was a chance that they could
have gotten in trouble for the things that they said and they
didn't have proof of the things that they said.
But I did have proof and they knew I had proof.
So there was a lot of pressure on me to provide that so that
the person wouldn't get in trouble. So I did after a while provide
all of the proof which I'm sure you guys have seen. It's been
this on the call. This is kitnetic. We've just been talking about
this kitic person. They're the person who tweeted about how they
heard the same like cycle of abuse from the same man without
realizing it was the same guy and then she found out it was the
same guy. And the two women who were describing the situation
to her didn't even know each other. They never talked before.
That was Kinetics. Kinetic tweet.
>> so again, I actually don't know where she I don't know
who she's immediately referring to. I'm trying to listen. >> There
was a >> So who made this tweet? Who is the tweeter in
this
>> like it was this pink saying something about like >> could
have gotten in trouble for the things that they said and they
didn't have proof of the things that they said.
But I did have proof and they knew I had
So there was a lot of pressure on me to provide that so that
the person wouldn't get in trouble.
Um
so I did after a while provide all of the proof which I'm sure
you guys have seen. It's been
everywhere. Uh
>> the proof of what? I'm actually trying to find the proof
that she's referring
it uh
>> this is so this is really really vague. If Shimu is
still watching, I hope he is. I don't know what this is referring
to now. I can map it on to different things. I'm trying to walk
through all of the possibilities because I don't know how to
map this. One thing I will say is anything that was said by me
or included in screenshots, any of that stuff was
a thousand% true. So any of the people who are going on
videos right now and saying that the videos didn't exist.
Um, >> what videos?
>> Oh, videos didn't exist. So this sounds like she's actually
confirming that there were videos that existed. the the revenge
stuff.
interesting. So, that flips everything on its head then. >> So,
people saying that that didn't exist and that Techone made that
up, that's not true. >> Uh, it did exist, but because Pink
and Frame like, you know, decided to settle or whatever, it just
that all gets >> right? The bad thing about that is
I came forward trying to do the right thing and help someone
because I felt really awful
that her privacy was being invaded cuz you know Pink, she's a
very good person.
>> she genuinely did not deserve that and I was just trying
to help her and then unfortunately I got kind of thrown under
the bus a little bit because now people think that I lied about
that stuff when I never even it was never meant to be public.
I have um messages where I sent both of them a thing and said,
"Look, like you guys have been asking me for this for a while
if I do."
>> So, it sounds like this person did see it or they're
saying they saw it and that they basically let somebody know.
Now, this is one of those things that's tough, and I can see
why
if if basically it was sent to her and then deleted and she made
no archive of it, then she's basically testifying to something
that can't be proven
except for her and apparently her boyfriend who saw these things
together. >> This is to remain only between
you and your lawyers. Like, it is for legal purposes only. It's
not to be used for internet like drama, whatever. Um, and unfortunately
it got posted three times
and then removed afterwards. But you know when something's on
the internet, it's on the internet. So my name got pulled in.
>> So So you saw the revenge or you you
>> So she's saying there was
reported. >> It's not super graphic. I'll I'll tell you
that. It's just
uh something that could be constituted as that. I'm not sure
if that's something that I one can talk about or will talk about.
>> Yeah, you don't need to talk about that. >> Um
cuz I don't want to hurt Pink in any way. Um but it's definitely
something that shouldn't have been recorded. >> And it
was over a um like a security camera
that Frame still had.
>> Okay.
Okay. Okay. >> No, no, no, no, no. What I'm saying is,
uh, Free still had access to the
>> And on a couple of occasions, uh, when Pink came over,
she recorded
like, uh, little snippets of the footage and sent it to me and
my ex. >> And those were just outside cameras.
>> Okay. So, what would Tech be getting head outside?
I cannot confirm or deny. >> Well, you are saying yes here.
So, I'm wondering how in the world.
Oh, this is really this is really broken now because she's basically
saying that she is essentially saying that Pink's lying here.
Like like it seems pretty clear to me that Pink has said unless
I'm misunderstanding something. It seems pretty clear to me that
Pink has said in this this Crush's M's case. What do you
Well, I I I'm saying right here it seems like Pink's saying,
"No, no, no. These were not videos."
I'm thinking about my case. I don't care about M's case. I don't
know what Ms. even I I don't think Ms. has been running with
the same I've been running with. Um
Pink said she never saw the video. She said she never saw the
video, but she's saying that they weren't,
which is why she filed the lawsuit saying there was She's saying
she filed the lawsuit because she wanted to subpoena them, that
she wasn't getting a view of them, right?
No, this woman said not graphic. Pink said not videos in this
transcript. I'm almost positive. So, what I'm guessing is like,
okay, I'm trying to trying to think of how to describe this delicately.
What I'm thinking is one of two situations. Either one where
there was some contact that that is indeterminate,
right?
That is like basically you can't see anything on the video. You
see somebody like leaning over or bending down,
And so you can infer what it would be or it's something where
she was bending down legitimately and it was made to look that
way. One of these two situations, right?
Pink said that. Pink said something about the garage and now
I uh now I don't have this document so I can't search through
it.
It's techone. So of course you
actually it's well captured. We just cannot. We don't have the
the level of definition does not yet exist. Okay, 4K cameras,
it doesn't exist to capture Techone in its full glory. Okay,
it just does not it does not exist. There is no technology we
could invent. Turns out Ring has not put out their electron microscope
outdoor cameras yet. All right, we just can't can't make it work.
>> I don't like the face you're making right now. >> No,
I'm just confusing. Like why would Tek I mean Tech's
I don't even um yeah she can't go in the >> only thing
I'll tell you is uh all of the footage that I saw was either
in the driveway or in a vehicle. >> Okay. So that was
Okay. So >> Oh,
hold on. I see. So could it be a video of them pulling up in
the car and like Pink's like head pops up?
Is that what it is? where you don't see anything graphic, but
it's like Pink's head coming up from like she's like leaning
over him or something. I feel like that's what it is. And then
I wonder if that's actually what it's claimed to be. Or I wonder
still a violation.
I do believe that wouldn't constitute
at least under the Florida things
revenge technically,
but
h interesting.
Frame had that
and it was in the driveway or a vehicle.
Okay.
And that's what
he was trying to tell her is revenge and is bad and she needs
to be >> Yes. I look I'll to be frank I loved Frame. I
really did. Uh I still do and I think that anything that she
did was because of the abuse she went through. >> Right.
I think that she is I don't think she's a bad person at all.
>> I I think that uh things got really messed up just because
of how poorly they were both treated. Cuz I will tell you,
Freen used to message me stuff uh the things that he would say
and do and the way that he treated her.
And then at first,
you know, when Pink got with with John and they started,
>> I think the entirety of all of my analysis still applies
entirely. Like it's still one to one, 100% still applies,
right?
I think all of the analysis about it being misrepresented still
applies.
And that would very likely be I'm guessing this is why now we
have it explained to us essentially I think Frame could have
basically shown these this video to the cops and said that's
outside that's in public they knew where the camera was and there's
nothing graphic captured and the cops would go well [__]
[__]
right
now we still don't understand why or sorry I'm still very interested
here maybe pink will will
highlight this for Why? In February of 2024,
at this precise time where FER starting to get more active and
talking about TechOne, I believe before right before they signed
the NDA,
when do they shimmude, do we have a a timeline on when they signed
the NDA? Because we looked at the the tweets. I think we had
it in your video here. Where is this? Where is this? This one
right here.
Why is it that like right here where suddenly we want to file
a lawsuit over this? That's what's very interesting. Okay. I
want to hear why this was pushed again. Why why was this fresh
in somebody's mind?
I kind of >> I think the NDA comes after that cheese >> Thought
that he had changed at first because of the things that Pink
would tell me, but then very slowly
it started to shift and I was like, "Wow, this is the exact same
thing all over again." And they had never spoken. You know, this
is not two people who could have cooperated their stories. It
was two people who >> went through the same treatment and
neither of them deserved it. >> Yeah. And they they obviously
didn't talk because she sued him. She shooted her so they weren't
talking. >> Yeah. They've never spoken. >> And you
were the kind of middleman and you heard both the similar stories
of abuse. No, cuz I I ended my friendship with Frame
um on a basis of I didn't think that her
looking at the internet history and looking at the cameras was
healthy. And if I told her that, she would kind of laugh it off.
Which >> wait, hold on.
>> Looking at the internet history and looking at the cameras
was healthy. I'm not sure if you like totally obsessing over
your ex is healthy. Uh, how about you, dude?
Uh, yeah. No, it's clearly not helping. It's clearly not good.
Obviously. So, >> and if I told her that, she would kind
of laugh it off, which to be honest,
brutally honest with you, looking back.
If I would have known the extent even further of how bad he he
was,
I probably would have just been like laughing along with them
at some of the search history stuff he looked up cuz it was really
stupid. But >> Oh, that's insane bait. That's insane >> I
don't know. I hate tech tone. I think he's a terrible person,
but
I still don't I I don't know. At the time, I didn't think what
she did was right. Um, but I did love her, so I just distanced,
you know. >> Mhm. So, you're basically saying that you
and Frame were very close, and she would personally tell you
things about Teone that were abuse, not meant for the public
or anything like that, just to a friend to a friend. And then
you stopped being friends with her after she started to
uh they broke up and between the camera footage and everything
else. >> I just felt like the the end of their relationship
was really unhealthy on both parts and >> I couldn't you
know you can't make someone not do something. So it was easier
to just distance. >> And you're saying and then afterwards
you started you were friends with um Pinku because of GTA. >> Yeah.
I had met her several times and role played with her on no pixel
>> and she would who never talked to Frame confide to you
privately not publicly saying any of this stuff about how bad
he was she techto was to her. >> Yeah, it was the same
kind of unhealthy treatment. I, you know, aside from what like
the
assault stuff that is in their lawsuit, I wouldn't I mean, I
guess it's like emotional abuse, but he's just a really bad partner.
He's very
Um, he even manipulated me cuz like,
you know, meanwhile,
>> let's go. like they're they're pressuring me to like
add all of the stuff to
um
you know give them information about the situation with Frame
which again I never wanted to do because I still have and always
will a lot of love for her and the last thing I wanted to do
is hurt her but I also wanted to protect Pink. She was
inconsolable
um about everything and um
I lost my train of thought. I'm getting a little nervous. Dude,
dude, why? >> I said I wasn't going to get involved and
now I'm on here, but >> No, it's okay. Can I ask you a
question? Did Did Pink believe that he was abusive in the beginning?
>> Well, of course she did. Yeah. >> I think because
of the mistakes that Frame made, it made it a lot easier to discount
and discredit anything that
she, you know, went through. >> Oh, it's like on a relationship
level, Teton did the thing. Okay. He did the thing where you're
like building a villain, but he did it for his relationship,
right? Where like, yeah, obviously his wife was making bad decisions.
Sounds like Frame did some bad things. She was lying and stuff,
right? But basically, Tone built the enemy up that they could
both hate and that means for that means Pink is not looking very
closely at what he's saying, right?
>> Oh boy.
So, Yep. I mean, that makes sense. That makes sense.
>> I saw someone in say that
>> of course he's not waiting for my consent. Of course
he's not. He's really upset about what Free's doing to him. He's
like a victim.
I I just I
I can just see it, man. I could see it. I could see it, dude.
I can h
so brutal, man.
It's actually so up. >> People in Tech's Discord are saying
that they think Frame and Pink are teaming up for Sisterhood.
They've never spoken.
They still have never spoken.
They've only talked through like lawyers and stuff.
I I'm surprised in that. I thought they did, but damn.
Okay. Well, I don't want to keep you here to get you in trouble,
but if you have anything else as we go through, just feel free
to message me. But I >> Yeah, I mainly I just wanted to
clear up the fact that I didn't lie about anything at all. Um,
and I I certainly don't want to be branded that way. I
genuinely was just trying to do the right thing. I still am.
So,
>> so if F would tell you >> I have no idea how to
interpret this, but man, I I feel like trying to be so vague
is not helping.
I
I don't want to I
I almost feel like
uh I feel like she's being both both vague and definitive at
the same time. They've never spoken. Well, I don't know if you
could really know that for sure. They might have told you they've
never
oh, this stuff was definitely like revenge. This stuff definitely
existed, but it's not explicit. I think I think being vague there
is actually kind of
>> you in confineence
or or confident confidently that he would have revenge on her.
>> Wait, huh? >> Wait, Tone would have revenge.
I should Well, hold on. This is like two hours in the past. Your
ADHD run as well. >> We can't really advise Miz on that.
>> I don't know anything about that. >> He would
have revenge on her.
>> Wait. Huh? >> Wait. Tone would have revenge on
Frame as well.
>> I don't know anything about that. No. >> Oh, okay.
I I So, okay. I mean, yeah, that's So, basically, you were the
diary like you said. You were to put between them. I thought
they actually talked, so I guess they never talked, which is
interesting. Um, >> not to my knowledge. No. Anytime that
there was any conversating, it was through lawyers.
>> Yeah.
Well, I'm sorry I had to go through that and been dealing with
this. If you see anything in chat that you think is is you want
to say, let me know and we can just call or you can type it in
chat. But we appreciate it cuz you're
>> So, I think she feels like she's getting thrown under
the bus. Dude, if I had a trans, it'd be nice to be able to control
F on this document right now. If Miz Miz, please biz, please
send me the document. Be nice to be able to control F on this
document. I just want to be able to go through this document
and find where she's talking about um I can find a time stamp
if I have to, but to try to find where
she's talking about the videos cuz I think she almost explicitly
declares here that they're not videos. So like I wonder how you
would know if you can't see somebody's
or whatever whatever the video is. I wonder how you would know
because she might think, "Oh, that's actually not context or
when I see it." Oh, I I recognize this. It isn't actually >> continuing
to show the pattern. The very famous streamer says two line,
two dots make a line or some [__] but there's like,
you know, 300 dots at this point. You know, you can
>> um she's be I think you're letting your hatred for Bisk
totally blind you to what's being said. I don't think you have
a good read on this right now. >> Kept very quiet for the
last two years. not like getting involved in anything. And um
I felt a lot of guilt for a long time at first because I knew
about,
you know,
I don't know. I don't want to say too much, but I was just very
I feel a lot of guilt for not saying something about Techone
sooner. >> she does sound fat. I am fat. Yo, hell >> Don't
Don't feel bad. Don't feel bad.
Wait. Oh, Miz is so don't feel bad. Don't feel bad about I just
I think he's saying don't feel bad about not saying something
about Tecttone, but it sounds like she said I am fat and he's
like don't feel bad. Don't feel bad about that.
Wait, what the [__] >> It's the truth is it's
out and that's what matters the most. It's not, you know, it's
not like it went on for decades. It's it's
it's fine, you know. >> Yeah. and we're we're hopefully
trying to tell as many people as possible the story. I'm literally
just reading the transcripts and it's it's say that people are
trying to defend him in the slightest or say that it's just a
civil case, but you know, it's already bad.
>> So, okay, I'm going to keep reading, but if you have
anything, just message me or just type it in chat. But I really
do appreciate it. I I seriously do. Like
>> I have so many questions. I just want to know how clear
when was it made clear to Pink that there were no cameras in
the house or was there any intimation that there any cuz I think
this is no but it would be interesting to know was there any
like um implication that there were cameras in the house cuz
I'd say that's how it was advertised to everybody on the internet
that like there were some cameras sitting in the house and she
had to come and take them down. Right. I think that's even said
in one of the lawsuits that Frame was told she had to come and
take the cameras down or something. As if like a Ring camera
at your house would be something that both people in the relationship
didn't know about and both people in the relationship wouldn't
have like some idea of.
You know what I'm saying? >> Thank you. >> Like did
Tee really not have access to these Ring cameras at all? Would
that actually be the case that he wouldn't know about them? He
wouldn't understand that where they are. That he wouldn't um
see the videos pop up on the app? That seems crazy to me that
he would just not know about it. But I swear in the previous
in the previous lawsuit in the u previous civil case, I got the
impression that
he he was basically arguing he didn't know about those cameras.
don't worry, you didn't say anything crazy or anything that will
get you in >> Right. He was um Pink was. >> I just
told the truth. >> Yeah, that's it. You just told the truth.
That's it.
>> That's it. I have no doubt that Frame set it all up.
I'm saying that the idea the idea that he didn't know anything
about it. >> Have a good stream. >> Okay, bye.
All right, let's keep going.
Interesting. So, she claims or she says, and I believe her, that
Free would basically talk about the abuse with her constantly
about how bad of an abuser he was. And um she would consult her
for that, which then Fe had a you know, was was upset. Yeah,
the the the
things that the the the cameras outside and stuff like that,
the and his search histories
Techone used that to go to Pink and be like, "Hey, look how insane
this woman is. We need to stop her." And she started to be friends
with Pink or she was already friends with Pink. She started talking
to Pink and Pink essentially had the same story as Frame despite
never talking to each other and also despite it never really
being public. So, it was like, why would they lie to this girl
when they both were not public about it and didn't talk about
it for a long long time? It makes no sense why they would lie.
Okay, let's keep going. I do I really want to know now.
Also, yes, how aware was he of the cameras?
I I understand that Frame would have set them up, but in my mind,
like the idea that he had no idea there were Ring cameras at
his house.
Come on, man.
Somebody pointed out it's possible. And I I do wonder about this.
Like would he have intentionally done that, right? Would he have
intentionally asked Pink to do that knowing where the cameras
were?
I I'm going to hold off on making that claim cuz I
I feel like that's a lot that's a lot to go to that extent, but
Jesus.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I do believe she would have set the cameras
up, but why would you how in the I just I can't imagine a relationship
like this where somebody sets up like a Ring camera or multiple
Ring cameras and they just never tell their partner about it.
They don't let them know where the cameras are. They never show
them a video from the
How many people do you know with Ring cameras who have never
ever talked about the Ring camera or shown you a video from their
Ring camera?
I feel like everybody who gets a ring camera shows like their
partner or whoever will look like funny videos that happen with
the ring cameras at different times, right?
>> I just said your testimony, John introduced you to send
him a text messaging, ask him if you could suck his dick that
night. Um, yes. He told me I needed to ask to suck his dick to
show he could trust me because I tried reaching out to another
girl and talk about what he has done. What was the date of that?
June 28th, 2024. That was the month before hospitalization. That
was the night before. No, hospitalization was July. I'm sorry.
July 28th. Okay, thank you. Uh, >> he justed up the timeline
again. He justed up the timeline again. He justed up the timeline
again.
>> Mrs. Lock comes in here real quick and and defends uh,
Pinkchu and says that she that the guy's getting the dates wrong
and she corrected him and it's we go on. What was the date of
this? That was July 23rd. I don't know if she can authenticate
it. Judge, may I approach? You may by Mr. Porier and Pingchu
that is fair and accurate representation of those conversations
that you have with John I believe from July 28th 2024
leading into July 29th. Yes, I remember. Okay. And this is fair
and accurate copy. Is that correct? Yes, I believe so. Yes.
This is Tee's lawyer, Mr. Porier. And I'm going to mark and offer
this as respondents exhibit three, two, and three.
Your honor, I would offer them at this time. No objections. Respondents
two and three are admitted. Permission to publish your honor.
You may. Again, Pinkchu, at 7:44 p.m. on July 28th, 2024, you
say, "Love you." And then what do you call that? An
Whoa. The big time. This is it. Tech's big case. Yes. Okay. What
does that emoji signify? Happiness. Nervous. Okay. Hope you're
having a good day. Sorry. Last thing as a thank you. Can I sucky?
I assume you meant your tonight. And then another emoji. And
what does that emoji signify? A mouth opening. Okay. This was
the day before you went into Austin Oaks. Yes. And when you went
into Austin Oaks, they did a screening process with you. Is that
fair? Yes. And they would >> I think this is the probably
the worst moment for Pink in this transcript in this hearing.
Um, the worst moment in terms of what people will use online
to paint techto is like, "Oh, he was telling the truth." She
She totally got manipulated after the fact is right here. So,
you can pay attention to this. >> Judge, may I approach?
You may. Are you going to introduce all of the records? I am.
This is excerpts. I have. They're voluminous.
So, I have them on a flash drive. Judge, I don't have an objection,
but I think the entirety of the records needs to come in, not
just the sections. I don't know if they're coming in under the
business records affidavit.
Judge, I have a copy of an electronic copy of the records. Ashley,
again, I think when we broke, we were discussing you going into
Austin Oaks. Yes. And before you went into Austin Oaks, you sent
John a series of text messages and you guys had a text conversation
about your decision to go into Austin Oaks. Is that correct?
Yes. And that's what we see on the screen behind us. Is that
fair? Yes. Our discussion? Yes. And you said, "I really need
a friend right now. I think I need to go to the mental hospital.
My mom doesn't answer. I don't know if it's the medicine. I'm
going to have a hard time. I need to see a doctor. Figuring it
out right now. Packing my bags. Heading to my mom's. I hope you
see this, but I'm going to do the right thing and get a full
psych evaluation and get some real help. I love you so much.
I'm sorry if I ever hurt you and I can't wait to come back feeling
better. I love you. Is that what you wrote, Pink? Yes. And did
John Direct write any of that? No, not that. Okay. just
um so
again uh I need to this would have been the next day I believe.
Okay. Okay. Okay. Now
man
it's tough when I see this like
it's not impossible to once you got distance that changes things.
It's it's a complicated situation. So, I will say that is
Oh, that's not even the biggest part yet where this is like
it's tough because she could need some distance from the situation.
Like if she is being sort of like, you know,
mentally manipulative, if she's being manipulated in some way,
she could just need distance. Um
I this doesn't really mean much. I guess it is, but it is important,
I guess, if you're Tech's lawyer to come out and say, "Hey,
like they were they were close at this period of time. I believe
this. I believe this could be how she felt. I believe this could
change very quickly based on new information coming in. Right.
I don't even think Well, the other thing is is what does she
love here? Is she trying to hold on to something she thinks is
making her stable? Is she trying to hold on to the one thing
like
when you're obviously she's in like a storm right now, right?
and she's like teeone might be her one life raft and
she's not even aware like basically she's holding on to this
life raft and she doesn't know that it's like not helping right
maybe there's a better analogy here she's got like a a tiny life
raft that's like taking on water and there's a ship a little
ways away and she has to make a decision on whether she's going
to go for the ship or stay in the life raft and the thing that
feels safe is to stay in the life raft right the thing that's
like keeping her slightly above water but long- term it's like
not helping. Maybe this is like the analogy that works in some
way. Um,
basically it's the one thing that's stable. It's the one thing
that like is kind of working or kind of helping her when she's
in this really chaotic period of her life. So, she could feel
this way, but it might it might not really indicate anything
about techone or the relationship. It might just be like this
is the one thing I like if I give this up, I lose everything,
right? If I give this up, I lose everything. And that's not like
the basis of a relationship or love. really she's just saying
the things to keep that thing stable, right?
>> So, I'm I'm trying to I'm just trying to reason through
how she could feel this way and feel like both at the same time.
That makes uh some sense >> what's going on with Teone.
Um it's not really anything crazy. It's just her saying like,
"I I just want to feel better." Maybe she didn't want Teone to
bother her at that time. It's not much. I will say the dick sucking
thing is kind of insane, but the fact that she's saying Teone
told her to say that is weird.
But um you know apparently it also happened to frame. Okay. But
that was the only part that he directed you to write. No, he's
done it before.
Okay. And then he responds, Jesus Christ. All right. Well, be
safe and trust your decision. Is that correct? Yes. He doesn't
belittle you. Not in that text. Correct. In that text, he doesn't
belittle you. No. I mean, Jesus Christ is uh
I I would say that's actually
sort of doing something right there by itself. The Jesus Christ,
>> not in that text. Okay. He doesn't call you crazy. Not
in that text. He doesn't call you psycho. No, he says, "If you
need me, just text me.
I have my phone. I'm sorry you're going through this pink." Yes.
So, he's supportive of you in those texts. Okay. Sure. And for
the sake of our questions about these text messages, that's what
I'm referring to. Okay. In the group of text messages, he's not
dismissive. No. He doesn't use any pre uh pre-jurative language,
crazy, psycho, anything like that. Is that fair? Yes. Okay. And
in fact, when you message him, hey, he says first thing, hey,
are you safe? Yes. That's what that's the priority for him is
making sure you're safe.
Okay. Is that correct? If that's what he I don't I'm not him.
Can't tell you. Okay. But that's what it reads as, right? That's
what he wrote. Is that correct? Yes. Okay. Then you respond with,
"I'm safe." Yes. I'm just trying to figure this out. And he said,
doesn't say, "Cool. Don't care. Good luck." He says, "Okay, keep
me updated." Yes. And then you describe to your your >> Okay.
You made a report on the basis of a suspicion that Jessica had
videos of you and John engaged in intimate activities. Yes. And
you believe that she had those recordings from my That's what
I was told. Yes. From what you from? Okay. From what you were
told by who? Mr. Robertson. Okay. By John. Yes. Okay. You believe
that what he told you because your next action was to call the
police. Sim setting something up, but yeah. Okay. Um, so you
don't have any independent evidence or verification that anybody
had any footage ever. Is that fair? No, there was some footage.
It just wasn't footage.
Okay. But to be clear, you never saw any video footage. No, I
was believing John and his friends. Okay. When did when did Jessica
tell message to that to John to your understanding? So
yeah, this is interesting because now we're getting another person
who's coming in and saying, "No, no, no, it was footage."
And man, that's
that's rough. Again, you need all these people in a room. It's
like you're you're getting this insane game of telephone going
on right now, right? So, if you guys are unfamiliar
or if you just came in, okay,
the issue we're having here is we're trying to make the the kinet
kinetic interview jive with the original civil case and what's
going on right now. And it's actually
a little weird. Hold on.
There was some footage. It just wasn't footage. That's not what
she's saying. She's not saying this, Cam. She's not saying Oh,
hold on. Not Cam. Uh, she's not saying Oh, yeah. Cam. She's not
saying it's not it's not explicit. She's saying it's not at all.
She's saying not
as in so she might be, you know, hinting at there's no content
in it as in there's no like um we can't see any body parts. There's
nothing like this, right? Might be. Might be. I'm trying to figure
out exactly
what happened here. So, hold on. Here we go. Um may approach.
Have you ever had a different position on that? Okay, hold on.
I didn't understand the full context. I knew it was some footage,
some something going on, but I didn't understand the full context.
You ever heard I had a different position on that message that
it was him me giving him a [__] but I didn't like
know if it was inside the garage or if it was outside the garage
like the full context of it because I've never seen it myself.
Okay, let me back up. When did you learn about the message that
Jessica sent John? Something to the effect of, "Is she better
than me?" When did you learn about that? December 2022. He said
that she called and said that. Okay, I believe. And what did
you take from that? I was disturbed. Okay. Was Jessica there?
Jessica in the home. You guys engaged in this. Implication from
that message to John was that she was viewing what you guys were
doing in the house someplace. Is that fair? Yes. Okay. Did that
concern you? Yes. Okay. And you learned about that in December
of 2022? Yes. So, she believed this was inside the house. So,
again,
my actual questions, OM OMG, it's OG. Can you just chill, bro?
Okay. Just chill. Um,
the question we should have from this is
did Teto know about the ring cameras? Was he aware that these
videos were taken on ring cameras?
When when was it decided that oh, there weren't cameras here?
Like that there weren't cameras that Right. Cuz this is clear
that somebody's trying to imply
there's cameras in the house.
Okay. So, she talked to Hoffman. This is in 2024.
Reported to police until here. So, I would be asking if I were
if I were the other lawyer and we get techone up on the stand.
Hey, why didn't you you thought there were cameras in your house
and you didn't call the cops? You thought there and did you when
did you let Pink know that the cameras weren't in the house and
there was no activity from in the house that could be on a camera?
That would be important for me to know. Although, I guess it's
difficult to say. I don't know. I ah man it's uh
they might not want to litigate that like all of this civil coming
to take you going to Delone
and then you eventually say they're probably going to take my
phone away in other words don't be surprised if I can't call
or message you is that fair yes
and you uh
and you say John says everything will be okay and you respond
I love you so much. Please don't tell anyone. And John replies
100%. Are you with your sister? Yeah, she's on her way. Can I
call again? If not, that's okay. And he says, I need you to be
strong. Yes. Correct. Again, he's supportive. He's encouraging
of you to get whatever acute mental health crisis you have going
on addressed. Is that fair? I wasn't having it was I just wasn't
feeling good. It wasn't acute. Okay. Well, we'll get this into
some of those medical records. I mean, at the time, were you
having some feelings, some thoughts of self harm? I mean, yeah,
I was. Okay. In a bad situation. Sure. And Okay. Maybe we have
a different definition of acute mental health crisis, but you
felt like you needed to go.
I just needed to get out of there. Okay. And then again, John
says, "Text me when you're on your way and please be safe. Be
careful." Uh-huh. Correct. And you eventually tell him, "I'm
going to Austin Oaks." And that's when you check yourself in.
So this lawyer um
>> uh I don't think I don't think this would be under NDA
personally
that like hey what did you tell Pink and when
like I don't think that's under NDA. I think that's not her talking
about Frame
or I think that's not her talking about >> what is this
guy saying? >> Oh right. But that is something that I think
Pink is also under an NDA. [__]
Yeah it is. Dude, the whole situation's >> big respect.
It's nice seeing you still stream after everything that happened.
and I've been watching you for six years, so it means a lot you're
still going. I'm gay. So, the lawyer is really honing in on the
fact that at Austin Oaks, she went there and Tech was supportive
and she was supportive of Tech and they were saying, "I love
you." And they were saying, "You're great." >> Despite
the fact that a month later, she basically files a report and
destroys his life and says that he was a monster and all these
terrible things happened. But at this moment, right before she
went into uh Austin Oaks, she still believed that Teone was this
great guy. Or at least that's what he's trying to show is that
Tee was a great guy here and that um you know, he didn't do anything
wrong. He was still texting you, but yet you were saying that
he was abusive. Why are you calling him abusive when you're saying
I love you?
Okay, I want you to ask that process. And when you go into Austin
Oaks, they ask you a bunch of screening questions. Is that fair?
Judge, may I approach? You
>> 1.5x. I'm having a hard time listening to this and paying
the correct amount of attention at 1.5. Put it to 1.25. >> Is
that fair? Yes. They want to get to know your situation a little
bit more. >> Bro, that cat is used to miss doing some skits
[__] >> And as >> that cat barely barely
moved when he slammed that down on the desk. That cat was like
awake for a millisecond and was like, "Ah, no, whatever. Back
to sleep." This cat's used to just insane outbursts from Miz.
Probably because he's a streamer, right? Chompy. Oh, is this
Chompy? I didn't know this was Chompy. If this is Chompy, I've
heard Chompy reference for a long time. That cat was like, "Bang."
I don't give a [__] Back to sleep. I feel like any
other cat you bang something down right next to it like that,
that cat freaks the out, right?
Total trust, you mean? Yeah. The cat doesn't think it's like
in trouble. It's just like, "Oh yeah, he's going skitso again.
He's on stream. He doing some skitso [__] again."
It's very >> Screening questions. Is that fair? Yes. They
want to get to know your situation a little bit more. Okay. Is
that fair? Yes. For instance, they're going to ask you on page
26.
>> I'm just saying he like pops off on stream. He just
screams on stream. That's what I'm saying. >> What you
are allergic to when you respond. Chicken. Is that correct? Are
you allergic to chicken? On my hands, I get red bumps. Yeah,
you get red bumps. And you disclose that to the nurse at Austin
Oaks. You get red bumps if you touch chicken. Yes. And they ask
you about a special diet if you have any a special diet going
on. And on page 31, you talk about blank that you have at the
time. Yes. Yeah. Because you're you knew the importance when
you're going through the screening. >> I see. Trying to
build up. You told the >> when they were asking you questions
of being sexually abused answers. Is that fair? Yes. Because
you knew if you left something very important out, it could lead
to disastrous results, right? If you didn't tell them about your
blank allergy, for instance, and they touched you with a blank,
you can get those red bumps. So, what this lawyer is trying to
do in a very boring way, holy [__] he is exhausting
to listen to. He is trying to basically really hone in on the
fact that she needs to tell the truth at this point. She's at
a hospital and he she needs to tell the truth no matter what.
And she is not uh and she's telling the truth about allergies,
but what but she won't tell and he's going to get into this.
He won't she won't tell the truth about how Tek was abusive
because you knew if you left something very important out, it
could lead to disastrous results, right? If you didn't tell them
about your allergy. Yes. So, understand that. That's why it's
so important to be honest, to be complete, to be accurate in
the answer you provided to the >> I feel like she already
made it pretty clear that she at this point still didn't like
understand the extent of the manipulation. It's going to be the
same answer. He's building this all up and I get why he's doing
it. He's trying to get as much of an impact on the judge as possible,
but it's just going to be the same answer before. >> For
instance, they asked you about your history of your present illness
on page 15 and you indicated you quote blah, which is when I'm
high stress in high stress situations. We don't know what that
is. Okay. Okay. And then you go to say that that was the reason
that you believe John broke up with you. No, I don't. I don't.
Oh, the first time that wasn't I don't believe that was the reason
the first time. Okay. I broke up. Are you talking about the time
where we like mutually talked and or you talking about the time
where I broke up with him? So, she broke up with him the second
time, chat. The first time she they mutually broke up. Uh, it's
probably about her getting panic attacks. In medical records,
you describe it as blank. And that's why you believe John broke
up with you was because blank. Do you mind telling me what that
page was on? Sure. That's page 15. I don't see that. I just see
blank. And that's how you and those medical records characterize
your relationship with John. Is that correct? That you were friends?
No, I'm just confused because you said blank and that's the reason
we broke up. But I can't find that on the pages. Okay. Ken, get
that addressed to you. Okay. So, the last line on history of
present illness, description of acute illness or exception of
illness requiring admission. Do you Is it on these printed pages?
I just can't find them. Or is this a separate page? So, Paint
doesn't know what the [__] going on. Yeah. So, it's
on that screen that you should be able to see. Oh, it's just
on the screen. Yes. Okay. And these are things that are wrote
down because I don't believe that's my handwriting. Well, yeah,
they would have. Okay. Talked to you and you would have reduced
reduced what you had to tell them to writing. Okay. I'm just
trying to understand. Sorry. Yes. And again, you got details
that you get blop. Do you get blop? I mean, anyone who is getting
abused gets pretty blop. Probably depressed. I'm guessing. Okay.
I do.
>> You have in the past year since I've been out of the
situation. Okay. But at the time, you were not in front of anyone.
It was more of like by myself. I don't know what that is. Um,
so if it was if it was by yourself, then why do you think that's
why? >> Listen, I think we have a long way to go on this,
Josh. I don't know. I we tal they basically said that he charged
more eventually and like we talked about it a little bit. It
seemed like weird and it seemed to be something that changed
with,
oh, you don't want to suck any dick anymore. Well, lots more
money.
>> At the time of July 2020, >> but if they if they
highlight it and go into it, all right, we I'm not totally sure.
24. Did you believe that was the reason John >> I don't
know if we've covered it yet. >> I believed they probably
miswrote what I was explaining to them because I was probably
crying. Okay, but the quotation marks there, you think that they
maybe mischaracterized what you told them? I think they may have.
Okay, it looks like they were trying to cut it down into pieces
and I think they probably weren't understanding what I was trying
to explain. So, Pinkui was saying that while she was there, they
weren't getting the full depiction because Pinkui was crying
like crazy. Okay, fair enough. We'll come back to that. But you
think the nurse, though you were attempting to be accurate, honest,
and complete in your answers, you think the nurse with training
and certification probably wrote it down wrong? Well, no. It's
because I was under like a lot of distress. I was just trying
to explain everything as much as I could and putting that into
one small paragraph. >> Got you.
It's very hard to do that accurately. Got you. And okay, then
in on page 33, they ask you about your history of victimization.
Okay. In your And they ask you about your history of victimization
in the last six months. Do you remember that? Yes. And you answer
your answer at the time was blank which is probably no. Is that
correct? Yes. Because at the time I didn't >> the answer
was no. >> No that I was. Yes. >> Okay. And when
they asked you that question and again this covers in the last
6 months that is in blank. This is July of 29th of 2024. Correct.
Yes. Only 6 months back that would have covered May 28th May
29th incident that you've alleged of 200 uh 4 that you alleged
in your application for a protective order. Um I I think they're
saying 2024.
So basically what this this lawyer is really trying to get into
is Pingchu never really talked about the fact that she was abused
or neglected up until the fact that she got out of Austin Oaks
and started talking to other people. And why did she never talk
about the abuse? Why did she never say she was abused? Why did
she never go to anybody? Why? >> That is the point. Yes.
Yes. Like he's just trying to build the narrative that hey
somebody whispered in her ear that she was abused because they
hate techone because he is a strong powerful man who pays my
checks. Okay. Pays my salary right now. That's the narrative
he's obviously trying. >> When there was a police officer,
she didn't talk about it. And why is she still saying, "I love
you, detect." And this guy's really honing in on this right here.
He's really trying to re this one in. Really trying.
Okay. So, they ask you specifically, have you been victimized
in any way? Not assaulted, but victimized. And your answer was
no. Yes. And they go on to ask your entirety of victimization.
Again, not just assault, not a criminal offense, but any victimization
at all of your lifetime. And you say no. But you clarify and
explain that blank. Yes. So, I don't know if this says no or
yes. It's basically this guy's trying to say that regardless,
you didn't say tech tone. You would agree with me that no point
in this question do you mention in uh intimate interactions that
you had with John that you don't discuss anything related to
John. Is that correct? No, I did not.
Okay. What are the court and you understand understood at the
time that you needed to be honest, complete and accurate in the
information in >> somebody just pulled out food for that
you were providing. >> Yeah. Freaking out >> to the
best of my current knowledge. Okay. They al also ask on page
16 of those, have you experienced any emotional, physical, or
abuse history in any way? And you disclose no. Yes. Okay. And
that was the relationship that you were in six years prior to
going into Austin Oaks. I was a child. Okay. So this might be
no or yes. It's regardless it's not about techone. Do you discuss
your relationship? >> It's about other in answer. You mean
with John? Wait, I'm sorry. I'm confused. I mean any adult sex
victimization. Do you discuss that it's any answer? No, I don't
believe I did. So this
god, I just realized
>> this guy is trying to basically >> I can't talk.
>> You know what sexual abuse is and you understand this
yet? >> Oh, do you think he she talked about like an incredibly
personal conversation he had with her? Like an incredibly like
vulnerable personal conversation to convince Do There's no way
he tried to play the hey, we both had like child sexual trauma.
Want to hang out? There's no way he played that card, right?
God, it h
I I just feel like in my head it was something that was super
personal. Like we could both we understand each other. It's just
gross. I hope not. I >> Why didn't you say this about techone
in my head?
>> Okay. Did you mention any sex abuse in this answer at
John's hand? >> That would be really just [__]
bizarre, man. I I
>> no believe I only put blank in there. Okay. At any point
in any of these records, do you discuss according to your testimony
this vicious these multiple vicious brutal course encounters
that you had with John? No. Okay. And again, this was just 2
months after the last July brutal oral sex victimization that
you had experienced and before I had it confined and got clarification
on what was going on. That's literally what this is all summarized
chat is this guy is really honing in on the fact that it was
just 2 months after the alleged brutal oral thing. She understands
what abuse is cuz she's had it before. Yet, for some reason,
she didn't say it when she was at Austin Oaks. She was texting
Techone the night before. She was texting Teone afterwards. They
were friends with benefits. So, how does it make any sense? And
you sent him that you want to suck his dicky.
But you had been through before. Is that fair? You were familiar.
Unfortunately, with what that looks like, with what that feels
like, the dynamics involved. It was very different. It was fullblown,
you know, crime.
>> Like, these are entirely
different things.
she's made it pretty clear that while this stuff was forceful,
it wasn't like a one-time
forceful violent rap. It It wasn't that. It was a coercive thing
where she didn't consent. She said no. She was pressured repeatedly,
right? There were other elements of course of control employed
here. Obviously, that's her point. Obviously, that's been the
point the whole time. I don't know. Maybe this again
>> the lawyer has to understand
and like that is very different. I understood like what is I
didn't fully understand like so pink is basically saying
>> so she says I didn't fully understand like assault I
think she's probably saying something like I didn't understand
like course of control and how that could like warp my view on
consent or assault. She was right. But she is not saying she
is saying that what Tekum did wasn't necessarily what she thought
was that what she thought what Tek was was assault and she didn't
really understand assault. Um so that's why she didn't say anything.
I think what I said is more accurate that she probably just didn't
understand that like she was probably minimizing the fact that
he was like disregarding her consent. the fact that he consistently
like was manipulating her to do this even when she um even even
things like when you realize that every time he's getting b it's
because you've refused to suck him off, right? Like stuff like
that, it's all pushing you towards doing the thing he wants to
do.
And and once she starts putting these things together, she's
like, "Oh, I was manipulated. I was taken advantage of. I was
actually assaulted in some of these cases. Like I straight up
didn't consent and he didn't care and still forced it." anything.
She understood what full-on is. She didn't understand what Tekk
did was wrong.
Okay, I want to pivot and I want to ask you about how you so
you were you're released from Austin Oaks. Is that correct? May
I have a moment? I'm sorry. Okay, my apologies.
You released from Austin Oaks and you and John continue. >> It's
actually so it's just so rough. Like it must have been so for
her to
have to go testify to all of this and
it's hard for me to get to what do you call it? It's hard for
me to get to
like I obviously can't make a huge deal out of people making
content out of it, but it does suck for her. Okay, I will admit
it sucks. I'm not going to apologize for like the job I do. This
is like actually my job, but it does suck that all of her personal
is being litigated and that like I I appreciate the courage it
takes to go through, you know, doing this knowing that it could
easily be made public in some way and and litigated out >> and
communicating. In fact, I believe he's listed blank. Yes, you
listed him as that. Sorry, I just I say that cuz I I think she
probably took a moment here
>> because that's where I was living at the time. So, probably
his residence. Okay. And you send John your patient access code
so that he can call up to Austin Oaks so that he can find out
more information. Is that fair? I don't remember if I did that.
Okay. If that's in those text messages, would you have any reason
to disagree with that? No. Okay. I want to fast forward to a
post that I believe you made on X. I think we can get formerly
known as Twitter by this point in time. Mrs. Lock, this is Pink
Chu's lawyer. Well, what's fun is what fun is that?
Pictures lawyer says, "What fun is that?"
Mr. Porier, who's uh Tech's lawyer, and this was on November
20th, 2024. You write on your Twitter. How are you supposed to
feel if a guy abuses and and makes you cry, then shove your head
on his crotch and demands that you suck him off and his excuse
is quote, "Emotion just turns you on when you cry." Or when you're
asking that you don't feel comfortable doing something and he
records you and demands you stop making faces and pretend you
like it. Or you say you don't want to do it anymore and he shoves
your head down until you throw up. Guilt trips you into believing
[__] and says do your job. You don't pay rent. I
took you to a water park and you still owe me and all you can
do is sleep up
stairs because you know what he's going to keep telling you what
to do. Do you remember making that post? Yes,
>> she did make that post. >> If you don't want to
be here for this dude, leave, please. Like get then stop watching
my [__] stream. If you're going to cry about this,
I just permit you. Get out of my stream. Like I'm sorry. We're
going THROUGH THIS. >> LET'S GO. >> WHAT ARE YOU
GOING THROUGH? SHUT the You >> You don't have to be here.
>> Get the [__] out of here. You don't like
the content? Go. Get the [__] Get out. Get out now.
>> Just leave.
>> Okay. This wasn't a private post, correct? It was on
an alternative account with a very low following. It was really
just for close friends and smaller fans, not like my main account.
So, this is Pink Chu on her old account. This is when she was
um she tweeted about Techone, but not saying his name, and everyone
knew about Techone and knew that it was bad. Well, it says Pink
and that's kind of your screen name. Is that fair? It's like
an alternative name, Pink Chow or something like that. Okay,
but fair to say in November of November of 20th of 2004, well,
before any of the exhibits that were entered into evidence, before
any of that, you make the allegation that John had abused you.
Is that fair, judge? I'm going to object. One, that's a mischaracterization.
And additionally, the best evidence are actually the text messages.
We don't even have them to know what they say. Any response,
judge? I think she's ratified through testimony that those were
her Twitter post. I think that is an evidence. All right. Objection
overruled, Mr. Poorier. a blank which is pink. I'm going to ask
you again November 20th of 2024 for any of those expositions
were posted that are in evidence now through your direct testimony.
Before that, you discussed John allegedly abusing you. I did
not say any names. I talked about a personal experience I had.
Okay. And very similarly again, I think we've established that
none of the posts that have been entered into evidence that John
had made mentioned your name in any way. Is that fair? The post
though that he does mention my name. Okay. Okay. But you would
agree with me that the allegations on your November 20th, 2024
Twitter post, they mirror the allegations that you made in your
application for a protective order.
It's a place where I can write down my personal feelings like
a journal without, you know, it's just personal thoughts.
Okay. Much in the way John communicates online. But wait, wait.
Oh, no. Wait,
hold on.
Sure, but that protective order wasn't public, was it? I don't
think any of that was public.
I do think when she just talked about it the first time that
that wasn't necessarily like all that bad right she did I think
when she starts talking about it she's obviously talking about
techone once she maybe this is the one trying to think November
20th was that where she talk starts talking about like getting
the [__] they did just read that maybe that one is
obvious okay >> but he uses >> that one was obvious
who she's talking >> sorry I'm saying like there were there
are posts where he uses my name it's a bad argument okay at the
risk of getting asked again and answered objection I'm going
to ask you again sorry My apologies. Can you point to me any
exhibit that is in evidence where John post your name? It's in
that binder. Does that count as the No, ma'am. Okay. The exhibits
that are in evidence. Okay. Not the ones that were shown. Correct.
So, fair to say that while you don't mention John's name in this
Twitter post on November 20th, 2024. Fair to say he doesn't mention
your name in any of the exhibits that are in evidence.
Just in the exhibits. Just in the exhibits. So there's nothing
in evidence says that Teone said anything with her name in it,
but it is everything in the exhibits that does. I'd say at the
time we weren't very public and then we became public. So I guess
what's highprofile I guess because like I think highprofile I
think of politicians or celebrities. Okay. Well, within the kind
kind of the relative scope of your sphere of influence online,
did most of your followers know that you were in the relationship
with Techone? Yes. Okay. Did most of Jon's from what you know
observed, did most of John's followers know that he was in a
relationship with you? Yes. In fact, it is exactly that relationship
and the impact that online rumors had on your business that served
as the bias of the lawsuit that you filed in Williamson County.
Is that correct? Thank you, Fan Dog TV, for the five get the
subs.
No, it's not. It's not exactly the same because she did those
uh behind closed doors. So, he's basically trying to say that
Fe was a bad person and she did these with the online rumors
and stuff. Um, but the truth is she filed this behind closed
doors, so it wasn't the same. Um, okay. But my question to you
is if you didn't have a significant online presence, there would
have been no significant online presence for Jessica to damage.
Yes. Would you agree with that? Yes. Okay. So, you would agree
with me that you had at least
>> people talking about bad things you've done actually
hurts your reputation online? Wow. Thank you. I'm glad we could
establish that. Thank is she an expert witness.
Wow, dude. guy talks in circles for significant online presence
enough that rumors online lies according to you disgusting lies
that were spread online could damage your image to the point
that you would lose endorsements business deals things like that
it's possible and in fact again that's what alleged in that lawsuit
fair yes okay so you knew the impact with even to borrow kind
of uh phrase of from your testimony you're small in comparison
to John's following the impact that lies of rumor or negative
comments could have on a business is that fair yes dude so his
lawyer is basically trying to say you know how bad it is and
how you can impact people online and what you you already have
a following that that can happen with. So imagine how techone
is because again that's the entire base of that lawsuit that
you filed. Okay, is that fair? Yes. Okay. And understanding that
in your sphere of influence it is well known that you were in
a relationship with John and understanding that in John's sphere
of influence it was well known that he was in a relationship
with you. You would agree with me that it's reasonable for that
those people upon reading that Twitter post would come to the
assumption that you're talking about him. Is that fair? Not at
first until he publicly stated it himself and he said that it
was about him. No, I think
she could say this and she might even maybe she even believes
it. I don't think that's true. I think people pretty quickly
connected it to
if you're like in a couple
and you're with like a big influencer when as soon as you talk
about you don't explicitly like cut them out of it, people are
just going to immediately connect those dots.
Now whether or not you believe that I don't know but that is
gonna happen every single >> I will say that Pinkchu I
think that everyone knew that it was about techone though and
I think people also knew it was about techone because we did
people knew about frame so I was like okay well this is obviously
about techone since his last girlfriend also had or his wife
had problems and left it's about tectone
you know like if you had someone tweeting about like Elno like
if Big Bird said Elno assaulted him and stuff like I don't know
if I can really believe that you know I I've actually tickled
Elmo's tummy many times when he didn't want me But tectone,
people were believing it for sure very quickly that it was about
Tecton and he did get a lot of attacks worth it.
>> It's the physiotomy. Okay. Physiotomy remains undefeated.
Tecton just looks like the guy that would do it. Okay.
Everything about this guy's face screams one thing at you. >> Um,
he sniffed on himself. True, he could have said that it wasn't
him, but we also don't know if Pink would have not said it's
about Tech.
Sorry,
it's just been a long court
All right, Mr. Teto, sit back down, please. We are in the court.
Court of Justice, please. Please. We're in the
Okay. Uh, here we go.
People that he had. Okay. Maybe some people, but not because
there was no clarification of who I was talking about or any
names, but your interaction in intention to posting that, it
was really for my friends, people that he had been trying to
isolate me from. But you would agree with me that you were free
to text message those friends. You were free to direct message
those friends. No, you couldn't just text them. I was I believe
I was ignored and blocked by many after we broke up. So Pink
is basically trying to say the reason why I said that was because
not because of of of trying to ruin Teone publicly. It's I wanted
to let people that blocked me see this and know that Teone is
a monster and that TeeOne was the problem, not me. Because Teone
probably went about and told everyone that Pink is a monster.
So when she goes out and says something, no one believes her.
We're going to be taking a quick break to your chat. Uh your
baiff right now, Chompy is going to be here. So you guys are
free to uh get up for a second. you guys had a thing exasperated.
I'm sure she did want to know because the truth is when you say
something without someone's name, especially when you just dated
and it's a very explicit thing, um people are going to probably
put two and two together. Now, granted, it was a
>> I hate to do this to him. Okay, I love you, Miz. Case
in point,
when Maya starts talking about her ex that used to drive the
car fast, okay,
when that happened, everybody was like, "Oh, Msk's a psycho."
Right? It didn't matter that she didn't say Msgiv. It didn't
matter that she made it like she didn't say his her last. She
like didn't really narrow it down at all. Everybody just went,
"Oh, Misk's crazy." >> Uh, you know, it was on a second
old Twitter, but those are usually more.
>> Uh, how can you make comments about his face when your
face is an avatar? Awesome take, man.
Uh, because I can say whatever I want. It's my stream. Problem?
Yeah. Techone has the physio of a He looks like a Neanderthal.
Yep. Boom. There it is, buddy.
Now, you can fight against that. If you disagree with something,
disagree with something. If you totally agree with the take,
I I wouldn't say 2 plus 2 is four. And then you're like, "But
you don't show me any of your math credentials." And I'm like,
"Well, do you disagree?" No. Then shut the up. Like, people knew
it was about Tee. Then Te went public and said it was him, but
it was pretty obvious it was Tect.
All right. And you can memorize any personal thoughts you had
in that journal. Is that fair? No. There's really not anything
personal. There's only two pages that were written of three.
Let's take a step back. Twitter is a social media. Yes. Correct.
Yes. The purpose of Twitter is to communicate with other people.
Yes. Okay. The purpose of Twitter is to communicate unless you
have a private setting with anything that looks at your profile.
Is that fair? Yes.
>> I look like in real life the penguin avatar that I'm
using. That's that's basically me right there. That penguin avatar.
Okay. >> And if you wanted to communicate with friends,
you could have used text message, email, direct message. It's
more complicated, I think. How? And this is a good point by his
lawyer, I would say, is that he uh you could say that you were
blocked by them and they wouldn't listen, but there was definitely
some kind of way they could have communicated, whether it's through
DMs on Instagram or Twitter, they probably didn't block you on
everything. So, I doubt that's not what happened. But, I mean,
she obviously was just lashing out and she doesn't want to say
that. Makes her look worse. Like, if somebody blocked you or
ignored you on don't doesn't want to get involved or scared to
reach out in a lot of awkward interactions. So, she's trying
to claim that it was awkward, so that's why they didn't she didn't
want to do that. So, it's your sworn testimony here today in
court that zero part of your motivation in posting that to Twitter
was set was to let the general public know what you experienced
with John. If I had to do with the personal experience I experienced
and I didn't want explicitly say names, were you talking about
John? He assumed I was talking about him. I didn't ask that.
I said, "Were you talking about John?" I'll remind you, you're
under oath. Okay?
I'm not listening to a bird with tanks.
Uh, you're welcome to come to Discord and say what any of the
takes are, but you're a terrified loser, so you won't do it.
discord.gg/jc.
Hop in the cord. Say what you disagree
Okay. She nods. She nods her head. So, you were talking about
John. And when you put it on social media, we can agree that
it's reasonable that people in the public, specifically business
association of John specifically, potential employers of John,
would see it. Is that reasonable? Is that possible? I didn't
think it was possible until he went public the next day. Like
I said, it was all Is your Twitter set to private?
>> Did anyone come in to defend TechOne? Not yet. But we're
still watching the whole thing. We're still going through the
whole transcript. So, >> no, but I put it on a small Twitter
page that's not many people could find and that was like an alternate
page with not many followers. Okay. If I represent to you, if
I present to you that4,000
people saw that tweet, that that's what reflected on your Twitter.
Was that before after he publicly made it public or publicized
it? I just ask you a question. Would you would that surprise
you? Miss Lock, who's uh pink shoes lawyer? Judge, I'm going
to object. The timing of the views in comparison to when it was
posted and the number of followers she had on that post. I mean,
he keeps talking about uh about he never names her. We're getting
ready to show the video where he specifically names Pink the
day after these messages. So, this guy's been talking in circles,
and I can just imagine Pink's lawyer getting more and more impatient
as this guy talks in circles. He's not saying anything. He's
a total,
right? Just keeps talking in circles over and over again. And
eventually Pink's lawyer is like, "We're about to show the video
where he he directs attention to the post. Can you like can you
just move it
Can you just move it the along, buddy? Make your point." Or her
lawyer is like, "Can we hurry this up? We already have evidence
that he literally names her perfectly. Like, why are we doing
this?" Um 7K viewers, low slow chat. Everyone's hate watching
the court. I mean, I agree. Asking how many views there have
been of this video now today is completely distorted. So, I mean,
you can ask a different question. How many
She knows. But the ask
>> Hold on. Is the chat slow? You know what usually gets
the chat going? If I play this right here, is this Would this
get the chat going a little bit?
>> Wow.
Sorry, that's um Oh, you're in Twitch chat. Hold on, Corby beats.
I'll show this for like a quick millisecond here. We've got like
a whole kick chat that's going like quite fast. Most of the audience
is on kick. On Twitch, we've got what 57 people on
We've got 539 right now. So, unfortunately,
the the Twitch chat does move slow. A lot of the community likes
to sit in the chat that's way bigger. So, unlucky, but I will
still interact with you if you're in the Twitch chat. Okay. Love
the Twitch chat. >> To reference it today is not that what
you're asking for, which is true. the the lawyer's bringing up
that it had 114,000 views as of you know a week ago when she
tweeted this 2 years ago. So many people could have looked at
it. It's completely different to what it was. Um and I don't
think that's very fair to use. I think it's fair to use after
the 24 hours before Tee talked how many views it had, but it
doesn't make sense to use after Tech talked about it and also
two years later. Okay, Mr. Porier, I agree with you, your honor.
By Mr. Porier Pink, let me ask you this in a different way. You
had more than one follower. Is that fair? We can agree on that
account. >> Um, actually, evil Johnny Bravo, I think I
could just make two sessions and have both of them play as long
as they're separated. I think the problem with Twitch is that
they don't like the mixed chat, which is stupid to me. I don't
understand why they don't like the mixed chat. I think it's that's
why a bunch of streamers have these like little separated chats
now is cuz Twitch will ban you if you mix the chats together,
which is just stupid when I literally have on my thing, this
isn't a mix chat, by the way. This is just my kick chat, but
it has all the kick icons, right? That's just my kick chat. And
by the way, if you only have kickat up, they will also ban you
for I forget what it is. They'll also ban you for any Twitch
vi any chat violations. But if you moderate your chat and you
show both at the same time, >> they're really all about.
>> So, understand that you were releasing information about
your situation with John to at least one person. Can we agree
you discussed this online prior to John discussing it online?
I did not at the time say anyone's name and it wasn't specifically
about him. Like I didn't know I'd have the purpose of it being
for people to know exactly who. It was really for close friends
of people in the space if that makes sense. I agree chat this
is boring as [__] It doesn't but you know what you
want to keep explaining. Miss Lock I'm going to object as vague
for the question. The court I don't know if this is vague. It's
definitely argumentative. So it's objection of sustained. The
court sides with techone despite the lawyer uh the lawyer from
uh Boo wherever the [__] he's from claiming that
it's all about uh one-sided with Pink. I'll move on your honor.
Bye, Mr. Porier. Pink. Uh again, can we agree you were talking
about John when you made that post? I had it was some of what
he done. Okay. Somewhat. Yes. Like it was like and you could
just testify that it was so you Yeah. I'm saying like it's not
everything is what I'm explaining. Okay. But the post was about
John. Yes. But not publicly stating anyone's name and not many
people knew exactly who it was about at the time. Okay. from
what I am aware of. Okay, very good. Mr. Porier, I will pass
the witness, your honor. The court. All right, Mrs. Lock. Yes,
judge. We are going to play what's been marked as applicants
47s. It is a one of the streams from November 22nd of 2024. So,
it will be the day following the tweet that was just being discussed
and so I move to introduce the subject to what we discussed before.
Any objections? No. >> I got a lot of [__]
to say and uh yeah, >> let's go. >> We we're going
to talk about all this. >> Okay. Uh, first of all, I'm
going to link you the Twitter post that I've made today.
Uh, if anybody wants to know what's going on, uh, I'm, uh, I'm
linking the tweet. Uh, and now I'm going to go ahead and read
it live on stream. Uh, we're probably going to have to read this
twice because I know a lot of people are going to be coming for
this later today and we're going to talk about all this [__]
Okay. Uh, I want to make one thing perfectly clear. I am keeping
note of everybody who is knowingly repeating lies with a reckless
disregard for the truth. Dude,
>> there's so many of these clips. Is this new? No. This
would have been up there. People would have known about this.
There's so many clips of him just repeatedly saying, "Everyone
else lied. I'm telling the truth. I'm going to sue you all for
defamation."
>> That's been his entire career since this happened, by
the way. >> And I cannot I can >> uh the Death Note
tech, the the LE tech never fails. Okay. >> I cannot stress
enough how dangerous that is. I cannot stress how dangerous that
is. big fan of the stream
>> as a world as a content creator. These people should
be ashamed. >> I will just say as a smallest as a very
tiny aside, Ms. GIF, for the love of God, just look at your OBS
audio levels ever once, please, for the love of God. People should
be ashamed. >> That's all
W meating
>> No, this is miss this time. >> No evidence whatsoever.
Believing guilty until proven innocent is disgusting.
And I'm going to talk about everything.
We're going to talk about all this [__] And once
again, good morning. We have the Hawkeye Star Rail dev live stream
in a couple of minutes and we're going to react to all that [__]
Uh I'm going to set the game to Hawkeye Star
and we're going to read all this [__] Okay, once
again, I want everybody
to do their due diligence, okay? When accusations like these
are made, it is of the >> So Tech purposely said he's going
to the Hong Kong Star really quickly. I There's one thing I'm
really good at, chat. It's reading people. I'm really good at
reading people because um I just it just I think it's like ADHD.
We just like evaluate everything about someone. So I'm pretty
good at reading people. >> and Teto obviously >> good
at reading people.
[__] Don't point out that he had all the same friends
as Gold like two years ago. Okay, hold on. I'm getting I'm I'm
coming down again. Calming down again. Hunk because he wants
to make this like this isn't a big deal and it's such a big deal
that I'm just going to go over this and then just get out and
we're going to go right back to this is basically just a small
break. Um so he does that on purpose and to make his viewers
think that this isn't a big deal. Pink lied and this has no effect
to my life whatsoever. >> Utmost important that people
wait to reserve judgment and wait until the facts have been laid
out. However, this [__] is insane.
All right, we're going to talk about this.
Dude, the
the self victimization stuff is also really crazy.
Um, like as a victim of assault myself, I just every time
as a victim of assault myself is like how he talks about anytime
he's feeling like a victim. It's it's just crazy.
Um, Pikachu puts him back in that in that place. Um, Hassan puts
him back in that place. Everybody puts them back. >> I
really want to make jokes about this situation because I'm [__]
up. However, I'm going to reserve the things that I normally
would joke about, which is crazy. Uh, I come back being singers
of war. I'm so sorry. Oh, don't worry. We're only starting this
phase four, boys. This is phase four. We have so many content
creators about show their true colors. Show their agenda against
me. It's going to be great. Yep. And I'm keeping track of all
of them. I keep You know what's crazy? I actually I actually
have a list. Yep. Uh, here's here's the one thing about me, guys.
I don't forget. All right. Uh, so legends. Okay. I'm not going
to reject, >> bro. How many times go full screen? Holy
>> That's fine. I'm going to read this right now. Okay.
>> It's so performative. Like, do you really care? cuz
you just keep having Dance Dance Revolution with your [__]
>> Many of you are aware by now pink.
My ex-girlfriend's accused me of number of things I can't let
go don't address. I've been accused of sexual assault, potentially
rape, prostitution, severe emotional abuse. >> Oh, so they
obviously can't use this in court as how many views the tweet
has when Tee the next day tweeted it like Yeah. I mean like you
can't really use that. That's not fair because Teone tweeted
the next day. >> I Is it even really the next day or is
it like the same night? Basically 4:55 a.m. he's pulling it up
on his screen, right? That's so sorry that's when he tweeted
it and then the stream is later in the day. He names her in the
tweet and on the stream >> accuse me of her statement is
a complete lie. Nothing about these accusations is true and they're
entirely made up. Out of respectation, I'm giving Pikachu two
weeks to apologize for these statements and acknowledge they
are false and inaccurate. If this does not happen, I'm going
to be pursuing legal action against Pingchu and those who knowingly
repeat her lies with a reckless disregard of the truth. Okay.
I have preserved everything. >> What a sweetheart. >> Guys,
I have preserved everything. >> I have preserved everything.
This is what he's been saying the whole time, right? This what
he was saying the whole time. I've preserved everything. Comes
with no text, no nothing. All like the best evidence he had is
just her medical records for somebody else from somewhere else.
Right? I have preserved everything. He just means the non-conensually
recorded. Okay? That's what he's preserved. He hasn't preserved
anything else for tax, nothing. Okay? >> And I'm more willing
to prove my >> I'm not going to lie, guys. I am a very,
very cautious man. >> That sounds in my opinion so like
>> I'm a very cautious man. And I'm a very, very cautious
man. That's why I told her to tell me that she wants to suck
my dick. Look. Proof that she's consented to sucking my dick.
Proof that she asked me to suck my dick. Look. Look.
Look. What's the XC voice? Look, look.
Like he was ready for this because it's like I'm a very >> It
dude it does feel like he's just expecting the allegations to
come. Uh it's it's brutal. Man, >> doesn't that come up
like I I knew this was going to happen one day, so I
You know what I mean? >> For progressive. But here's the
difference. When somebody says to me, "Hey, Techno, we're going
to view about you." I say, "Oh, hell yeah."
You want to know why? Because everybody else is doing that and
I'll be damned if I say no for a couple of free dollars. Hey,
hey, man. Hey, hey, I don't care. Now, I will say I will say
much to my credit. Um, it's even more so on, let me
this up, uh, YouTube. There's also companies like Ethereum Restart,
uh, which botted my video.
You heard that where he's like, "Oh, I don't care if somebody
view Yeah, give me the free money if somebody wants I'll never
say no to somebody viewing me." As he knows that Pink has evidence
of him
That's wild, man.
for 1.3
million views. As you can tell, a 1.3 million view video should
probably have more >> Oh, wait. So, he basically admits
right there that his views are bought on YouTube as well. Remember
when I said that yesterday that people were constantly seeing
his stuff? I was right. That was really accurate. He admits that
right there. Okay, I was >> I mean, the reason he they
were seeing it in your stuff was because he was targeting advertising
at you.
W Businessman, I guess. >> I'm a very cautious man. I am.
Guys, it sucks to say this, but I understand with my PR something
like this was only a matter of time.
What? You understand with your PR that Pink Chu was going to
say you assaulted her? It was only a matter of time. I'm going
to be honest with you, chat. I never in my life thought that
Emmy would go live and say what she said ever. Like, I never
thought in hundreds of hours of me sitting there uh pondering
this, having anxiety and not sleeping at night, I ever thought
the things she said would have been said.
why did you have anxiety?
Why weren't you sleeping?
What? I'm sorry that that part to me I you know what I'm not
going to ask >> because it was not a reality in my life
that I thought that she would say those things you know so like
I didn't have any I had nothing because I was like I >> to
be fair he could he couldn't sleep cuz he lost Emmy okay that's
why he couldn't sleep he fumbled the bag both literally and in
like the both in like the relationship sense and the money sense
cuz she's rich as >> when did this happen like what I I
had no clue but Tek's like I've been preparing for this for eons
like what >> he didn't mean it like that clearly. Well,
I think he means like he didn't think she'd do that. So, like
I I can tell you how Msk feels about it, right? Msk feels like
they both had abusive moments in that relationship
and that he he felt like at some point that it would be like
a tremendous betrayal
to go and use how that relationship went
to attack her, right? That's how he feels. And so, I think he
feels like on the flip side, I I wouldn't want to do that to
her. I can't believe she'd do that to me.
Um,
I don't know. I think uh, how should I put this?
I understand the sentiment.
I don't think it means that she shouldn't talk about it or couldn't
talk about it, but I understand the sentiment. The sentiment.
Okay, I get it >> And it sucks. But that is what it's like
being a man on the internet in 2024. People are going to come
after you. People are going to do this to you. And so I'm I'm
I'm I want to I want to emphasize this to my audience, guys.
You need to be careful,
guys. You need to be careful. I'm giving Pink two weeks. I'm
also more than willing uh I preserve all >> Wait, so he
said that if if she doesn't come back and say her things are
>> he did he did also say this week, he's going to basically
expose her and he never did. >> Videos during relationship
more than willing. Uh
>> say what you will about Miz, when he makes a threat
about dead bunnies, he follows through. Okay, Tactone, you're
a little when Msk said I'm going to post the bunny evidence if
you ever go if you ever put this make this public. He follows
through. Okay, Tone could never >> Sorry, I barely selected
because I'm just incredibly pissed off. I'm more than willing
to prove my court of law. I'm also more than willing to comply.
>> A noo document on a streamer on for techone just dropped.
Hi all, it's been a while. Some of you might have guessed my
complete absence from the internet, but I will not be returning
to gun to creation. I find myself compelled to talk about why
and this now due to the release of the court documents regarding
Tectone. Who is this?
Yeah. Who is this? What the?
>> Well, there many many reasons of my for my permanent
retirement from consecration. The primary one is that I know
that Tecton would never allow me to be free on my association
with him. I deeply regret my association with him. I blocked
all contact with Tecton around September of 2025 after Charlie
Kirk's
>> Oh, wait. Is this Bra?
>> No, Bra wasn't taking time off. >> Who is this?
>> Hex Juice.
The is Hex Juice.
This person, she's a VTuber. I need to confirm that this is from
someone that's a verifiable source before I read this and just
wonder what's going on. But this is pretty lengthy. >> A
nobody. >> It's on her YouTube. Hold on. Uh YouTube
Hex Juice. Hex Juice. What a weird name.
>> retriever puppy. >> Hex. No.
>> Shut up. Techone. Hex
Juice. Hex Juice. Hex Juice World. No. No. Not that.
Hex Juice almost 50,000 subs. We finally met Hex Juice. >> I
do want Hex to come on stream. I know she won't. And she also
told me to not ask her to do it. >> So I can ask. >> Yeah,
you can. >> I'll answer one, man.
>> Hex, you're finally here. Wait. Oh my gosh. He's here.
Will you come on stream or no?
Okay, come,
boys. Well, text.
>> Wow. Wow. >> So, what exactly is Hex Juice? It's
a really long and very strange story. And I don't >> Okay.
All right. Whatever. It's just
don't say it's a nobody. Don't say it's something that doesn't
matter. If it's someone that that that is saying this, we can
go we can we can look at this. >> Well, I is this an allegation
or is this just is this an allegation or is it just somebody
saying like
right? I think I think it's just somebody who's saying Teone
sucks.
>> You knew about this more than a year ago, but you continue
to respond and support Teone up until a month ago. You lying
sack of Yeah, you totally didn't say anything because you were
just pretending to be Tech's friend for
Damn, you liar. You were buddy buddy with Techone all the way
up until November 2020. Who the [__] are you trying
to fool saying that you had to keep up with a pretense of friendship
of Teone because he was unstable? If he actually wanted to blow
someone's head off, he would have just done it already. He literally
got a restraining order in August 2025. Here you are being friends
with him in November. Do you think we all have 100 minus 100
IQ?
Monkey.
Monkey. I don't know chat who this is from. So I'm not going
to. There's no >> that legitimate victims are questioned
and aren't for how. >> Let's go back to him talking about
it. >> And almost anything else. >> And it's because
of liars like Pingchu that weaponized trauma that legitimate
victims are questioned and aren't
>> Used to sweep for tactone. Well, that's what it used
to that's what she said, right? She was associated.
But I'm guessing it's Yeah. basically just saying like, "I don't
think this guy's a good person. I'm going to [__]
off. If if it's worth noting that Hex's girl is a lawyer or learning
law or is a psychologist or has a degree in psychology or something.
Well, that's a lot of different possibilities. Lazy Pink, what
the you gave me like 80 different options there. What the hell?
>> How serious these accusations are. I will not address
I will not discuss in any capacity until I am certain there's
no other path for and I'm for to pursue legal action. Clear my
name with these micious lies. >> Tech did not do that and
he continuously attacked and berated her non-stop. >> Thank
you to all my community for seeing me through this. He also supports
the world me going anywhere. My content will remain unchanged
as I've done nothing wrong and I will never let a lie stop me
from doing what I love. Guys, I'm not going anywhere. That's
what people want to happen. If you want to read the post for
yourself, you're more than welcome to. It's right here. >> You
can go. >> He left for eight months >> and read that
yourself. This is
>> He did leave, but it was after he got chased away. Wait,
eight months?
Has it really been 8 months? No, it's been like 3 months. It's
been like four months. >> Is this is abso fuckingutely
outrageous. I'm not going anywhere. I'm going to stream every
day. >> I don't have a YouTube career after this. Uh if
he wants one. Yeah,
I'll be honest. The right-wing grifting stuff doesn't really
stick to him that well. Like, it's just the one comment. We'll
see once we get eventually we'll get there in the transcript
to see what that is. But I don't think it sticks that hard unless
there's way better logs in this or way better lines in this transcript.
And like I sorry, I should be clear. He's obviously a right-wing
grifter. I'm saying his admission of that like people were advertising
basically that he said oh well I did direct redirect onto Hassan
even if that's like even if he says it like that there's ways
for him to talk through it and those people won't care about
the pinky stuff and anything that's in this transcript that could
be used to absolve him which is basically her saying to the intake
people at the hospital no I wasn't abused in the past six months
that's all they'll need to just keep
right like that all of his fans will see that and they'll go
oh I don't have to see anything else bye
So, I don't think this sticks to the right-wing group, right?
Maybe some of the VTubers are like, "Yeah, we don't put up with
that." Maybe some of the VT people, the gotcha fans, the VTuber
fans, maybe they'll peel off, but he's way bigger than like the
right-wing grift anyway right now. I would expect him to keep
going in that direction. >> I'm not going to end up like
these other when he comes back. Entire lives ruined over false
allegations. I will be here every day. I will be streaming every
day. This will not be another story of someone gets completely
[__] over by lies. Absolutely not. I love what I
do too much. I love my community too much. And this will not
be a repeat occurrence. Absolutely
not.
Absolutely not. You stop having girls in your house. Well, then
tell your mom to get out. She's already here. >> He thinks
that joke's so funny. He grabs his Canada drive fruit splash
thinking he's so funny. >> Dude, this got such insane hater
energy right now. Literally, Tech does anything. Techone switches
from full screen to like windowed view so he can look at the
tweet. This loser isn't even taking this serious. He keeps switching
cameras. He picks up his [__] drink to take a drink.
This stupid [__] Canada, dude.
This is the best part of the stream. He just hates every atom
in this guy's body. Everything about this guy, he hates. I love
it. I love it. and his cringiest who has the uh humor levels
of a a broken down car already before he even finished the joke.
Hakuna soy. Of of course he has hakuna matata soy in his name.
Puts a laughing emoji like that dancing like he literally they
didn't even finish the joke and he's like cringely drinking his
Canada dry
like and then he's already got someone look look at
>> he's cringely drinking his Canada dry. Oh, I love it.
>> Not going to lie, lawyer up is the best move. You think
I already have a team of lawyers? You're just gapping. Guys,
I cannot stress to you I am a very very cautious, very very paranoid
man.
I have had a target on my back for years >> Him saying
this stuff kind of also cooperates with the fact that Pingchu
said that he made him text message stuff to her. You know, him
saying that >> I have had a target on my back for
>> I need to hear Miz has said this word a couple times
this exact way. I just need to make sure I hear it correctly.
>> Him saying this stuff kind of also cooperates with the
fact that Pink >> Yeah, he's definitely Elmer Fdding that
word 100%. who said that he made him text message stuff to her.
You know, him saying that he was cautious and he was a protective
man and stuff like that and that like he he knows this stuff.
Like it makes it sound really bad that he's like kind of he he
know he knows he needs to protect himself. You know what I mean?
Why would you need to do all that if you never did anything wrong?
Like I really didn't know Emmy was even coming out with the she
said. I just was assuming she came out with something. I didn't
have anything to say really because I was like what the [__]
This is just so random. Um Techone seemed to be very much ready
for anything which is
to where anyone can make up a lie about me and people will believe
it. If you think that I didn't see this [__] coming,
you are gravely gravely
Gravely, gravely mistaken.
We're going to handle a ship. You think I didn't see it? What
did he see coming
that you had like a messian relationship and
ah, it's one of those things, man.
You sum up the drama for people with jobs. Um,
has been found liable for assaulting and stalking his ex.
He is very upset about this. He's got a lot of his friends are
trying to sweep for him and they're pointing to this transcript
now and some places where basically his um his ex has testimony
that conflicts in some ways, not in ways that are difficult to
understand, but in ways that if you're like intentionally trying
to take that side, you can definitely use to do so.
And
where do we go from there? Yeah. So, basically found liable for
assault and stalking, got a protective order for 10 years, and
he's upset about it. He can't talk about her anymore.
And basically, a bunch of people like Ms. Kiff are dancing on
his grave,
reading all the documents, dancing on his grave, enjoying enjoying
a good life. Really, nobody has earned getting like over like
this. Nobody has earned
getting what the the shot in fraud, okay? Nobody's earned it
at the level Techone has in a long time. Like it's just like
everybody feels good. It's like the Pirate Software thing, right?
Except more deserved. Maybe less like less instinctual and more
just deserved
>> Just everybody's like, "Yeah, this guy this guy does
deserve this. He actually does deserve this."
>> Everybody who preserve judgment
uh until proof is provided. Thank you guys. I appreciate the
[__] deal.
Dating is so dangerous as a content.
>> Uh, the noticeable part should be nobody else in the
React circle seems to really be touching it apart from XQC.
Wait, who else would touch it that's not? Asmin Gold. I'd say
like Asmin Gold's avoiding it. He's kind of got an out with the
with the court case maybe. Although, now the documents are out.
Asmin Gold should be able to just read it by himself. And I'm
guessing we'll see some Asmin Gold reactions to the legal mindset
stuff. We'll just have to see exactly. I think I still we still
have to get through this whole thing. Okay, we do still have
to go get through this whole thing. And
as it is right now,
I definitely think if if there's no new facts here at all, if
there isn't something like totally devastating for Techone, like
like basically proof that he kept the revenge, I do think this
is like sweepable by Asmin Gold, it's just about whether or not
whether or not he wants to take the hit to do it. Like I personally
don't think this is like cool. I think Teto's a total piece of
[__] But realistically,
this could be sweepable for like that audience. It's just about
whether or not he wants to do it.
And there's nothing, just to be clear, there's nothing preventing
him from doing it, right? There is nothing preventing him from
reading these documents absent miskf.
So if he tries to put it on miz, now legal mindset is the same
documents. There is no excuse. There's no dodging miskf excuse
anymore. Okay.
Emiru. Is Emiru a reactor? I don't think Emir is a reactor. Emiru
doesn't do like long-term lots of react content in my
>> Other than that, I feel like a lot of other people just
don't really um it's like a lot to go through right now.
>> I don't know. >> Keep watching. >> The problem
is, and I'm just going to be
>> there is a reason why, and I don't want to go into this.
What was your immediate reaction when everyone went live about
>> Oh, [__] Was basically it.
>> I'll just say
if I knew two to three weeks before that happened, not even two.
Yeah. Like if I knew two weeks at least before that happened
that Amir was going to go live and basically say almost exactly
the she said Misk had to have known, right? Like Asmin Gold was
straight up styling on this guy. He's doing he's hitting the
gritty on stream every day being like, "Miz, your time's ALMOST
UP. MIZ, I'M COMING TO GET YOU. MIZ, GET READY FOR THE PAIN."
RIGHT? As goal's going nuts on stream every day taunting Msk.
It's like, well, I know something's coming. He couldn't have
been that shocked about it, right? cause people to speculate.
But there is a reason why I am so
needing of someone uh
who can share the same bed with me uh for reasons. Uh but it
has a lot to do with uh how my brain functions unfortunat >> who
can share the same
>> no way >> of someone uh
who can share the same bed with me uh for reasons uh but it has
a
>> oh share the same bed okay okay >> with uh how
my brain functions unfortunately so that's what kind >> doesn't
that also with her story that she that he would want her to sleep
with her all the time but she wanted to sleep
This issue is that when we got together, I was underneath extreme
duress due to prior circumstances that caused me to jump into
a relationship uh without being uh too careful. Unfortunately,
>> it is what it is. >> Now, I am going to >> we'll
say the new >> it's him saying he can't sleep alone because
of his schizophrenia. That's what he's talking about after this.
>> We're going to move forward and you know what? Every
now and then we might make a pit stop, but at the end of the
day, um we're just going to continue. Oh, so this person Hex
Juice reposted this six hours ago about tecton.
Oh, I'm kind of interested to see this. We're kind of at a middle
point now where we're at pink juice thing. Okay, so this person
Hex Juice is saying I I feel like I'm going to just skip this
if you guys don't mind. I like listening to Miz Reed because
it saves my voice, which is kind of right now.
So I I I'm sorry, Miz. I am going to kind of rely on you to read
and me to just react to the stuff as we go through
I yeah my voice is really about techone
damaging association with techone they especially while feel
just put in the chat GPT
chat GPT sum up this yapping for me >> techone was lying
to her the whole time all right moving on so let's get to Mrs.
lock who is uh pink shoes lawyer. So we got through the lawyer
that is uh techones and we are now on to Pink Choose.
So this is a redirect. Okay. So this is basically Pink Choose
lawyer came in asked her some questions. Then there's the cross
which is the other lawyer can ask their own questions or follow
up and then Pink's lawyer will get another chance to ask her
get clarifications on anything that they need to clarify and
then it will go back to one final redirect. I think one final
is it called recross? I can't remember. >> All right. So,
we went through and we watched it where techone said that. Did
you notice the comments that were going on the side? Did you
have a chance to look at any of those? And if you didn't, that's
okay. >> Yeah, I didn't read them all. Prior to this video,
you had you made the allegations against Mr. Roberts public.
I had made a tweet without explicitly saying anyone's name. Okay,
let's actually let me pull up that tweet because I think it's
already in evidence. You made they made reference to the medical
records from Austin Oaks. You did not write or fill out that
paperwork, right? No. Okay. And they the nurses filled it out
for you. Yes. All right. And in there you did. You also make
reference to blank as uh causing your stress. I'm not entirely
sure if it says it in there. Okay. Let's go over the records.
And so the court is clear. You sued Mr. Robertson's ex-wife?
You sued Mr. Robertson's ex-wife, right? Yes. And you sued her
based on statements that she was allegedly making. Correct. Yes.
And those were the statements that opposing council highlighted.
Yes. Okay. And what were the statements that she was accusing
you of making that? Do I go into detail? What was because in
your lawsuit that Oh, more than just that section. Yes. Okay.
Just in that section, she was accusing him of grooming me as
a slave. Okay. It was his ex-wife that was making those allegations
in a public form, right? She was telling that >> what?
Oh, Miss just ended his stream.
Just got
Hold on. Where we go? Where are we going here? I got to refresh.
God damn it. His lawyer sucks because if his lawyer was smart,
his lawyer would have told him to never the idea that John was
grooming you or that you were his slave or that was the base
of your relationship. Free would tell you and
>> right before you filed your lawsuit
right on multiple she was telling that of that she was at recording
of me. Okay, I guess to stop that. I sued her.
>> So,
she was telling that privately to people is the last thing. Okay.
And you sued her, I guess. >> So, she wouldn't show any
more videos or like to make sure that she wasn't didn't have
access to the footage that she was at recording of me. Okay.
So, but it wasn't you making those statements about Mr. Robertson.
It was his ex-wife. Yes. Let me finish my question. Oh, sorry.
It's all right. And that was actually a settlement, correct?
Yes. And he receives payment from his ex-wife. Is that right?
Yes. All right. And there were some injunctions that you all
can't talk about each other publicly, right? Yes. And Mr. Robertson
had made reference to an NDA right on multiple platforms. Oh.
Right. Yes. And without going into the details, that NDA relates
to a lawsuit between his he and ex's wife post divorce. I believe
it was an agreement they made. Okay. It was an agreement. Yes.
And there was some NDA sign related to them not being allowed.
Judge, I'm going to object to speculation. I can ask her. I can
rephrase.
If she doesn't know, she doesn't know. She can ask the question.
All right. Did Mr. Robinson tell you about this lawsuit? He told
me that he
wait. Hold on. Would that NDA apply to like a new partner? Cuz
is are they about to ask like detective and desist, paid her
$30,000 and had her sign an NDA not going to the public? Exactly
what I said. And this was right before you filed your lawsuit
against her. Is that right? I believe after he had signed her
NDA and paid her, I then we had our spat and I sued her. Okay.
Was this was this that at this encouragement to sue her? He encouraged
a lot for me to sign an NDA and to keep all of it under wraps
due to the allegations the ex-wife had. He didn't want those
going public. Okay. Did you also lose a dog during this time
before you went to the Austin Oaks? Yes, my family dog. But it
wasn't just your breakup. You had other issues with regard to
why you went to Austin Oaks? Yes. Does going to Austin Oaks make
any amount of your allegations or accusations against Mr. Robertson
>> I'd like to think she's actually instead of making eye
contact with Pink while asking this, she's looking directly at
his lawyer, Teetones lawyer, and asking these questions. >> No.
Okay. Is there any reason why you didn't give detailed information
in the Austin Oaks records about what was going on with Mr. Robertson?
I just wanted to get an evaluation and leave. That's why I was
only there for 3 days. And you in fact did not return to live
back at Mr. Robertson's place. Is that correct? No. All right.
And then in these are the tweets that Mr. Robertson, I'm sorry,
the opposing council was talking about. Is that right? Yes. All
right. Can you point out where in this you provide Mr. Robertson's
name? Nowhere. Can you provide a time frame of when this occurred?
No. And did he make a reference to this specific tweet in his
rantings online? Yes, all the time. Or a lot of the time, I'm
sorry. And did he refer his followers to this tweet? Yes. You
heard in that video back on November
>> November 22nd where he said, "It's war now." Do you
recall that?
>> So cringe.
He's so cringe. There's so many of these things. He genuinely
thinks he's like an anime character. It's so gay. He like thinks
he's an anime character. He talks all of this all the time. >> And
what has he done into your life since he made that statement
on November 22nd, 2024, which is the video we just
He completely destroyed my streaming career. Barely ever stream.
I had to comply completely switch to another platform to for
content and to make money. How did he destroy your streaming
career? No one wanted to get near me because he would attack
them too. And he had already done that to some people. An example
is her name's Morgan. People didn't want to associate with me
or collab with me. So, I actually ended up having to fly out
to LA a lot to make friends or cooper collaborations to help
my career.
>> Morgan,
that couldn't be Morpai, could
>> There was reference to a text message that you sent
him asking him for a [__] right before you went to
Austin Oaks. Do you recall that? Yes. All right. Can you explain
to the court how that text came to be? Are you talking about
the blowing, >> dude? God, that just sounds so weird.
Are you talking about the blowing?
>> So, I had tried to originally confine in a girl
>> that was a mutual friend.
>> Froggen. Oh, wait. There's no way it was Frogan. Really?
Is it really Frogan?
>> Well, that's crazy. >> And when
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Oh, what? Wait.
There's no way that he picked to go. so hard on No, Froggen was
really, really, really
I can't believe that he would attack Frogan because she was friends
with or collabed with.
I can't I can't believe that.
Plus, there's no collab, right, that I know of. Why would she
shoots like um only not only fan stuff like uh nude stuff, but
she shoots like LWD content? Why would she collab with her? >> There
was reference to a text when I don't blow. So I tried to originally
confine in a girl that was a mutual
>> We call it blowing about the blowing. Yes. So I had
tried to originally confined in a girl that was a mutual
>> Okay. And when was that? Why do we call it blowing when
we don't blow?
So true. So true. So true. >> Sorry. When I don't blow.
So I tried to originally confide in a girl that was a mutual
friend. Okay. And when was that? When did you try to confine
her? I believe it was possibly a week before that text or I don't
remember. Okay.
It was a little bit after the first time we broke up. Okay. Then
what happened? I told her that we would make uh he would make
me give her uh him [__] and she freaked out. And
I'm like, "But it's all fine. It's not a big deal." And then
I got scared because I didn't know if I could trust her. And
he then the next day sat me in his office and sat me in a chair.
And he's like, >> "The whiteboard. Is this where the whiteboard
comes out? I'm going to get I'm going to get on the phone. I'm
going to step out inside and out. And he stepped outside of the
office and he said, "You're going to tell me everything you told
her in detail and I want you to know if you're lying and we're
going to have her sit on the phone and back and forth and find
out all the information. You're going to text me that you want
to suck my dick."
No shot.
No shot that they brought this up. There's no way on earth that
they brought this situation up on Teone side. And this is the
actual backing evidence that she texted him that because
he heard that she told a friend that he forced her to give him
[__] and he's like, "You're going to text me right
now that you want to suck my or I'm never talking. I don't trust
you. I can't." There's no way, right?
You're We're all following that. Yeah.
There's There's no way that they brought this up and tried to
like sneak this in and this is the actual story behind it. Get
the out of here, >> dick. Or else I'm gonna not trust you.
How tall is Mr. Robertson? 6 feet 6 or seven. How tall are you?
5'3. How much to the best of your knowledge does Mr. Robertson
weigh? I believe it's like 260 somewhere around there. And what
is it? I know no one wants to talk about your weight. What is
it? You
>> You think there's any way that like is it possible that
like
cuz I I feel like in regular court you have to show the exhibits
before you go to court, right? you get time to deal with it.
Is it possible that they don't know? No, they have to know what
the other side has,
I feel like you usually have to share that stuff before you actually
go in front of a judge cuz otherwise gets really with objections
and you just waste time. How How did they bring this up?
How did they try to bring it up like the way they did?
>> Oh, it looks so bad, man. >> Okay. When he had
you, >> Dude, that looks so bad for the judge. Think about
how bad that looks to the judge that she's listening along. She's
hearing the story from Tee's lawyer and then this is the other
side of that story and if they have the text to the
like you're
>> in that chair in the office. >> What was his demeanor
towards you? >> Very angry. Did it cause you any
Uh and the text he was showing everyone as proof she is lying.
Wait, what do you what do you mean actually? And call me on that.
Uh, and that's the text he was showing everyone as proof she
is lying. Yeah. Oh, like this is the text that um Oh, was Techone
showing this to other people?
Oh, maybe that comes out later. Axian in the side chat is saying
and that's the text he was showing everyone as proof she was
lying. So when when people would say, "Wait, is she is she lying
about this?" And he would go, "No, no, no, no. Look at this text
she sent me begging to suck my dick."
Bro, he's an actual psycho.
Ah, he's an actual psycho. is crazy.
There's no [__] way, dude. There's no [__]
way. >> Yes. Action.
>> Action, are you there? Hello.
>> We have another witness chat coming in. >> Yo.
Yo. So, that that text that she had that he had her send him
>> is what he was showing everyone to be proof like, "Oh,
she's lying. Look, look, she want to suck my dick all the time.
Look at this."
>> And he sat her down and made her write
>> Mhm. Mhm. So he was going around >> his proof.
Yes. >> That was his big proof that he had that was that
was it. >> That she was lying. Yes. That was his proof
because she he made her send that >> Interesting. Interesting.
Okay. All right. Well, thank you for joining the courtroom. I
appreciate it. >> Yep. Anytime. And you Missy Wizzy? >> Yep.
Sorry about that. I mean, uh, thank you very much. I appreciate
that. Okay.
>> All right. Bye.
>> Order. Hey,
just because one person spoke doesn't mean everyone can't order.
Assistant, she was a friend, a mutual friend of ours to go with
me to the domain instead of concerns. I
>> Russell, sit down. Not now. Do not
Okay, we're back.
Did it cause you any concerns? I was just terrified that he was
going to say too much and might he might do something. I don't
know. I was just kind of scared. Okay. And then how long after
before did you confine in someone else about having the events
that occurred during your relationship? Him and this other girl
went to an anime convention. I asked my new assistant, she was
a friend, a mutual friend of ours to go with me to the domain
that I just needed somebody to talk to. I could find it in her
some of the things he had, you know, done. And I told her that
we've never had
that he would only make me give him [__] And she
was just really worried. and uh me and her have become best friends
since then. She's helped me through a lot.
So, Techone left for a convention with somebody who is I don't
know who that is. And then she started talking to her assistant
uh who then became her best
>> She starts having this regular discussion with somebody.
She's like, "So, what's your relationship like?" Right? Her assistant's
like, "So, what's your relationship like?" She's like, "Oh, it's
like kind of good, but this is weird." And she's like, "What's
weird about it?" Well, he's never touched my a single time. Like,
oh, wait, wait, what?
>> Uh,
and was like, "What the?" And I know you had some sexual assault
in your past and you said that you knew that was assault and
I know the last thing you want to do is go into it, but can you
just tell the court briefly what happened with that so the court
understands what the distinction was in your head?
He had gone to the hospital for an injury, he told me. asked
me if I could help him into the bathroom. We went to the bathroom.
He then pulled down my pants and ripped me as I cried and told
him no. >> Jesus Christ.
>> And that was your boyfriend at the time when you were
about in your early 20s? Yes. Okay. And that was what you determined
as
Yes. Okay. And you actually followed up with the proper authorities
and everything for that. Correct. Absolutely. So basically what
she is saying is
>> that that very much that's like what she thought was
the line for reporting somebody to the cops. >> The reason
why she didn't think tech was bad was because that is like serious
and what techone she felt was not and therefore it wasn't anything
of seriousness. So therefore she didn't say anything that's not
techone. Let's make that very clear. That is her ex-boyfriend
from 10 years ago.
>> He tried to murder. And what is the difference than
what Mr. Robertson was doing? Yes, he tried to murder
us out of guilt on a highway at one point. It was very intense.
That was not Mr. Robinson. That was No, no, no, not Mr. Robertson.
That was the other person. So, that was an extreme event. Extreme
events for you. >> Um, yes. And those are all in the police
record. Did uh because he was 5150 for that. What does that mean?
What does 5150 mean? >> Uh, involuntarily committed for
that. She probably was like, "This guy just tried to kill me
and kill himself. Get him away
and say, >> "Listen, I just I just there for a reason."
Okay. >> But that is different than what the actions that
Mr. Robertson took with you. Yes. >> Uh it's not quite
the same thing though, Nemo. It's not quite the same. >> That
was >> at all. It's actually
I don't believe that Miz was trying to do the same thing. It's
like a funny joke maybe, but
uh the just the >> position is that I'm sorry. Let me Mr.
Robertson had you engaged in behaviors against your behaviors
against your will. Is that right? Yes. And it occurred on multiple
occasions? Yes. And you still believe that a protective order
is necessary for your safety and protection? Yes. And you're
asking the court to grant it today? Yes. Please. I passed the
witness. Mr. Porier, nothing at this time, your honor. >> Bro,
I don't know how you don't recross
Like I you just got blown the out and you just leave that as
the record that you basically gave this total. Like if they just
disagreed, couldn't they just say maybe he's waiting to go to
Techone so Tech can dispute that? I don't know how you let that
go. I feel like you're
oh one of the the biggest pieces of evidence for you. One of
the best pieces of evidence you had just got completely blown
up and you're like, "Yeah, I'm I'm good now. I'm good." >> All right.
Thank you for your testimony. You can join your attorney at the